So, was ist hier mit unseren Rolls-Royce-Portasten?
Ja, meine geht nicht.
Der Vadert schon wieder, der Dennis, ne?
Naja, der Vadert so ein bisschen rum, ne?
Gar nicht.
Bist du eigentlich mein Vater, Dennis? Also, bist du jetzt mein Vater oder nicht, Dennis?
Hm, glaub nicht.
Dafür bist du zu alt.
Auf jeden Fall muss ich mich mehr eräuspern, damit David mehr Sample-Material hat, glaube ich.
Naja, Jungs, wir müssen uns benehmen, denn wir haben einen Damenbesuch. Ja, wir haben nämlich einen Überraschungsgast und ich begrüße Winnie. Hallo, Winnie. Du hast doch dein Trademark-Intro auch gleich mitgebracht.
Ja, das gehört dazu.
Ja, super. Ansonsten auch alle anderen da. Dennis, Buckel, Max, Tach und Icke, Tim. Und das Ganze ist Mobamex.
Und das Ganze gab es steckt zur Pizza.
76, es gab steckt zur Pizza und es gab überhaupt Pizza?
Irgendwas knackt.
Irgendwas knackt. Ich glaube, das war ich wahrscheinlich. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, es knackte heute schon mal und irgendwas ist im Busch.
Im Kabelbusch?
Irgendwann atmet es auch zu sehr und Steve Jobs ist tot und es ist überhaupt alles total. Es sind einfach Zeiten.
Steve Jobs ist tot?
Ich glaube, Max, du bist jetzt gerade derjenige, der rein atmet.
Ich atme gar nicht insofern.
Ja, hör mal auf zu atmen. Das hat mich schon immer so gestört. Dass du die ganze Zeit atmest.
Toll, danke.
Wie hell hält man das nur mit dir aus?
Du hast mich eingeladen und ich dachte, ich schaue mal einfach vorbei.
Das stimmt, das hast du ja gut gemerkt. Ich dachte, wir könnten hier mal ein bisschen die Runde ein bisschen aufmischen, ein bisschen bunte Farbe reinbringen. Deswegen haben wir jetzt Besuch aus München. Der eine oder andere Hörer dürfte dich auch schon mal gehört haben, denn du wanderst ja auch so durch verschiedene Podcasts. Ich habe auch deine Webseite nachgeblättert. Du hast ja schon so einiges probiert. Aber jetzt bist du ja im Mainstream angekommen und machst Fernsehen.
Ich mache Fernsehen und Podcasts.
Ihr quatscht doch jetzt über Serien oder nicht?
Das war jetzt der Plak. Ja, ich mache jetzt ein Serien-Podcast mit dem Uli.
Total cool, es macht Spaß.
Der heißt?
Wiederholungstäter. Also, Webseite wiederholungstäterpodcast.de.
Sprecht ihr da nur über so Zeug, was im Fernsehen kommt? Oder sprecht ihr da auch über...
Auch, was man auf DVD kaufen kann.
Was man auf DVD kaufen können wird.
Oder was im iTunes-Store verfügbar ist. Oder auf Holo oder sowas.
Wenn du das so formulieren willst, ja, das geht auch.
Jetzt kennt Dennis das auch.
Jetzt ist immer die Frage, ob man es gucken soll.
Das heißt, wenn eine neue Serie herauskommt, wie sagen wir, American Horror Story, dann redet ihr darüber?
Gegebenenfalls, ja.
Wie gegebenenfalls?
Wenn uns die Serie zusagt.
Redet nicht über die schlechten Serien?
Bis jetzt noch nicht.
Wieso nicht?
Das ist doch...
Im Moment haben wir noch genug Material mit guten Serien. Wir sind ja noch am Anfang.
Ich finde, über schlechte Sachen schlecht machen ist doch immer das Beste eigentlich.
Ja, das kommt mit Sicherheit auch.
Also Dennis wäre gerne mal Gast und möchte ein bisschen ranten.
Nee, aber wir hatten ja auch schon mal so eine Sendung über Filme und meine Idee war eigentlich unsere nächste Sendung wäre entweder über Filme, Musik oder über Serien. Und damit, da müssen wir wohl über Musik machen.
Du kannst auch gegen Podcasts machen. Du kontinuierst ja bei anderen Podcasts auch.
Hört schon eigentlich.
Wir haben die alle platt gemacht, oder?
Ich warte ja schon seit Ewigkeiten darauf, dass ich mal irgendeinen Schauspieler treffe, in der Hoffnung, ihm einfach sagen zu können, ich kenne dich aus dem BitTorrent.
Kirsten Dunst lebt ja angeblich jetzt in Berlin.
Deine alte Flamme.
Das ist Lux aus Virgin Suicides.
Die hat doch mal bei Spider-Man mitgespielt.
Die hat auch mal die Freundin von Spider-Man, aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Ach, diese rothaarige?
Nee, die ist blond. Das ist die von Melancholia.
Oh Gott, ich hab echt schon so lange keinen Film mehr geguckt.
Du bist so raus.
Ja, ich auch. Serien-Podcast ist eher was für mich.
Schlimm, schlimm, schlimm.
Habt ihr schon Episodes besprochen?
Wir machen auch nur über eine Serie jede Folge. Wir machen nicht über Programme, mit denen du striken kannst.
Verstehe, ihr wollt einen längeren Podcast machen.
Nein, aber Episodes ist eine Serie.
Deswegen war ich jetzt... Ich find die ganz schrecklich, ich hab die erste Folge gesehen.
Ich hab fünf Folgen am Stück gesehen und die anderen beiden ein paar Tage später.
Ich schlacht dabei ein.
Das war großartig.
Na gut, wir sollten mal wieder mehr über Max reden. Was passiert? Es gibt in der Tat Entwicklung. Wir berichten jetzt live von dem Platz der 1000 Möglichkeiten, wo alles Wichtige gesagt wird zu diesem Thema. Warte mal. Ich muss hier nochmal kurz mit der Technik... Hallo, können wir mal kurz das Band einlegen?
Es geht gar nicht um Steve. Ich weiß jetzt worum es geht.
Ist doch schön oder?
Wo ist der Button? Wir brauchen jetzt noch den Button. Voll schlecht vorbereitet, Jungs. Er hätte mich einweihen sollen.
Aber jetzt müsstest du eigentlich so ein verzerrtes Sample machen.
Den Schuss und die Explosion dann irgendwie so mit ranschneiden.
Ist alles zu leise hier. Ja, ich brauch hier ein besseres Mischpult für diese Programme. Das ist ja mein Begeher schon seit Langem, dass du einfach auf dem Mac, gibt es einfach keinen Mixer. Windows hat das. Windows 7 hat das. Da kannst du jedes Programm einzeln abmixen und auf diesem scheiß Macintosh...
Wenn du jetzt nochmal Kalender sagst, dann fertigerenst du den Hunk alleine.
Ich sag nur SYNC. Also entschuldigung, eigentlich wollten wir reden über...
Oh Gott, das hat doch nicht mein Flash verdient.
Wir wollen über Flash reden.
Wir müssen ja über Flash reden. Adobe hat aber als eigener Seed, dass sie keine Chance haben. Ich bin mir nicht so richtig sicher, ob es...
Flash for mobile ist tot.
Ja, es ist vorbei. Ich meine, dass es einfach das Eingeständnis ist, dass sie auf dem Zukunftsmarkt der Technologie nichts bewirken. Und dass sie jetzt sozusagen so Legacy Plug-In fahren.
Das ist jetzt so, der Weg hat sich ja an einer Kreuzung oder an so einer Gabelung aufgespalten. Und man sieht auch gleich, wer die falsche Abzweigung genommen hat, oder? Weil RIM, nämlich?
Die armen Schweine.
Die müssen jetzt weiter Flash for mobile koden. Also sind eindeutig falsch abgebogen, würde ich sagen. Die haben das Schild nicht gesehen.
Totale Unis sind das.
Ich dachte ja schon, ich hatte ja schon gedacht, dass die in ihrer neuen Mobile-Plattform auch Flash drinnen gehabt, oder als Main-Plattform Flash drinnen hatten. Aber offensichtlich hat da eben jemand rechtzeitig vorher Bescheid gesagt, dass das nicht mehr kommen wird. Weil die haben ja ihr neues Betriebssystem, ihr neues Handybetriebssystem quasi angekündigt, wo sie jetzt die Entwickler darauf einspüren wollten.
Bei RIM jetzt? Bei RIM, ja.
Und da dachte ich, naja, ist das jetzt auch noch eher? Und? Nee, ist es nicht. Also es war schon nicht mehr in der Präsentation drin. Zumindest ich hab mir hier ein paar Folien da angeguckt. Aber ich sah mir ehrlich gesagt auch so ein bisschen aus, als ob wir das relativ kurzfristig rausgeflogen seien. Aber das ist jetzt keine Spekulation.
Die sind ihr Schlechtspartner aber auch wirklich ein paar Monate.
Nee, haben wir jetzt das eine Betriebssystem? Wir haben jetzt hier schon genug Serien geplagt.
Ich bin im Fernseher nicht gut.
Serientäter?
Wie ist denn das bei Grey's Anatomy?
Wiederholungstäter? Ja, Wiederholungstäter. Ja, jeder mit jedem.
Gucken.
Ich glaub du willst Grey's Anatomy gucken.
Das ist schon eine Mädchenserie.
Naja, vielleicht wird das ja auch mal was für mich. Wer weiß. So ja, bei Computern hat's ganz generell sehr gut ankommen.
Willkommen bei Kalender-Apps und Mädchenserien.
Wenn du so aufs Bild einrichtest, mal in den Teilen ansehen, das ist voll mit Ponys und Einhörnern und so. Und das sind nicht nur Frauen.
Sondern auch Einhörner.
Ja, genau, ich folge auch Einhörner.
Mut zur Metrosexualität.
Ja, genau. Bleiben wir bei Flash. Also ich glaube, das war's. Ich meine, ich bin schon immer davon ausgegangen, dass er eh keine Zukunft hat und wer da jetzt seine Zeit mit vergeudet selber schuld ist. Aber jetzt wird es halt einfach deutlich, weil was sie im Prinzip gesagt haben ist, wir haben keine Zukunft.
Wir haben versagt.
Ja, was heißt wir haben versagt?
So haben sie es jetzt nicht ausgedrückt.
Sie hätten von ein paar Jahren, hätten sie irgendwie sagen können, das was sie jetzt tun, hätten sie von ein paar Jahren machen müssen. Was haben sie jetzt für eine Zeit vergeudet? Seitdem das iPhone auf dem Markt ist. Seit 2007. Fast 5 Jahre. Das iPhone ist jetzt seit viereinhalb Jahren auf dem Markt. Angekündigt wurde es ja Anfang 2007, aber es war ja erst Juni oder so, verfügbar seinerzeit. So, und hätte Adobe gesagt, ah super, da ist ja die Zukunft, wie schön. Da machen wir doch gleich mal was dafür. Hier hat dem L5, da sind wir doch auf dem richtigen Weg, da bauen wir mal was. So, in der Zwischenzeit machen wir hier unser Flash-Plugin noch mal ein bisschen sicher, damit es nicht alle 20 Sekunden Security Warning gibt, sondern nur noch irgendwie alle 20 Tage. Und wir bauen jetzt hier mal unsere Tools um. So, hätten sie machen können.
Und natürlich ihr Flash-to-Native-App-Compile. Könnten sie auch dann immer noch weiter betreiben, theoretisch.
Ja, da haben sie ja eigentlich den Gnadenfress bekommen. Na, dass es dann sozusagen von Apple dann doch noch erlaubt wurde. Für iOS jetzt. Obwohl ich davon ehrlich gesagt relativ wenig halte, aber das bleibt dann jedem selber überlassen.
Na ja, dann haben sie diese ganzen Magazinen oder so, die benutzen das, ne?
Ja, und das taugt dann eh auch nur für Spiele und sowas. Also alles, was nicht wirklich ein natives User-Interface bietet.
Das ist halt wie auf dem Desktop, diese Real Basic Programme konnte ja auch keiner leiden, so wird es immer auch sein.
Ja, wobei die schon noch deutlich besser mit dem OS gespielt haben.
Real Basic hat alles selbst gemacht. Die haben eigene Controls gezeichnet.
Bist du sicher?
Ich hab lange was mit Real Basic gemacht.
Okay, dann täusche ich mich da vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen.
Also die sahen alle sehr, sehr, sehr macOSig aus, aber...
Aber irgendwie dann doch nicht, wenn du mal ein bisschen geklickt hast.
Na, die waren auch unter System 7 sahen die aus wie System... oder macOS 8 oder so dieser 3D-Look und die hatten...
Hat sich das nicht irgendwann geändert?
So ein Real Basic App, das erkennt man relativ deutlich daran, dass es... also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht mittlerweile könnte es anders sein, klar, aber damals als war das... Da gab es immer eine Ressource drinne, mit so einem Pick drinne, wo alle Grafiken drinne waren, also alle Buttons und Checkboxes und Konsorten.
Vielleicht könnte sich der Chat ja auch mal darüber unterhalten, worüber wir jetzt hier gerade reden. Wenn ich mal den Chat mal kurz darauf hinweisen darf. Ja, keine Nebengespräche. Real Basic.
Aufgepasst!
Wo sind denn hier die erfahrenen Hasen, die schon immer dabei waren und nicht immer besser mussten?
Die haben immer noch über unseren Gast und wollen wissen, wer das ist.
Wieso? Winnie ist doch bekannt.
Anscheinend nicht.
Wie ein bunter Hund.
Na wenn nicht, dann werden sie sie jetzt halt kennenlernen.
Sag doch mal Hallo im Chat.
Bist du im Chat?
Winnie?
Na die Freundin vom Tigger.
Genau, die ist sogar im Chat. Du bist jetzt bei The Poo, oder?
Ja, aber den hast du wahrscheinlich auch schon öfters gehört im Witz, oder?
Ach, fast gar nicht. Schlimmer als nur noch Mini-Winnie-Würstchen-Kette.
Was ist das denn?
Lieben Carl und dir, Annette. Mini-Winnie ist doch klar, ist der Kinderparty-Star. War eine Werbung.
Gut, jetzt ist es raus.
Jetzt droht es nicht mehr.
Schleichwerbung.
Ey, zurück zu Flash.
Ja, wir sollten mehr über Flash reden.
Ich glaube ja ganz ehrlich, dass sie eher von ihrem Management gezwungen wurden, das aufzugeben. Ich glaube, intern die Entwickler haben schon geglaubt, dass sie das nicht mehr machen.
Meinst du nicht eher andersrum?
Ich glaube, das ist so dieses klassische Problem mit irgendwie die Kacke samt Dampf.
Also davon abgesehen, dass da vielleicht ein paar Developer ihren Job behalten wollten, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die das wirklich Spaß hatten.
Also es war ja auch, es gab ja...
Also die Flash-Entwickler, die ich kenne, die sind ja so hart gesortene Flash-Entwickler.
Die sind furchtbar.
Ach so, ihr meint Leute, die das benutzen Flash-mäßig. Ich meine ja die Programmierer bei Adobe, die engine-coden, die meine ich nicht, die das nutzen. Die sind ja egal.
Ich glaube, die würden sich auch mal um was anderes kümmern, als an so einem Körnerl rumzuballern.
Na eben, sag ich ja. Die wurden vom Management gezogen, das so lange durchzumachen. Die hätten wahrscheinlich schon viel früher aufgegeben.
Macht's doch mal schnell, macht's doch mal sicher. Können wir nicht alles wegschmeißen?
Nein.
Ja, die haben es wahrscheinlich schon gehasst, als es von Macro Media kam.
Was mich total verwirrt ist, Adobe hat jetzt in den letzten zwei Jahren irgendwie so eine Vielzahl von Mini-Apps rausgehauen, auf der einen Seite, also unter iOS, was weiß ich hier, so Photoshop Elements und so weiter und dann gibt es irgendwelche komischen Konzept-Tools, mit denen du da irgendwas zusammendrängen kannst und rummalen kannst und Sketching-Dinger. Ich hab dir vollkommen den Überblick verloren, wie viele das eigentlich sind, aber es sind so ein paar. Und dazu haben sie dann gefühlt auch schon so fünf verschiedene Alternativen, wie man jemand irgendwie was am Mac oder am PC zusammenklammbüsern kann, mit HTML5 angekündigt oder halbgeschippt. Was weiß ich hier, dieses Edge zum Beispiel. Adobe Edge, ja siehst du mal, das kennt man auch alles gar nicht, aber das Phone Gap haben sie irgendwie gekauft. Genau, ja dann haben sie irgendwie eine Vielzahl von Sachen gekauft. Jetzt haben sie jetzt nicht sogar noch diese, krieg ich jetzt was durcheinander, diese Bude gekauft, die, dieses Javascript, Sproutcore, war das Adobe die das gekauft haben oder kriegt ihr das jetzt gerade?
Nee, nee, nee, das war...
War das nicht Facebook?
Facebook, genau, das war Facebook, Entschuldigung, das hab ich verwechselt. Wie auch immer, sie haben einfach keine erkennbare Strategie, also es ist überhaupt nicht klar, was sie jetzt eigentlich tun wollen und sie glauben, sie sind total besessen in diesem, also sie reden sich die ganze Zeit ein, dass sie ein Plattform-Provider sind und das ist halt ihr R. Sie wollen, dass die Leute in R irgendwas machen, sie wollen das irgendwie rimmunterschieben und ich meine, die Deppen, die kaufen das halt auch noch, jetzt sehen sie halt, wo sie sind und das führt halt nirgendswo hin. Ich meine, ich glaube nicht, dass Adobe auch nur den Funken einer Chance hat, in irgendeiner Form als Plattform-Provider weiter agieren zu können, vor allem mit dem Track-Record, den sie da haben, bzw. den sie nicht haben. Ich meine, das ist alles unsicher, langsam, instabil.
Und wird auch immer schlimmer.
Und es wird auch immer schlimmer.
Das ist das Erstaunliche.
Ja, es ist, es muss einfach ein Ende nehmen. Ich kann jetzt einfach allen nur raten, jetzt ist einfach der Zeitpunkt gekommen, wo ihr mal wirklich durch eure Webseiten durchgehen solltet und mal überlegen solltet, was ihr da alles so inkludiert und embeddet und vor allem, was ihr da selber surft.
Aber.
Aber?
Für so, also ich arbeite ja da bei so einer, weißt schon, so einer Social-Gaming-Bude und da gibt es ja schon keinen Weg an Flash gerade dran vorbei leider.
Ja gut, weil da jetzt gerade aktiv an eine existierende Userbase gecatert wird mit diesem hier sofort Spiel im Browser spielen und so. Aber ich meine, ihr wisst ja, wie weit ihr da kommt auf dem iPad.
Naja, naja, da gibt es ja jetzt Native Spiele, genau.
Genau, und da investiert man jetzt, da guckt man und da lernt man und da probiert man aus und da holt man sich vor allem neues Talent. So, aber man sucht jetzt nicht den Markt nach Flash-Programmierern ab.
Na doch, die suchen auch nicht.
Also gute gibt es glaube ich auch nicht so wirklich viele.
Ja, nee, das Problem ist, also bei uns ist ja eher, dass die meisten Flash-Developer haben halt mal irgendeine Werbe-Seite, wissen schon, irgendein Promo-Dingeldongelflash-App gekodet und haben halt dementsprechend einen tiefen, also nicht tiefen Einblick in was da eigentlich alles geht und wie man das mal sauber alles macht und deswegen ist das relativ schwer wirklich gute Leute zu kriegen, wo dann halt das Spiel nicht nach 20 Minuten oder 10 Minuten anfängt zu ruckeln und einen Speicher aufzueißen und den Browser crashen zu lassen.
Na ja, jeder der mal einen tieferen Blick in Flash geworfen hat und das verstanden hat, ist wahrscheinlich weggerannt. Doch, ich hab's ein bisschen... Du hast es auch gemacht, aber...
Ja, aber mittlerweile, die benutzen ja alle jetzt Eclipse und so und selbst so Programmierer, die sonst eigentlich eher so C++ oder anderen Scheiß gemacht haben, die kommen relativ schnell damit. Klar, ich staune auch, aber...
Fragen wir doch mal die Betroffenen.
Also ich hab das letzte Mal was mit Action Script 2 gemacht, aber da war es...
Ich glaub, bei mir war es 3 und ich hab mir Flex nochmal kurz angeguckt.
Also ich glaub, mit 3 ist es besser geworden, aber Action Script 2 war wirklich... Ich hab es irgendwie geschafft, dass wenn man ein Objekt über Syspunkt angesprochen hat und dann eine Eigenschaft und über das Objekt von außen angesprochen hat, dass man zwei verschiedene Properties hatte. Also dass man zwei Werte zuweisen konnte. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie das...
Aber mittlerweile ist das ja eher wie Java. Das hat ja nicht mehr viel mit dem alten Action Script zu tun.
Naja, aber das war auch schon Action Script 2. Also es war auch schon objektorientiert und dann da war das Script dran und da war es ja teufelwas.
Aber jetzt wird es eher Java-esque und alles ganz anders.
Na, das ist ja ein Qualitätsmerkmal.
Ja, eine weitere Sprache mit Zukunft. Na gut, als Java-Programmierer muss man sich jetzt erstmal nicht unmittelbar Sorgen machen. Das ist halt irgendwie das Kobol des 21. Jahrhunderts und das wird halt noch lange mitgeschliffen werden.
In Banken wird man dann auch lange...
Ja, da kannst du immer noch für eine Versicherung arbeiten.
Alles.
Alles, ja. Backends bauen.
Hab ich nicht neulich gehört, dass iTunes auch noch auf Web-Objects läuft und Web-Objects ist ja auch, oder?
Ja, Apple benutzt noch Web-Objects. Ich hab letztens gedacht, so haben die das noch und hab so ein bisschen mal rumgeklickt und dann irgendwie siehst du dann wieder diese Errors und so und dann steht da tatsächlich noch Web-Objects in der Uhr hier, die müssen auch Schmerzen haben, damit diese Web-Site...
Also im iTunes-Store möchte ich hier auch nicht sitzen.
Wahrscheinlich ist er auch deswegen halt schon 5 Stunden vorher offline, weil irgendwie müssen da die Web-Objects irgendwie mit Hammer und Meißel manuell da hin und her schubsen, aber naja. Nee, aber ja, also Flash-offs so, Desktop und Spiele und so, das gibt's glaube ich noch eine Weile, weil so da HTML5 und so, der ganze Kram, der ist einfach noch so weit davon entfernt für Spiele zu taugen, ist halt echt leider noch...
Ja, ist klar, aber ich meine, wenn man jetzt mal so in Richtung Webseiten denkt, die einfach so Flash im Wesentlichen als Infographic Delivery benutzen.
Restaurantseiten, Hotelseiten, ganz großer.
Ja oder spiel.de oder so ein Quatsch, ne? Ja und dann auch diese ganzen komplett in Flash gesetzten Webseiten und so. Zwischenüberschriften.
Damit Überschriften besser erinnern, die in Flash waren.
Das ist wirklich so was, wo es... Oder Werbung in Flash war, aber ich fand das immer gut, da könnte man so schon wegblenden.
Flash kann überhaupt nicht sterben, weil ansonsten hätte Adobe, also CS4 und so, hätte er Probleme, da sind ja teilweise die Menüs in CS...
Die haben jetzt auch Probleme. Die haben ein Problem. Die müssen das neu machen. Also ich meine, sie können es natürlich einfach in ihr blödes CS einfach reinbauen und erinnern sich das damit, aber...
Das ganze Creative Suite wird irgendwann in Flash programmiert sein. Also fühlt es sich zumindest an mittlerweile, also...
Aber ist nicht dieses neue... Also die haben doch jetzt auch so ein, ich weiß nicht wie es heißt, so ein HTML5 Tool, ist das dieses Edge, was du meintest? Also auf jeden Fall haben die ja so ein HTML5 Animation Tool und so weiter, ich weiß es ist komplett in R geschrieben. Also in Flash. Also insofern hat Hoke jetzt nicht so unrecht.
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist ja in Ordnung, wenn eine Firma irgendwie ihr eigene Plattform da erfährt und das irgendwie damit baut und damit nutzt und so. Sollen sie das machen, wenn sie damit glücklich werden in meinem Problem? Ich will bloß einfach nicht mehr darunter leiden. Ich will einfach ein Web haben. Es muss doch zumindest eine Sache geben, die wirklich überall funktioniert. Und Flash ist einfach das, was einfach...
Du solltest mal so eine I have a dream Rede schreiben.
Aber Vrm...
I have a Alptraum.
Vrm gibt es doch auch noch irgendwie in sehr vielen Browsern, habe ich gehört.
Was? Ich denke, es ist halt einfach generell vorbei für Plugins. Plugins sind einfach tot. Dieses Konzept, dass man dem Browser durch Partycode nativ irgendwas beibringt, was er halt nicht kann, ist einfach vorbei. Weil das Allermeiste kann man sich jetzt mit JavaScript bauen und die wirklich wichtigen Dinge, die werden einfach Teil des Standards. Und das wird jetzt auch relativ schnell gehen.
Ich glaube, du erreichst auch einfach keine Masse, wenn du es nicht machst. Weil, also, wer hatte das... Wer kann heute noch allen Ernstes seinen Usern zumuten? Bevor du hier draufbarst, musst du ja erstmal dahin gehen und dieses Plugin installieren und da doppelklicken und Admin-Rechte vergeben und aus der Sandbox raus. Und wenn du das Betriebssystem hast, dann... Also, was nicht dabei ist, das funktioniert auch nicht.
Die Hexe ist tot. Ja, wir lassen dich zurück. Nächste Schlachtbank heißt Silverlight.
Scheiße, ich wollte noch eigentlich was zu Flash sagen. Und zwar zu der Begründung, warum sie es eingestellt haben. Das sind ja im Wesentlichen zwei Gründe, wenn ich mich recht erinnere. Und zwar zum einen, dass es nicht auf allen mobilen Geräten zur Verfügung stand und auf einer wichtigen Plattform nicht. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, auf welcher, aber es wird irgendeine gewesen sein.
Nicht auf allen mobilen.
Ja, aber das andere ist, dass sie zu viele Probleme hatten mit den auseinander laufenden Plattformen. Dass es zu viele Plattformen geworden sind, für die sie entwickeln mussten. Das finde ich schon mal einen spannenden Punkt. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie denen nur nachgelegt haben, um noch irgendeinen Grund außer Apple zu haben. Um sagen zu müssen, wir geben es auch.
Sie zitieren aus der Realität der Computerindustrie. Oh, es gibt jetzt mehr als Windows.
Auf dem Desktop ist es nicht so?
Sie meinten, dass sie mit der ganzen Diversifikation nicht klarkommen würden. Wahrscheinlich sind es die diversen Android-Versionen, die sie nicht in den Griff gekriegt haben.
Was denn sonst?
Mit den verschiedenen Auflösungen und Plattformen und so.
Es gibt ja sonst nichts, wo Flash auch überhaupt nur angedacht wurde. Talking about Platform.
Und hier Web OS. Ich meine, sie haben es gemacht, sie haben es alles entwickelt.
Aber es ist nie geschippt, es gibt kein einziges Release. Nein, es ist alles Beta.
Ja klar, es ist Beta, aber sie haben viel Geld und Zeit und Arbeit reingesteckt, um das zu machen. Und also, die haben diese Arbeit schon hinter sich. Also das ist, also, wir hätten jetzt noch viel mehr vor sich, aber sie haben da schon sehr viel Geld und Energie reingesteckt.
Dass sie das nicht hinkriegen mit ihrer Codebase.
Genau. Na vielleicht nicht nur mit der Codebase, sondern auch mit dem sonstigen auseinanderlaufen.
Also das ist wirklich krass und RIM, ich meine RIM ist einfach dabei, sich irgendwie wirklich den Vlog selber ins Herz zu treiben. Ich verstehe diesen Laden überhaupt nicht.
Sie machen...
Wie kann man nur so visionsbefreit sein? Das ist mir wirklich ein totales Rätsel. Aber jetzt haben sie wieder ein neues...
Die Vision haben sie gesichert, oder ist die falsche?
Ich verstehe auch die Leute nicht, deren Telefone benutzen.
Von wem? Von RIM?
Na ja, das ist diese Business-Welt.
Nein, das ist nicht nur die Business-Welt. Das sind auch echt Privatleute und ich kapier's einfach nicht.
Kennst du private Menschen, die einen Blackberry haben?
In Europa?
Und wie sind die so drauf?
Die wären gerne Business-Menschen.
Arbeiten die mit SAP?
Ich glaube, das sind...
Was haben die für Hobbys so?
SAP, Oracle-Daten, Bankgarten-Ministrieren oder so.
Darüber kann ich jetzt nicht reden.
Also ich kann über Leute reden, die Blackberry-Telefone benutzen. Also meine Cousine, die macht so Wirtschaftsunternehmensberatungszeug in irgendein Riesenladen mit Leuten, die sich jeden Tag Kostümchen oder Anzüge anziehen müssen und furchtbare Sachen machen und Firmen vernichten. Und die hat natürlich geschäftlichen Blackberry, aber die hat auch diesen geschworen. Und die sagt, diese Tastatur, mir kommt nichts mit Software-Keyboard rein und die Tastatur ist super und die mag diesen Blackberry-Messenger. Das sind natürlich jetzt beides Dinge, die nicht mehr lange vorhalten werden, aber die gibt es halt. Und ich glaube mittlerweile, das war doch bei diesen Riots in England, war das doch, dass dieses Ding, dass Blackberry-Messenger eventuell abschalten wollten, wenn so was nochmal kommt.
Ach echt?
Weil da grad die Leute, die nicht ganz so viel verdienen, die aber den ganzen Tag chatten wollen mit ihren Freunden, für die ist das halt eine geile Plattform, weil das nicht so viel Traffic verursacht und die Geräte billig sind und so. Und wenn du nicht mehr willst, dann ist das vielleicht genau das Richtige, keine Ahnung. Also insofern.
Demnächst wird dann wahrscheinlich iMessage abgeschaltet, wenn die nächste Revolution kommt.
Das Telefonnetz pauschal.
Können sie ja nicht, weil dann wird weiter SMS gesendet.
Nicht bei oder zu?
Das wird dann auch. Vielleicht noch kurz, Silverlight ist ohnehin schon tot, weil Microsoft hat das offiziell noch nicht gesagt, aber sie haben auf der anderen Seite betont, dass sie ja eine Plug-in-freie Zukunft zumindest unter ihrem Aero planen. Also dass der Internet Explorer keine Plug-ins hat und auch unter Windows Phone 7.5 Mango-Saft ist auch keine Plug-in-Geschichte in irgendeiner Form und kein Flash vorgesehen und meines Wissens auch kein Silverlight. Was ist los Max? Willst du vom Thema abkommen?
Ne, wir heben es uns noch ein bisschen auf.
Will irgendjemand was zum Silverlight sagen oder wollen wir gleich zu O2 kommen?
Ich finde Silverlight ja eigentlich gar nicht schlecht. Raus! Oh, ich geh dann mal kurz. Also ich meine, es gibt wirklich einen sehr begrenzten Anwendungsfall für dieses Silverlight-Geraffel, aber es war immerhin, also es war tatsächlich besser als Flash in so vielerlei Hinsicht. Also es hat nicht so gebloatet und den Speicher aufgefressen und den Browser verlangsamt und hat...
Wo hätte ich das kennenlernen können?
Zum Beispiel bei Bing Maps.
Wenn du mal auf einer Microsoft-Seite warst, dann sind die erfordern das immer.
Bing Maps mit Silverlight war schon cool, aber ich wein dem jetzt auch keine Tränen nach. Weiter machen.
Man findet schon Sachen toll, wenn sie nicht total saugen.
Im Vergleich zu Flash war es schon okay, aber...
Ja, das ist schon irre, wie man schon so konditioniert ist. Aber es ändert einfach nichts an der Tatsache, dass Plugins einfach schon immer eine Scheißidee waren. Das hat auch nie wirklich was gebracht. Das Einzige, was ich Flash zugutehalten kann, ist, dass es jetzt einfach über Zeitraum, eine Dekade... Was ist los? Die anderen lesen deinen Bild schon nicht.
Ich glaub, ich glaub, ich glaub, ich glaub. Max, ja.
Wo ist denn hier dein Mikrofon? Ich schalt das mal aus. Ja, also das Einzige, was man Flash zugutehalten kann, ist, dass sie jetzt einfach...
Wechselnd.
Die Plattform... Sie waren einfach die Plattform, auf der sich der Bedarf des Webs eigentlich abgezeichnet hat. Also auf Flash wurde eben das getan und programmiert, was einfach gewollt wurde wirklich. Nämlich Videos mit Overlay-Menüs, YouTube-Style, diese Sachen, dafür war es wichtig. Sowas wie interaktive Grafiken-Geschichten. Das ist definitiv eine Anwendung, wo Flash Sinn gemacht hat, insofern, als dass es eben da war und dass man das eben auch entwickeln wollte.
Also damals war das toll.
Ja, das war toll und ich hab ja auch gar nichts dagegen, dass man sowas will und anbieten will. Es ist nur so, dass einfach Flash einfach kein Standard ist. Und dass das jetzt einfach zu einem Flash, dass es einfach zu einem Standard erhoben werden muss. Das, womit man das macht. Und es ist gut, wenn sich jetzt alles auf HTML5 konzentriert, und dann wird das hier einfach ein besserer Planet.
Na warte mal ab, bis dann Google versucht, seine Dart-Language reinzudrücken und...
Zu Google kommen wir auch noch. Kommen wir erstmal zu O2. Haben wir hier alle O2?
Nee, ich bin immer noch Telekom.
Ah, du hast gerade angerufen.
Du bist ja Snob.
Das ist geil, am Anfang war ich immer das Telekom-Opfer.
Telefonisch erreichbar sein.
Jetzt bist du immer noch das Telekom-Opfer.
Ja, aber wir sind die O2-Fer insofern. Telefonierst nie, ne?
Telefonieren ist bei mir überhaupt nicht das Problem.
Ja, Daten ist das Problem.
Hallo, ich will surfen unterwegs. Nee, geht überhaupt nicht. Also hier in Berlin hab ich teilweise Schwierigkeiten. In München, in der gesamten Innenstadt. Es ist einfach nur zum Kotzen. Du weißt ganz genau, ab dieser Haltestelle hab ich einfach kein Internet mehr. Und dann wirst du nur permanent vertröstet von denen. Ja, bist nur ein Einzelfall. Und meld dich doch bei unserer Hotline.
Verstehe, wollt jetzt auf diese Webseite hinaus, wo sich die melden sollen, weil da auch die Schnauze voll ist. Dass sie ihm sagen, dass es nur ein Einzelfall ist und nur temporär.
Wir sind strich einzelfall.de.
Ist das von Möfjo?
Und da ist ein kleines Blog und vor allem ist dahinter noch da ist ein fetter Link auf der Hauptseite. Das führt auf so ein Google Docs Formular. Und da kann man dann so seine Erfahrungen eintragen.
Das ist eine Einzelmeinung. Ruf beim Support an.
Erzähl mir nichts hier mit dem Rechner.
Ich seh den Pegel, ich hab den hier direkt.
In der Rechel immer Pegel.
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen?
Die Seite, du hast das Formular ausgefüllt.
Also meine Erfahrung ist, es gibt einfach verschiedene... Der Chat macht mich fertig. Ich schalte euch gleich ab hier. Mann. Also ich weiß nicht, was du erlebt hast, wenn du sagst, du kannst keine SMS verschenken, was ich ganz typischerweise hab. Du hast kein Daten. Er sagt, dass du 3G hast, aber es kommt nichts durch. Oder du hast gar nicht erst 3G?
Ich habe 3G und es kommt nichts durch.
Genau, das ist exakt das, was ich auch feststelle. Ich hab schon ganz viele Leute getroffen, die wirklich auch dieselbe Probleme haben. Und es ist so gefühlt alle drei Tage mal irgendwo.
Nee, nicht alle drei Tage in München. Es ist eigentlich Dauerzustand. Gefühlt, also zumindest in den Ecken, wo ich so unterwegs bin. Was dann, nee, beim Apple Store, da war ich schon ewig nicht mehr. Wir haben wenigstens einen.
Und Frankfurt hat jetzt zwei Hipster.
Aber dafür habt ihr ja keinen Fernsehturm.
Wir werden den schönsten bekommen.
Aber hallo.
Viel toller als eurer.
Mit Produkten, die es woanders nicht gibt.
Aber habt ihr auch gelesen, dass das schon jetzt hier...
In unserem Lipstief noch.
Dass sie schon reagiert haben.
Die SS habe ich vorhin rausgekommen, da wollte ich eigentlich noch durchlesen.
Also angeblich hat der Typ schon mit irgendeinem Doktor von O2 telefoniert, der da zuständig ist für die Corporate Communications. Und die wissen, dass irgendwie viel online benutzt wird. Und die sind am Ausbau.
Also die hatten ja auch neulich hier schon...
Das heißt aber, wie lange dauert das? Also Chat, Alternativen, Prepaid, oder monatlich kündbar, Datentafel.
Also die Alternative ist halt, man bewegt sich halt von WLAN-Station zu WLAN-Station. Von dem Café zu deinen Kumpels, zu sonst wo. Also wo ist man denn mal, wo man nicht irgendwie WLAN hat?
Dazwischen.
Was machst du dazwischen? Uber.
Oder im Café sitzen.
Sollts ja wohl mal WLAN geben.
Es gibt halt nicht in jedem Café WLAN.
Dennis, du bewegst dich an zwei verschiedenen Orten in deinem Leben. Drei. Also entweder bist du hier oder im Club oder bei dir zu Hause. Oder in Kreuzberg.
Ich bewege mich da, wo das Passwort für die WLAN-Station Seepferdchensex ist.
Sechs.
Das machst du in meinem WLAN? Aber ich meine, so lange sitzt man jetzt auch nicht in der U-Bahn, oder? Ich meine, scheiße, ich fahre keine U-Bahn.
Also ich brauche 3G, ich brauche das einfach. Vor allem ist es wichtig, dass es zu einem Minimum funktioniert. Aber es kommt gar nichts mehr. Das ist schon hart. Und das hält ja dann auch lange an.
Also, ich will jetzt nicht hier des Teufels Advokaten spielen, aber ich hab das bisher nicht gemerkt. Ich bin auch manchmal unterwegs und benutze irgendwie 3G.
Das ist ein Einzelfall. Das ist ein Einzelfall.
Du kannst ja in den Einzelfall da mal...
Nein, ich nicht!
Das Einzige, wo ich mit O2 keinen Empfang hab, ist wenn ich mal mit meinem Moped über die Dörfer bretter und da ist immer genau, da geht nix, da kriegst du nicht mal einen kleinen Kreis.
Genau, ich bin heute 6,5 Stunden Bahn gefahren und ich hab's geschafft, zweimal leer zu saufen, weil ich...
Zu saufen?
Davon gibt's mit Sicherheit ganz wenig.
Also nochmal langsam, du kriegst dein Telefon zweimal am Tag leer?
Auf dieser Strecke, die ich jetzt gefahren bin, weil er ständig nach Netz gesucht hat und ständig versucht...
Im Zug geht das?
Im Zug kriegst du das zwar, aber du willst locker hin.
Weil da kein Empfang ist, oder was?
Ja, kein Empfang oder... Du versuchst halt irgendwelche Webseiten aufzurufen.
Aber kein Empfang ist so was anderes, als wenn deren Datenfrequenzen belegt sind.
Zwischendurch kriegst du ja Edge angezeigt, und es geht aber nix durch. Oder kannst du mal 3G angezeigt, und es geht wieder nix durch.
Also damit könnte ich persönlich leben, aber es ist halt hier in Berlin und offensichtlich auch in München, hat man eben auch diesen Fall, du hast 5 Balken, 3G, alles bestens. Und es geht einfach nicht durch. Und das ist, ich erkläre mir das so, dass die Datenbandbreite an den entsprechenden Antennen nicht da ist, oder schlicht und ergreifend zusammengebrochen, die Verbindung, und dass es darum ist. Und wahrscheinlich ist da niemand da, der die DSL-Leitung resetten kann.
Ok, noch kurze Frage. Wie viel Mobile-Data verbrauchst du so im Monat?
Das ist eine gute Frage, aber ich habe ein 3G.
Das sagt dein O2 nicht.
Doch, aber das Phone sagt das.
Bei mir steht es auf der Rechnung.
Wenn es täglich, wenn es immer beim Monats ersten Reset ist, dann sagt es dem O2 nicht. Ich habe jetzt schon einmal die 5GB gerissen.
Seit wann? Im Monat?
Also einmal habe ich so richtig gerissen mit irgendwie... Ne, stimmt gar nicht. Warte mal, jetzt muss man kurz überlegen.
Also ich glaube, mehr als ein Gig benutz ich nicht.
Ich habe die 10GB gerissen, aber das war wahrscheinlich eine Fehlgeschichte und die 5GB habe ich jetzt glaube ich zweimal überschritten, sodass ich dann irgendwie kein richtiges Netz mehr hatte.
Aber mit Hotspotting hier, also mit Tethering?
Oder?
Ich habe in diesem Monat noch kein Tethering gehabt und habe jetzt schon fast 300 durch.
Also ich habe anderthalb Gigs, seitdem ich meinen 3GS gekauft habe.
3GS?
Also bei mir war das jetzt in zwei Wochen.
Verstehe.
Also ich habe mal so geguckt, weil weil ich ja auch...
Ihr seid also die, die das Netz hart machen, weil ich auf der Suche nach...
Weil wir unsere Wohnung verlassen.
Aber ich höpfe halt von meinem WLAN zum nächsten WLAN im Café. Überall ist ein WLAN. Ich meine, du gehst ja irgendwie bei bei Serkan einkaufen und der hat WLAN. Hat der WLAN?
Also ich hab...
Das ist ein Traum.
Ich hab... Nee komm, es gibt schon wirklich überall WLAN, außer von der Innenaubahn.
Nein, bei mir in der Firma, das WLAN ist so flaky.
Verstehe, du sitzt den ganzen Tag in der Firma und benutzt 3G? Wenn das jede Firma macht, ist da kein Wunder, dass dieses Netz platt ist.
Ja, du hast ja dann manchmal auch so ein bisschen Zensur-Firewall und Port-Sperren und so.
Na, das haben wir alles nicht.
Dann ist man Hacker und dann macht man sich mit seinem Laptop...
Du bist ein Einzelfall, Dennis. Frag dich da mal ein hier. Ich hab immer Netz.
Das fällt total auf.
Ich sollte mal mit dem... Da freuen die sich bei U2. Dr. Kunzer soll mich mal anrufen. Ich sag ihm, was seine User falsch machen. Aber ich muss ja sagen... Sie sollen mal vielleicht auch Anleitungen schreiben, wie man halt sein Telefon so benutzt, dass es halt eben nicht die ganze Zeit das U2-Netzblatt macht, weil ich meine am Ende...
Dazu ist das Telefon da, verdammte Scheiße!
Ja, aber ich kann dir auch sagen, was dann demnächst passiert. Dann wird U2 teurer werden und dann hüpfst du nämlich zum nächsten, weil du es ja schon billig haben willst, oder?
Ich bin zu U2 gegangen, weil ich monatlich keinen Vertrag haben wollte. Monatlich könnte man einen Vertrag.
Wenn die teurer wären, wär's okay.
Ich wär bei der Telekom geblieben. Na gut, mit mehr Daten und...
Meinen auch bitte. Das heißt, bei der Telekom ist deswegen nicht so viel los, weil die halt nur Opfer haben und so viele Opfer gibt's halt nicht. Du zahlst schon ein bisschen mehr, richtig? Dafür hast du ja den Luxus, dass es halt dann auch funktioniert. Okay, du kannst halt noch mehr zahlen und dann funktioniert's. Oder könnte ich als alle bei Dr. Kunze beschweren, die werden es dann viel Geld in die neuen Basisstationen investieren oder in die Verbesserungen der Alten und dann wird's da auch teurer.
Ja, das ist doch okay, wenn es teurer wird.
Dann kann es doch gleich zur Telekom gehen.
Nee, Telekom hat halt dieses Problem, du verpflichtest dich für 24 Monate. Also das ist mein Grund, warum ich da nicht gerne hingehen möchte. Erstens, die bieten keine Tarife, also ich werde jetzt wahrscheinlich doch in den sauren Apfel beißen, aber das ist der Grund, warum ich bisher nicht getan habe. Wenn du vernünftig Daten drin hast, in so einem Tarif, dann hast du auch gleich Telefon, Flatrate und 5000 SMS im Monat. Alles Dinge, die ich überhaupt nicht brauche.
SMS, nee, wir brauchen nur SMS.
Ich vertelefoniere im Monat so 5 bis 10 Euro, wenn es hochkommt.
Das heißt, du habt auch den O2-Vertrag, wo man 0 Grundgebühren hat, plus die 10 Euro für die 200 oder 300 MB inzwischen?
Ich hab 20 Euro.
Für den Gigabyte-Flat.
5 Gigabyte, genau.
Ich hab nur die 10 Euro für die 300 MB.
Und das ist jetzt ziemlich nervig bei der Telekom. Also ist man wirklich gleich viel Geld los. Und diese 24 Monate Vertragsbindung. Wenn ich jetzt sagen könnte, ich kann da jederzeit wieder raus.
Weil ich will ja auch kein Telefon haben. Ich will ja die ganzen Subventionen, die ganze Scheiße will ich alles nicht haben.
Mit Telekom ist es ja auch gleich ein einziger Teurer.
Ich hab mir den ja auch anlockt, selber gekauft. Einmal Italien, einmal London.
Warum soll ich dann 24 Monate einen Vertrag abschließen?
Ja, das seh ich ja ein.
Das sind die Gründe.
Jeder hat seine eigenen Gründe, aber Tatsache ist, bei O2 geht grad nicht viel.
Na doch, da geht gerade zu viel.
Wobei, ich muss sagen, seitdem ich letztes Mal hier so furchtbar gemeckert, seitdem hab ich keine Probleme mehr gehabt, erstaunlicherweise. Also es war jetzt nicht schnell und sowas.
Das ist super, wenn ich jetzt meckere, dann komm ich nach Hause und alles geht.
Hast du dir zum Beispiel schon hier Tims WLAN eingestellt? Hast du schon, okay.
Hier gibt es eh keinen Autoremfang in diesem Studio.
Gibt's schon, aber nicht gut.
Ich hab drei Steve Balken.
So, wollen wir das Thema noch weiter vertiefen? Ich glaube, wir haben es jetzt, oder?
Also wir können feststellen, Huckel ist ein bisschen weniger Opfer geworden.
So, womit wollen wir denn weitermachen?
Was hast du denn so auf deiner Liste?
Ich fand ja hier zwischendurch, ich war jetzt vier Wochen, was? Vier Wochen? Hab ich ja Urlaub gemacht, dann hab ich mein News Featuring gelesen. Naja, vom Mobile Max halt.
Achso, ich wollte schon meinen.
War ja zweimal nicht da. Habt ihr ja auch gelesen, dieses Barnes & Nobles, die die Vertragsverhandlungsbedingungsgeschichten von Microsoft veröffentlicht haben? Nee, hab ich nicht gesehen. Microsoft kassiert ja hier für Android-Lizenzen ab. Und Barnes & Nobles hat ja auch so einen E-Book-Reader, so einen Nuke heißen die, Nuke Color, Nuke Touch, was auch immer. Und dann kam da wohl Microsoft auch mal vorbei und hat gesagt, Jungs, wie sieht's denn aus? Und im Vergleich zu allen anderen, bei denen das Microsoft gemacht hat, hat Barnes & Nobles gesagt, wir machen das jetzt aber mal öffentlich, weil in den ganzen Verhandlungen halt Microsoft auch als die auferlegt hält, überhaupt nicht über diese Verhandlungen zu sprechen und so weiter. Und dann stand da halt schon echt, echt viel krasses Zeug drin. Und das habt ihr nicht gelesen? Nee, hab ich das ja. Ich brauch mal den Link. Schlecht vorbereitet, nee, aber...
Es ist oft nur gehofft, dass wir das gelesen haben und schon wissen, wovon du redest. Ich weiß von nichts.
Nee, das steht halt drin, was sie sozusagen für Lizenzgebühren haben wollen, dass du halt irgendwie über den ganzen Krempel nicht sprechen darfst. Und das ist halt irgendwie so ein...
Wofür eigentlich? Ja, aber nein, wofür? Dass du was tun kannst.
Ach so, ihre Patente nutzen.
Ja, aber welche? Was?
User Interface zum Beispiel auch, ja. Und das Ding ist halt vor allen Dingen, dass sie halt in diesen Verhandlungen dann Barnes & Nobles und wahrscheinlich auch den anderen halt aufdrücken wollen, dass sie sagen können, welche Features sie shippen dürfen und welche nicht. Also das zum Beispiel, also angenommen, Barnes & Nobles wäre jetzt hier mit... Klicken wir halt auf den Link. Will jetzt halt irgendein Feature von Android da irgendwie ganz groß Featuren und so, dann könnte Microsoft da sozusagen letztendlich ein Veto einlegen und sagen, nee, das passt uns aber nicht. Und da sind, glaube ich, wenn das diese Artikel ist, scrollen wir ein bisschen runter. War das der, den ich hatte? Weil da waren halt so ein paar Snippets von den größten Kloppern sozusagen drin. Ja, ich hatte irgendwie ein anderes. Ja, genau, da sind diese Exhibits. Und wenn du noch ein bisschen weiter runterscrollst, waren dann auch, glaube ich, die Vertragspunkte da. Anyway, könnt ihr auch mal klicken. Auf jeden Fall, wie gesagt, wollen halt den Lizenznehmern dann diktieren, welche Features sie in ihre Geräte einbauen und welche nicht. Wollen halt ziemlich exorbitante Lizenzgebühren und wollen eben auch, dass diese gesamte Verhandlung dann secret ist. Und Barnes & Noble hat halt einfach gesagt, ne, das geht aber mal gar nicht und ist Antitrust. Und ihr benutzt jetzt gerade hier, sehen das als illegal an diese Praktiken, haben deswegen das so mal veröffentlicht und machen da jetzt mal einen Stunk, sozusagen. Und wenn ihr das halt durchleset, ist es halt auch wirklich krasser. So toll man das vielleicht oder so interessant man das vielleicht auch findet, dass Microsoft dafür Android abkassiert und sich für sie freut oder auch nicht. Aber die Art und Weise ist schon ganz schön... Ries!
Microsoft ist nicht nett.
Es ist kein Ponyhof hier.
Ja, also ich... also...
Microsoft ist auch in Panik.
Aber es ist krass, wenn die das bei allen anderen auch so machen und schon erfolgreich gemacht haben und da so abkassieren.
Ich frage mich nur, was sind denn das für Patente, für die Android zahlen muss, für die Apple nicht zahlen muss?
Ich nehme an, Apple wird für die zahlen.
Apple hat ja mit Microsoft einen total riesen geschaerten Patentpool. Die haben sich ja da nicht so. Die haben ja gegenseitig in den ganzen Jahren sich so viele Patente gegenseitig gesigned, dass Apple damit wahrscheinlich überhaupt genau gar kein Problem hat.
Ja.
Das ist schon echt krass, vor allen Dingen, wenn dann am Ende halt noch rauskommen würde, dass Microsoft am Ende an Android mehr verdient als Google selber.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so. Ich meine, was verdient Google an Android?
Nichts.
Ja, die werden schon irgendwelche Verträge oder so verdienen, aber es ist wahrscheinlich macht Microsoft halt in der Masse einfach mehr.
Tatsächlich.
Was für Verträge? Ja, ich weiß, was die da für... Android ist an sich.
Ja, ich weiß schon.
Postenlos lizenzierbar, darum geht's ja. Und sie haben halt ihre Deals mit Early Access. Aber ich glaube, der Preis, den man dafür zahlen muss für diesen Early Access, ist eher, ihren ganzen Google-Kram einzubauen, die Google Apps mit einzubauen. Weil das ist das, woran Google ja eigentlich ein Interesse hat. Googles Interesse ist nicht im eigentlichen Sinne Android und das folgt zu bringen, sondern ihr Interesse ist halt einfach, ihre Google Apps und ihre Infrastruktur rüber zu bringen. Android ist ihnen dann glaube ich auch ziemlich egal.
Naja, also nicht egal, insofern als dass sie natürlich schon wollen, dass es toll ist, und alle benutzen und dann halt bei Google Daten abliefern und ihre Dienste nutzen und so weiter.
Ja gut, aber Amazon benutzt jetzt auch Android und liefert definitiv keine Daten bei Google ab. Und das ist glaube ich nicht jetzt unbedingt das, wofür sie da das Development stemmen. Das wäre ja auch noch...
Habt ihr auch gehört, was der Amazon-Typ gesagt hat, der Jeff Bezos oder Bezos, wie er heißt?
Zum Thema Software-Patente.
Ja, und dass er das, wenn er seinen One-Click-Patent aufgeben müsste, dafür dass die Software-Patente verschwinden, dann meint er, dann wäre das das kleinere Übel.
Ja, das wär's wert. Ja, weil es einfach schadet.
Also Jungs, macht mal.
Ja, it's not going to happen anytime soon. Ich seh da so recht keinen Trend dahin.
Aber so aus Anwendersicht, das ist für uns so ein Problem. Ich meine, die machen sich doch da oben gegenseitig fertig. Das kann uns doch eigentlich nicht so wirklich stören, oder?
Ich glaub schon, dass das einige Entwicklungen behindert.
Die kleinen halt wahrscheinlich, ne? Weil da warten die wahrscheinlich immer ab, die klein lassen, die entwickeln, gucken, ob es cool ist. Entweder kaufen sie das auf, oder wenn sie es nicht kaufen lassen, hauen sie mit Patenthammer drauf.
Also Barnes & Noble sagt doch, dass es Trivial-Patenten im großen Teil halt auch sind, die sie da wohl einfach auffahren.
Ja, das ist der totale Stress. Und das ist vor allem auch generell das Problem mit Ziffer-Patenten, dass es dich einfach, dass es kleine Unternehmen üblicherweise einfach sofort out of business nimmt. Also es ist ja nicht nur so, dass es dann eine Frage ist, wie viel du bezahlen musst. Allein, dass du dann eben diesen Juristenscheiß an der Backe hast, das ist einfach für kleine Firmen nicht zu stemmen. Nö, auch wenn ich nicht.
Ich glaube, wenn du einfach zahlst und genug abdrückst, dann...
Nein, die sagen einfach, du darfst es nicht verwenden.
Ach, daran haben sie auch kein Interesse. Die sagen, du darfst es verwenden, wenn du uns so und so viel zahlst.
Ja gut, aber das sind dann wahrscheinlich auch Beträge, die du nicht zahlen kannst.
Nö, das sind durchaus zahlbare Beträge. Das musst du halt bloß...
Kein Geld mehr verdienen, ja.
Ja, also es macht das Leben... Also ich meine, das ist wie ein Schutzgelderpresser, der würde dich auch nicht umbringen.
Ja, aber wenn so eine Kostüme lose ab ist, die irgendwie Teil deiner Strategie ist...
Natürlich, also klar, dass das massiv problematisch ist, das ist ja gar keine Frage. Ich glaube übrigens, ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass da ein bisschen Bewegung demnächst reinkommen wird, weil einfach so unglaublich viele, sowohl größere als auch kleinere Firmen mittlerweile sagen, dass das total unerträglich ist, also zumindest in Amerika, dass irgendwann vermutlich auch mal irgendein Senator darauf aufspringen wird, auf diesen ganzen Zug. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das irgendwann etwas weniger schmerzhaft wird, aber bis dahin ist noch ein weiter Weg. Also es hat sich glaube ich mittlerweile hinreichend weit rumgesprochen, dass diese Software-Patente, zumindest so wie sie im Augenblick gemacht sind, totaler Pain in the Ass sind. Das braucht jetzt höchstens noch so zwei, drei Jahre, bis es im Kongress und Senat gebabbelt ist.
Naja, also so wie die amerikanische Regierung funktioniert, würde ich da nicht so wirklich viel darauf wetten, ehrlich gesagt.
Du hast die Lobbygruppen vergessen?
Ja, aber selbst, ja selbst die, also so dieses, da gibt es ja nun auch diverse schöne, Heise hatte glaube ich neulich so eine schöne Studie, dass die, wie viel die Softwareindustrie, die diese Software-Patente jedes Jahr kosten, da wird ja wirklich massiv Geld abgesaugt.
Ja, aber du hast ja gemerkt hier, die letzte Bill, die zum Patentrecht, wo alle schon gehofft hatten, dass sich was passiert, hat gesagt, dass sie mehr Geld in den Patentamt geben, damit sie schneller Patentanträge bearbeiten können. So, super, das hilft.
Ja klar, wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass das morgen passieren wird, aber ich hab schon das Gefühl, dass wenn da so ne komplette Industrie dahinter sagt und sagt, wir haben hier echte Bauchschmerzen damit, dann irgendwann kommt das an. Also auf die Wirtschaft, man kann ihnen alles vorwerfen, aber dass sie nicht genug auf die Wirtschaft hören würden, das ist ja nun wirklich nicht, oder? Ja, mal sehen.
Hat denn jemand die Steve Jobs Biografie gelesen?
Ne, jetzt nachdem alle schlecht geredet haben, würd ich nicht mehr. Na Gruber und Siracusa haben gesagt, das ist das Allerletzte.
Hast du den Podcast gehört mit Siracusa?
Hab ich mir noch nicht angehört.
Hypercritical, ich glaub Ausgabe, was ist das?
Die Aktuelle müsste sein.
Es ist vernichten und er hat einfach total recht.
Warst du es denn gelesen?
Ich bin noch im ersten Kapitel.
Mein Interesse daran war auch nicht besonders groß. In Englisch?
Ich hab nur gehört, dass es wahnsinnig viele Wiederholungen gibt.
Ja, die Siracusa hat wirklich ein paar Dinge da rausgepuppelt, wo man wirklich extrem gut verstehen kann, dass die Geschichte, die er da erzählt, einfach nicht die Geschichte ist, die uns interessiert. Also sein Kernpunkt ist, der Isaacson versteht einfach diese IT-Industrie nicht. Und deswegen fokussiert er sich auf Sachen, die einfach uninteressant sind im Vergleich. Und das, was er irgendwie ausführlich behandelt, das ist im Wesentlichen das, was in 20, 30 anderen Büchern schon viel besser und ausführlicher erzählt wurde. Und da hat er es dann auch in epischer Breite, was weiß ich, die Geburt des Macs, und was einfach super ausführlich. Aber so Details wie die Transition auf Intel und dieser Kauf von PA Semi und einfach diese ganzen interessanten Dinge, die so am Anfang und in der Mitte von Steve Jobs zweiter Zeit bei Apple passiert sind. Und vor allem auch die ganze Next-Ära, die ist einfach so vollkommen nebenbei. Und das ist das, wo kaum jemand überhaupt irgendetwas weiß. Wo ich jetzt gesagt hab, jetzt mal so Einblicke in dieses, wie hat Steve Jobs das so gesehen mit Next und was war so ihr Designziel und warum war der Next seiner Meinung nach auch ein Fehler und was war der Fehler, den er gemacht hat etc. Das wären einfach interessante Einblicke, aber davon ist halt offensichtlich in diesem Buch nichts zu finden. Und er macht das einfach sehr gut fest an vielen Details, wo man einfach sehen kann, dass also entweder er oder auch diese Editors das nicht hinbringen. Bis hin zu, dass irgendwie der Name der Firma falsch geschrieben wurde. Und ich meine jetzt nicht das Komma zwischen Apple und Ink, sondern sowas wie Apple Computers und so weiter.
Ja, der Siracusa hätte das Buch schreiben müssen.
Der Siracusa mit John Gruber sollten zusammen vielleicht mal dieses Buch schreiben, aber die durften halt jetzt nicht.
Dann wird das doch mehr Röntgen als alles andere.
Naja, da kommt der Gruber, ist doch der Fanboy, schlecht hin.
Also Siracusa würde das schon gut machen.
Die beiden in Kombination wäre auf jeden Fall interessant. Das Problem ist, nur der Isaacson hat sich halt mit Steve Jobs da hingesetzt und nicht...
Das Problem ist, der Steve Jobs ist schon tot.
Jetzt ist er halt tot, jetzt kann man ja nicht mehr fragen.
Das sind doch auch nur andere Leute, die man fragen könnte. Man könnte jetzt schon noch irgendwie die Edition rausbringen.
Ja, man könnte das Material veröffentlichen, was er hat. Also wenn er das...
Der würde die Fragen einfach nicht gestellt haben, die richtigen.
Vielleicht hat er das falsch gemacht. Vielleicht wollte er ein Buch über den Menschen Steve Jobs da ausmachen.
Ach, wie interessierter Mensch.
Es steht vorne auf dem Buch drauf. Insofern ist es auch vielleicht jetzt davon auszugehen, dass die meisten Leute das kaufen. Deswegen den Typen, der vorne draufgemalt ist, kaufen.
Ok, Geschenk. Dann hätte er eben auch diesen anderen Teil nicht so ausführlich behandelt.
Ich hab es nicht so. Ich bin bisher an dem da, wo sie Apple-Kurte gründen und hab dann auch nicht weitergelesen, weil dann bin ich krank gewesen und hab mich seitdem auch nicht wieder aufraffen können. Ich fand es auch nicht so spektakulär, dass ich jetzt unbedingt weiterlesen wollte. Und ich weiß ja, wie es ausgeht.
Hypercritical, Episode 42, The Wrong Guy. Weil das ist er. Wohl offensichtlich gewesen, laut.
Also nicht das sief, sondern der Isaacsen.
Der Isaacsen ist The Wrong Guy, ja.
Ach mein Gott, ich werd's trotzdem lesen.
Aber wenn man's mal aus anderer Sicht betrachtet, dann hat er wahrscheinlich ein Buch gelesen, was die normalen Leute schon gut... Buch geschrieben mein ich, nicht gelesen. Hat er ein Buch geschrieben, was die normalen Leute gut lesen können, oder? Also weil's wahrscheinlich nicht so technisch ist, sondern mehr so Standard-Blafhase.
Also ich hab's jetzt mal gesehen, wie dicke... Also ich hab's mir ja für einen Kindle gekauft, und dann war's relativ dünn, und dann hab ich's das erste Mal im Original gesehen, und hab, oh Gott, was hab ich mir da für einen Klopper gekauft? Also das zum einen, also es ist schon viel Material. Es ist jetzt... es sind schon teilweise ziemlich krasse Storys. Also ich meine, dass der Typ quasi mal, also Steve Jobs offensichtlich mal eine orange Haut hat, die ganze Zeit lang, weil er so unglaublich viele Möhren gegessen hat. Und das ist jetzt so eine von unglaublich vielen Geschichten. Also ich meine, er muss gestunken haben eine Zeit seines Lebens lang, wie die Pest. Weil er geglaubt hat, dass, hier, wie war's, wenn man Veganer ist, dass man dann keinen Körpergeruch entwickeln würde, und dass er darum nicht duschen bräuchte. Und das ist schon, finde ich, ganz interessant. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das jetzt unbedingt auf wie viele Seiten, sind es 800 Seiten, ausbreiten muss.
Nerds stinken nun mal. Nerds stinken nun mal.
Das ist nicht akzeptabel. Also wirklich nicht akzeptabel. Das fand ich ja das Eigentliche. Ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich über ihn gesagt worden ist. Seine Schwester, Lisa, ich weiß nicht, Lisa Simpson heißt sie, ne? Seine Schwester ist dies. Nicht Mona Simpson.
Mona ist auch seine Schwester.
Mona Simpson, genau. Ich verwechsel die immer mit...
Lisa ist die Tochter.
Und die Tochter heißt ja auch Lisa. Nein, Liza, der Computer, der war ja nach seiner Tochter benannt.
Es ist Gerücht, ja. Stimmt aber nicht. Weil die offizielle Story ist, das ist von so einem anderen Typen, der hatte auch eine Tochter, die sich und der hat den Rechner benannt.
Aber Steve Jobs Tochter heißt auf jeden Fall auch Lisa, die erste. Egal. Und die hat ja auch ein Buch geschrieben, nachdem sie Steve Jobs kennengelernt hat, ihren Bruder über einen berühmten amerikanischen Entrepreneur, der Computer baut, der so beschäftigt war, dass er nicht mal die Zeit hatte, nach dem Klogang zu spülen.
Du hast jetzt aber wirklich immer die unterste Schublade hervorgeholt von allen Stories, oder?
Das ist so, wo ich mitdenke. Ich weiß ja nicht mal, ob es über ihn ist, aber es ist irgendwie...
Wenn ich so reich wäre, würde ich auch nicht mehr spülen, weil es mein Toilette für mich alleine macht. Dann hast du nämlich so einen Teil mit Temperatursensor, dann so irgendwie Blutzuckerspiegel-Dings eingebaut und irgendwie... Und Krebsvorsorge schon, klar. Genau, ist alles drin. Und spülen natürlich auch.
Gibt's?
Okay, also nochmal zusammenfassend, das Buch ist nicht so lesenswert oder jetzt doch? Also ist es so richtig, richtig schlecht oder kann man es schon trotzdem lesen, nur ist der total interessierte Nerd nicht total gesättigt danach?
Also wenn man jedes Detail aus Steve Jobs Leben wissen möchte oder mehr als man jemals über Steve Jobs wissen wollte, da steht es drin.
Ja, ich glaube nach dem Buch ist er mir auch unsympathisch.
Ich freu mich.
Also nach allem, was ich bisher gehört habe, ich glaube, ich wär mit dem Typen nicht zurechtgekommen.
Okay, dafür muss ich nicht das Buch lesen, um das zu erahnen.
Also vorher war er mir irgendwie sympathisch, aber wahrscheinlich bin ich einfach nur blauäugig rangegangen und hab nur das gesehen, was er an Arbeit macht. Aber so als Mensch, fragwürdiger Kerl.
Ich hab mich ja auch ein bisschen geärgert, dass ich das Hardcover-Buch gekauft hab, weil...
Ist schon da hätte?
Ja, schon lange. Weil jetzt, wo ich ein Kindl hab, hätt ich mir eigentlich das auch sparen können und... Also diese Papierbücher, die du getestet hast.
Aber jetzt mal zu deinem Kindl. Huckel, wie viel hast du denn da bezahlt?
99 Euro.
Du hast ja bei deinem Flatnet schon 99 Euro eingenommen.
104, also, nee, ich hab ja noch viel mehr eingenommen, aber da ich ja jeden Monat auch rausflatter, also geht ja immer ein Teil davon ab.
Alles worüber? Du bloggst ja nur minimal eigentlich.
Ja, die 2-3 Blogposts, Twitter-Account und das Bad eigentlich.
Das heißt, ich muss meine also doch mal aktivieren, ja? Ich wucke nochmal.
Aber egal, welchen Kindl hast du gekauft?
Na den für 99 Dollar, den Kindl 3 oder was das ist. Wollt ihr ihn nochmal sehen? Aber ich fand's echt gut, ne? Also kam halt, also nur mal kurz die Kindle Experience beschreiben. Hab ich ja gestern bestellt, nee, vorgestern bestellt. Dann hab ich eine Mail bekommen, hier Achtung, hier kannst du schon deinen Kindl managen. Und dann stand auch in der Mail, dass mein Kindl sowieso schon auch auf mich registriert ist, auf meinen Account und ich könnte sofort loslegen. Okay, super. Dann kannst du ja Bücher in deine Library da hochladen, indem du es per E-Mail schickst. Dann hab ich schon in meine ganzen E-Books, die ich hatte, als Mobi mir noch mal runtergeladen und per E-Mail da hochgeballert, waren auch sofort da und heute halt ausgepackt und angeschlossen und dann waren halt die Bücher auch sofort da. Also insofern schon mal super. Und dann haben sie ja hier die Verpackung, also bei Apple alles shiny shiny, aber ich fand halt, also da ist jetzt so ein bisschen Kram drin, aber es ist halt alles so aus recycelten Material und irgendwie so passt genau, kommt hier die Box da so daher und dann war da der Kindl drin und hatte hier auf seinem E-Ink-Display auch gleich hier die Anleitung. Hier, Stöpsel mal ran und... Muss da unten glaube ich diese Taste einatmen.
Das muss man bei denen jetzt noch mehr dazu sagen, als bei den vorherigen, wo er auch irgendwie erstmal aufs Display nun tippt.
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an meinen Texta-Reader.
Es ist das gleiche Display, wohl. Es gibt nämlich nur eins.
Die haben alle das gleiche Display.
In dem Fall, wie gesagt, dann ausgepackt, reingestöpselt und los ging's. Bis jetzt war ich doch erstmal von dieser Experience ganz positiv überrascht. Vor allen Dingen auch so dieses...
Das Auspacken fand ich auch super.
Ich check jetzt mal sehen.
Den Rest fand ich nur so mittel.
Die Standard-Amazon-Kindle-Box.
Ich finde halt, WLAN-Passwort eingeben ist so pain in the ass.
Hast du auch den kleinen?
Ich kann ja nicht skippen, also drehen hier, weißt schon.
Ah, ok, du hast auch den mit Tastaturquery. Den gleichen, den ich auch hab.
Und schon benutzt? Seit gestern hast du den.
Nee, seit heute. Also ich hab noch nicht wirklich viel Erfahrung.
Du hast den schon länger?
Ja.
Und wie ist so?
Cool.
Wie lange hast du den schon?
Seit Sommer.
Und du liest da wirklich so stundenlang Bücher?
Stundenlang nicht, aber eigentlich jeden Abend halbe Stunde, Stunde mindestens.
Fachbuch oder Belletristik?
Beides, aber hauptsächlich meine Instapaper-Sachen. Ich lag mir die Instapaper-Feeds runter, die kannst du dir ja für Kindle runterladen, und spiel ich da drauf und lese da drauf, weil es einfach besser geht als auf dem iPhone oder auf dem iPad. Und dafür finde ich es einfach geil.
Teichmann.
Das ist jetzt sehr visuell für den Podcast.
Das haben wir hier andauernd, unsere User, die sind das gewohnt, die gehen jetzt alle gerade aus Klo und so. Du siehst gleich, in unserem Hörer Meter, der geht gleich kurz runter. Du brauchst auch nur Kalender sagen, dann fällt ja auch erstmal 100 Leute. Und dann geht der wieder nach oben. Wir haben auch immer coole Sprüche, um das zu überbrücken, so wie ich jetzt.
Wenn hier jemand Kalender sagt, dann machen die bei den Wasserwerken schon mal eine Sonderschicht. Die Klospülung anzuschmeißen.
Da sind ja jetzt keine Ups drauf auf dem Kindle, sondern das ist jetzt quasi dein Instapaper-Kram als E-Book runtergeladen.
Ja, den kannst du dir für Kindle runterladen.
Dann kommt das so als Mobi.
Genau, und dann spielst du es per USB drauf.
Ich dachte immer, das macht er per Mail.
Ja, aber da ich alles irgendwie eingeordnet habe in verschiedene Ordner, möchte ich das nicht per Mail unbedingt haben.
Womit machst du das, dass du das hier in Ordner einordnen kannst auf dem Gerät? Gibt es da irgendwas?
Für die Instapaper-Sachen nicht, nein.
So, ich claime jetzt meine Twitter-Dinger. Ich hab jetzt die Schnauze voll.
Ich hab hier mal irgendwie einen ganzen Berg Apple-Doku runtergeladen und das ganze Gerät damit voll und jetzt ist hier alles voller Apple-Doku. Ich kann es auf dem Gerät einsortieren, aber es sind halt irgendwie 500 Bücher. Das macht auch keinen Spaß, nee.
Aber es gibt doch diese Ab-Datei, dachte ich, dieses Calibri oder so.
Also das gibt von Amazon eine App, aber die funktioniert nicht, wenn du in Sachen einen Ordner einsortieren willst. Das zynkt da nicht zurück.
Also ich hab mir mal die Dateistruktur von dem Zeug angeguckt. Das sieht so aus, als ob da so etwas gehashed steht und dann halt der gehashter Fallname nach irgendeinem Prinzip und dann der Ordner, an dem es drin ist und das sind Jason-Daten. Also es sollte alles nicht so schwer sein. Ich hab nur noch nicht so ganz rausgekriegt, wie der Pfad lautet und dann wäre das theoretisch zumindest mal machbar, dass man sagen kann und ein Skript schreibt, was alles was in einem Ordner ist, dann auch in einen Ordner auf den Kindle verschiebt. Also ich bin mit meinem ja nur so bestenfalls mittelglücklich. Hab ja auch schon viel Kritik geäußert. Ich find die Tasten ganz furchtbar. Ich find's ja bei dem jetzt ehrlich gesagt, gerade die Weiterblättern-Tasten, ich weiß nicht wie du den hältst, um vernünftig weiter zu blättern.
Das ist jetzt nicht so mein Problem, glaube ich.
Also ich hab das so, wenn man irgendwie so im Bett liegt auf der Seite, dann hab ich es in einer Hand das Ding. Meistens so, dass ich es so mit einer Hand halte und dann würde ich gerne jetzt ohne den, also wenn ich so liege, dann drückt sich irgendwie, dann blättert sich das nur total scheiße. Und das war wohl mal beim Kindle 2 besser.
Ja, ich hab halt die Hülle.
Du hast die Hülle dazu, okay.
Und dann hab ich halt irgendwie immer den Finger dazwischen und geh dann halt bloß einmal so hoch zum Weiter.
Ich find die Menüführung ganz, also ich meine, muss man zum Glück nicht viel machen, aber...
Die ist zum Kotzen, irgendwie die Shortcuts rauszufinden, um irgendwas da dran zu machen, ist immer so, okay, ich google jetzt erstmal. Heute musste ich ihn zum Beispiel neu starten, weil ich ihn abgezogen hab, vom USB. Und dann hat er angefangen, mir die Batterie leer zu saugen. Und dann musste ich ihn halt neu starten.
Zu saufen.
Sind wir wieder bei dem Thema? Ja. Und das erst mal rauszufinden, wie du dieses Ding neu startest.
Viel Spaß.
Aber Google hilft.
Zehn Sekunden lang auf den Power-Button drücken?
Welcher Power-Button? Ist genau dieser Einschalt-Klopfer. In der Menüsstruktur musst du dann irgendwo auf neu starten. Aber das musst du auch erst mal finden.
Auf jeden Fall so, allerdings, abgesehen von diesen ganzen Dingern, finde ich das ja schon doch ansonsten ganz schick, das Gerät. Also ich wollte halt auch den kleinsten haben, weil ich eigentlich so nur, weil ich halt keinen Bock hatte mehr auf diese großen Papierbücher im Bett und so weiter. Und jetzt werde ich mal sehen, wie mir das so passt in den Kram, äh, in den Kram passt. Und dadurch, dass ich es jetzt durch meine Flatter-Einnahmen bezahlt habe.
Also ich glaube, als Printbuchersatz ist das echt gut. Aber ich hab halt irgendwie auf ein bisschen mehr gehofft, aber...
Ja, an der Stelle bedanke ich mich natürlich auch nochmal an die ganzen Flatter-Menschen, die das auch aus Mobile-Max wahrscheinlich aus der Ecke recht viel Flatter-Klicks auf meinen Twitter-Account geschickt haben.
So soll das auch sein. Und alle Twitter-Accounts findet ihr auf mobilemax.de/team. Obwohl wir noch kein hübsches Foto von ihr haben, Hucke.
Ich hab jetzt ja ein neues Foto auf meinem Twitter-Account.
Wirklich? Wirklich? Ich gucke. Ich bin gespannt.
Tim ist watching.
So Jungs, ich hab jetzt hier meinen Flatter-Dings eingelöst. Und ich glaube, ich hab auch automatisch Twittern lassen, dass man mich jetzt flattern kann.
Hast du das auch groß?
Puh, nee, das glaube ich nicht, aber ich guck mal.
Das ist eigentlich toll, aber auch schon ganz schön alt.
Ja, ich muss mal wieder irgendwie Foto machen. Ich zoome mal was raus. So, und wie viel hat der Dennis schon als Flitter-Twetterer? 88.
88 war ich, Firefox war bei irgendwie 60 oder so. Gruber ist bei der Hälfte von dem, was ich hab. In Gruber kennt da keiner.
Wer? Gruber? Fire was?
Firebug oder was?
Ein bisschen nervig bei...
Amazon Fire. Fire Kindle, Kindle Fire. Willst du da drüber auch reden?
Das einzige Nervige bei Flutter war ja nur, ich dachte so, okay, das erste Mal in meinem Leben hab ich auf Withdraw geklickt und dann, okay, Paypal oder Moneybook hast du, okay, muss jetzt also in meinen Paypal-Account und dann, ja, okay, ich kann bei Amazon ja gar nicht mal Paypal bezahlen. Okay, noch mal eins weiter auf mein Bankkonto und jedes Mal bleibt wahrscheinlich so ein paar Cent oder so hängen.
Das ist doof, aber leider mangels international gültiger und netzfähiger Paymentsysteme.
Na ja, die Sache wäre ja, wenn es nicht gerade der Kindle gewesen wäre, hätte man ja bei anderen Stores mit Paypal wahrscheinlich noch bezahlen können.
Aber Paypal auf Konto überweisen kostet doch nichts.
Ja, das kann sein, aber das dauert wahrscheinlich einfach.
Aber das Eins, das Abziehen des Geldes auf dein Paypal-Konto, das kostet. Also es geht immer irgendwie was weg.
Ja, aber bei Moneybookers wäre ja auch was weggegangen.
Ja, aber Moneybookers ist auch der Weg noch teurer, aber das Hinschicken ist billiger. Also wenn du hinschicken willst, nimmst du Moneybookers und nimmst du Paypal. Ja, ich hab das nur mal so testweise gemacht. Ich benutze das auch nicht regelmäßig, aber das sind so die beiden Optionen.
You've just received the first fletter, a small step for humankind.
Ne, doch.
Gratuliere, Dennis.
Also ihr solltet sowieso alle mal flettern und Fletter gehört auch. Also ich finde das ja echt cool so.
Kann man Fletter flettern?
Ja, man kann auch Fletter flettern.
Das muss ich flettern.
Jeden Blogpost kannst du da flettern. Ja, die haben es auch nötig.
Das ist ja dekorsiv.
Die können noch nicht leben davon, leider. Das ist schade.
Wo fletterst du denn jetzt für Fletter?
Nö.
Krass.
Das hätte ich ja nicht gedacht.
Na, sitzen halt irgendwie 15 Leute und arbeiten irgendwie. Das kostet schon so ein bisschen.
Ich habe letztens jemanden kennengelernt, der auch bei der Gründung von Fletter mit dabei war, bei dem ersten Brainstorming. Ich hoffe, ich erzähle schon nicht so viel.
Ich hoffe doch.
Und er hat sich mit dem Peter unterhalten. Und... Heißt der Peter?
Peter Sonde.
Genau. Und dann haben die geredet, wie die das so machen, mit der Datenbank und dem, den ich kenne, bei den Vögelchen. Hatte irgendwie alles vor, so mit irgendwie dick Datenbanken. Kennt sich mehr so mit MySQL. Ich glaube, er hat mit MySQL geplant. Und dass er dann die ganze, eine Menge Analogik in der Datenbank macht, da wo es schnell und sicher und...
Atomal und so weiter ist.
Genau. Und das war dem Peter aber irgendwie zu... zu hart gekodet, weil er meinte, dann könnten die ganzen anderen Developer, die da peißen und sonst die programmieren, nicht mithalten und dann wären sie nicht flexibel genug. Und deswegen wurde die Idee verworfen.
Ist auch nicht so cool, in der Datenbank so viel Logik zu machen. Warum nicht? Nee, ab einer gewissen Größe ist das alles andere als Rattenschnell. Dann will man das lieber auf Application-Servern machen, die du beliebig horizontal skalieren kannst. Also die Datenbank möglichst entlasten und dann machst du das halt eine Ebene drüber, weil... Also geht natürlich alles, aber dann musst du dich bei der Datenbank um ganz andere Probleme kümmern und wenn...
Kommt ja auch auf die Datenbank drauf an.
Ja, wenn es MySQL ist und so, dann will man... Ja, so heißt das ja im Fachjargon. Also haben wir ja gerade dieses Thema. Und ich hab das auch gemacht so, schieb es halt in die Datenbank, ist ja sowieso viel cooler. Und ist aber nicht viel cooler.
Also bei hier, bei meinem Bitcoin-Pool, das ist ja eine ganze Menge irgendwie DB-Kram, Postgres übrigens. Und da sind eine Menge Datenbank-Functions, die dann gefeuert werden. Und die sind ratten schnell. Jetzt hab ich es noch Asien gemacht, jetzt ist es noch viel schneller. Du bist zu leise, Tim. Wie kommt es? Das ist ja ganz ungewohnt.
Ich hab mal kurz ein Snickerchen gemacht. Ich wollte nur ein paar Klammer zu Klammer zu Klammer zu Ansagen machen. Also SQL Klammer zu, Flatter. Wolltest du noch was zu sagen? Außer, dass alle mehr flattern sollten. Ich finde das ja auch gut. Es sollten vor allem mehr Leute anbieten, dass man sie flattern kann.
Das ist ja eben mit einem Twitter-Account. Das wissen ja auch die wenigsten wahrscheinlich noch. Dass man halt den Twitter-Account hat.
Ja gut, das geht. Aber es ist halt ein Henne-Ei-Problem. Und viele Leute sagen so, ich werde ja eh nicht geflattert oder ich bin immer noch nicht reich. Das ist halt eine Infrastruktur, die erst mal wachsen muss.
Und es hat bei mir halt auch 6 Monate oder so gedauert, bis ich das jetzt zusammen hatte, oder 7.
Ich hinterlasse eigentlich fast überall Klicks, was ich lese. Also bei mir ist das gar nicht mal immer so ein Toll, sondern einfach nur so, du hast jetzt irgendwie hier meinen Slot gefüllt, für Informationen und Klick.
Ich will eine Autoklickerweiterung. Oder irgendwas, was mich daran erinnert, zu klicken.
Die gibt es jetzt immer. Also was sie jetzt gerade neu eingeführt haben, es stehen ohnehin Änderungen an bei Flutter. Also eigentlich wollten sie dieses Jahr noch was schieben. Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich stattfinden wird, aber da gibt es irgendwie größere Bewegungen. Die arbeiten gerade an sehr viel. Was sie jetzt aber schon eingeführt haben, sind Notifications. Und wenn jetzt du Subscriptions hast, was ich ohnehin für die sinnvollste Sache halte, also alles, wo ich irgendwie regelmäßig kontributieren will, Subscriptions. Und wenn die jetzt auslaufen, nach 3, 6 oder 12 Monaten, was du ja ausgewählt hast, dann gibt es jetzt eine Mail. Also zum Monatswechsel, also wenn der neue Monat angefangen hat und wenn deine Subscriptions quasi dann im nächsten Monat nicht mehr aktiv wären, für den jetzt begonnenen Monat quasi nicht mehr automatisch klicken, dann kriegst du eine Mail, wo drin steht hier, und das sind deine auslaufenden Subscriptions und willst sie nicht verlängern. Das ist schon mal eine ganz sinnvolle Ergänzung. Ich hoffe, dass die anderen sinnvollen Ergänzungen, die ich ihnen ins Heft geschrieben habe, auch alle kommen.
Automatisch ein Monatsabos, die sich automatisch verlängern? Das hätte ich ja gerne.
Ich glaube, das kannst du vom deutschen Gesetz her auch gar nicht.
Nö, das ist jetzt nicht so das Problem.
Also mein Biodorfung pro Weile hat damit keine Probleme.
Also das sehe ich jetzt auch keine.
Aber keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Ich dachte, da gäbe es wegen Jugendschutz und so weiter.
Nö, also unlimited subscriptions, das ist eine Diskussion. Ich weiß nicht, wie sie sich entschieden haben. Und dieses Notificationsystem ist drin. Und dann steht vor allem umfangreichere Änderungen der Webseite an. So, Klammer zu, Wetter, Kinder, Feier. Feuer!
Also ich hab ja nur Reviews gelesen und die waren ja, die klang ja so wie ein typisches Android-Device mit ruckender UI.
Tablet für Arme.
Das ist eine gute Frage. Die hörten sich eigentlich relativ angetan an und meinten so, ja wenn du ein günstiges Device haben willst...
Also die haben nur 8 Gigabyte, haben keinen Karten-Slot zum Erweitern, haben kein, doch WLAN haben sie, aber nur WLAN, die haben kein GSM oder UMTS.
Also was ich...
Der Market Store ist noch ein bisschen... Also was wollen die mit dem Gerät genau machen? Also es ist ja schon ein Android, aber mit Amazon-GUI oben drüber. Und deswegen soll es ruckeln.
Na, es ist die Amazon-Content-Schleuer.
Nee, es ruckelt, weil Edward ruckelt.
Das ist halt einfach so, wie sie derzeit ein Device hatten, um Bücher zu verkaufen. Haben sie jetzt eins, mit dem sie bunte Bücher verkaufen können. Sie träumen halt auch von Magazinen. Wobei, was ich gelesen habe, über so Magazine auf so einem 7-Zoll-Display, also ich meine, das passt einfach nicht zusammen. Und natürlich auch Filme.
Ja, Filme, das glaube ich. Und Musik.
Das denke ich auch. Obwohl, ob der Kindle-Fire jetzt das Gerät ist, was man so mit sich mitschleppt. Wie populär diese 7-Zoll-Tabletten bisher waren, weiß man ja auch. Also, man kann halt nicht mithalten mit so einem Player.
Wie viele Leute so einen, klar, 5-Zoll-Telefon haben oder dringend haben wollen, da ist jetzt der Hang zum 7-Zoll-MP3-Player vielleicht nicht mehr allzu fern.
Also, die meinten dann im Review, dass es auf dem 7-Zoll-Filme gucken wäre super, wäre vergleichbar mit dem iPad. Der große Vorteil, den die dort gesehen haben, war, dass du halt die Bücher automatisch runtergeladen bekommst, dass du dieses Landing-Feature hast, was bei Apple ja noch überhaupt nicht angekommen ist für Bücher.
Was ist das Landing-Feature?
Wenn du in Amerika eine Amazon Prime-Subscription hast, kannst du dir einmal im Monat kostenlosen Buch ausleihen. Für einen Monat.
Ausleihen?
Ausleihen, aus der Bibliothek von einmal.
Ich hab mich gerade gewundert, was da landet, aber...
Und Filme könntest du wohl auch über die Amazon-Plattform dort irgendwie bekommen, wo sie natürlich gemeckert haben, runterladen ist da natürlich nicht, weil das musst du alles online gucken, was für unterwegs total bescheuert ist. Das war so die Kritik.
Ach, man kriegt's gar nicht aufs Gerät drauf.
Doch, kriegst du schon, aber wenn du das über Amazon machst, dann kriegst du es nicht aufs Gerät drauf, dann musst du online gucken, also quasi wie Hulu.
Wenn du es über Amazon machst, über wen denn sonst?
Ja, du könntest ja auch kaufen, dir runterladen und per USB drauf spielen.
Ah, das heißt, wenn du es... Das ist auch geil, also bei Amazon, also der Laden, der dir das Teil verkauft, da hast du die schlechteste Experience sozusagen.
Nein, ich glaub nicht, dass du eine schlechte Experience hast. Wenn du gehst in den Store, sagst hier angucken, dann kannst du es angucken, solange du im WLAN bleibst. Also ich meine, so schlecht ist das noch nicht.
Doch, das ist schlecht, weil ich meine, du willst dir sowas ausleihen und dann gucken, wenn du Zeit hast, und du hast halt dann Zeit beim Computing. Ich meine, wenn du eh zu Hause im Sofa sitzt, dann kannst du dir auch da im Fernseher angucken.
Wer erzählt was das von dir? Hast du nicht erzählt, dass du seit Ewigkeiten nur noch Content auf dem iPhone dir anguckst, weil du gar nicht mehr dazu kommst vom Fernseher?
Ich schließe doch nicht von mir auf alle.
Ja, aber nehmen wir zum Beispiel mal an, du hast einen Mehrpersonenhaushalt zur Familie.
Nehmen wir das mal an.
Ja, das soll vorkommen. Kind will nicht mit den Eltern auf dem Fernseher harken, weil die irgendwas bescheuertes gucken, sondern nimmt dieses Gerät mit auf sein Zimmer und guckt sich irgendetwas anderes an. Dann bist du im WLAN, dann macht das Ding einfach auch Sinn.
Ja, aber auch nur genau dann halt.
Ja.
Ist halt ein Zuhausegerät vielleicht.
Ja, aber dann fragt man sich natürlich.
Na, und zum Bücherlesen und zum Magazinelesen, was hat das für was?
Ja, aber mit zum iPhone dazu, mit so WLAN-Tesoring, das ist es ja.
Nicht mit O2.
Und da hat sich wieder die Brücke geschlossen.
Also ich meine, ich halte jetzt auch nichts von dem Gerät. Weil es ist Amazon und, ach mein Gott, wenn ein Gerät, dann eher das iPad, aber auch das benutze ich nicht mehr. Also insofern, ja.
Also was ich bei den Reviews doch relativ krass fand, dass alle eigentlich geschrieben haben, dass man das zum Lesen eigentlich sehr schlecht geeignet ist, weil zum Beispiel Splattern lange dauert. Splattern? Ja, und das Blättern in Büchern. Das Splattern.
Naja, und wahrscheinlich ist es halt auch ein Hintergrund beleuchtetes Display.
Natürlich, also es ist ein Hintergrund beleuchtetes Display, es ist ein LCD-Display. So quasi wie beim iPad, aber es ist halt dieses...
Lesen ist auch anstrengend beim iPad. Ja, Splattern geht schnell. Ich denke mal, das iPad wird... Wenn es ihnen denn gelingt, zur nächsten Generation auf Retina-Display umzuschalten, dann ist das Thema wahrscheinlich auch...
Ja, aber ohne jetzt die Konkurrenz zum iPad zwangsläufig zu sehen, finde ich... Hätte ich gedacht, oder sagen auch alle, bei einem Amazon-Device erwartest du, dass du perfekt drauf lesen kannst. Also das sollte doch wenigstens gehen.
Wenn du deine Hand ein bisschen anders hältst, dann...
Ihr seid doch hier beide verwandt. Ich auch? Du bist Darth Vader's Bruder.
Was muss ich machen, damit ich so nicht mehr bin?
Nicht das Mikro in die Nase stecken, ja.
Nicht atmen.
Oder so einen Trompetenschalldämpfer davor.
Also wir stellen fest, wir haben eigentlich keine Ahnung vom Kindle.
Ich würds gerne meine Hand haben.
Wir würdens gerne alle mal anfangen.
Max ist doch immer derjenige, der diese blutenden Kantengeräte sofort ausprobiert. Ich hab auch ein Windows Phone als erster.
Ich hab so ein... nein, es gibt ja in Deutschland auch lange nicht. Ich bin ja mal gespannt, wanns überhaupt außerhalb von Amerika verfügbar sein wird. Erstmal muss Amazon daran pleite gehen. Die haben ja so einen unglaublichen Erfolg, dass sie dieses Jahr einen gigantischen Verlust schreiben werden mit dem Ding. Weil die ja bei jedem Gerät irgendwie 50 Dollar draufzahlen und je mehr die verkloppen, desto höher ist ihr Verlust.
Reden wir lieber über Sachen, die wir anfassen und wo wir uns auskennen.
Genau, da möchte ich mal kurz reinschieben. Gerade kam eine neue Version von Camera Plus. Und ich hab mal... also Kamera Plus ist diese kleine App. Und jeder, der die Geschichte kennt, also die Update-Beschreibung ist nichts weiter als Volumesnap is back, bitches!
Was ist das?
Volumesnap? Die sind mal aus dem App Store geflogen, weil sie das eingebaut hatten, dass man den Lauter-Button am iPhone drücken kann, um die Kamera auszulösen.
Ja, aber auch nur über ein URL-Hack.
Weil sie ansonsten gar nicht durchgekommen wären in den App Store. Und darum haben sie es halt als URL-Hack eingebaut. Und deswegen sind sie aus dem App Store geflogen. Und jetzt haben sie die neue Version, die heißt 2.4 VS. Ich nehme an, dass das VS für Volume-Snaps steht. Und wir sind offensichtlich sehr stolz darauf, wieder dieses Feature zu haben. Das Kamera Plus zu einem, der, also es ist eigentlich besser als die eingebaute Kamera-App. Insbesondere, was ich daran sehr schick finde nach wie vor, ist, dass man einen Burst-Modus hat, in dem man sehr, sehr viele Bilder hintereinander machen kann. Und gerade wenn man ein iPhone 4 hat, dann schafft er so durchaus 2, 3, 4 Bilder pro Sekunde. 4S meinst du, oder?
Meinschaft 25 pro Sekunde, ich drück dann einfach auf Film. Ja, aber wie viel schlechter ist die Qualität dann?
Das ist dann an deinem Winkel.
Das ist doch eine andere, ja.
Das ist doch die gleiche, da ändert sich doch nix.
Doch, doch, doch. Der Bildausschnitt ist anders.
Schalt mal um am Kameramodus, dann siehst du, dass der Bildausschnitt deutlich kleiner ist am Kameramodus.
Ja, das hab ich schon gesehen.
Die Auflösung ist deutlich kleiner. Das ist schon was ganz anderes.
Also wenn man wackelfreie Bilder hinkriegen will, dann klappt das oder wo gerade das Tier oder der Mensch oder das Kind oder wer auch immer gerade nicht in die falsche Richtung guckt, dann ist dieser Burstmodus von Kamera Plus schon ganz geil. Das ist ein tolles Programm.
Apropos Apps, die Gmail-App ist auch back. Weil der Chat das gerade schreibt, das hab ich auch schon gesehen.
Was ist diese eklige Webview-Teil da?
Ich kann's mir nicht anschauen, weil...
Gibt's noch nicht im deutschen Store?
Nein, das ist nur im amerikanischen. Ich hab natürlich den deutschen Account am iPhone. Und ja, dann ist es halt nicht.
Deswegen willst du nach Kanada ziehen.
Um die Gmail nutzen zu können.
Also ladet sie runter, bis es sie so lange gibt, bevor Google sie wieder zurückziehen muss, weil die Pushnotifikators nicht gehen oder sowas.
Was ist denn so gut an diesem Kamera Plus?
Das ist nicht zugehört gerade.
Ich hab nur gehört, dass es jetzt das gleiche hat, was die andere Kamera ab jetzt auch hat.
Also erstmal wandert nicht alles, was du als Foto machst, automatisch, also kannst du auch einstellen in dieses Fotoalbum rein, sondern es bleibt erstmal in der App drin. Du hast einen Haufen Filter, mit denen du sowas nachbearbeiten kannst, irgendwie Helligkeit hochziehen, Bildausschnitte wählen, dieses ganze Getöse.
Das haben wir jetzt auch bei iOS 5.
Du hast die Einteilung in 3er-Abschnitte.
Du hast Filter.
Du hast inzwischen auch, ok, na gut, es war doch.
Bildstabilisierung. Du hast einen Timer-Modus. Du hast halt diesen Burst-Modus. Bildstabilisierung ist halt, dass das erst macht, wenn du wackelst. Du hast hier diesen Modus, der heißt Clarity.
Du hast halt nicht mehr wackelt, meinst du?
Was du nicht mehr wackelt. Und was halt, also die Bildfilter, die du oben drauf packen kannst, die sind, also es gibt so einen Clarity-Modus, der kann wirklich auf, also, sieht nachher nicht wirklich gut aus, aber ich hab Aufnahmen, aus denen ich, also doch, einer hab ich dir echt krass gewonnen. Das ist, ja, kann ich jetzt nur zeigen, da sieht man hier dieses Bild, wo diese, wo diese drei Typen sitzen, die konnte man, im Original konnte man die nicht erkennen, weil die, weil das so überstrahlt war. Da gibt's ja diesen Modus, diesen Clarity-Modus, den du draufknallst. Und jetzt sieht's total überkontrastreich aus, aber ich finde, das Bild sieht sehr gut aus und man kann diese Typen da halt sitzen sehen. Ich kann ja warten, kann ich das jetzt hier? Und das finde ich, man kann schön Bilder mit bearbeiten und twittern und dieses ganze Zeug.
Ja, ich mag's auch, also ich benutze das als Haupt-Camera-App.
Genau. Und jetzt halt auch wieder, und sie haben das erfunden mit dem Auslöser in der Taste.
Also wahrscheinlich ist es die App, wo sich Apple alles abgeguckt hat.
Na gut, zumindest eine Menge.
Kommen wir doch mal kurz zum iPhone.
Ach das.
Ja, darüber muss man ja reden, weil es ist ja jetzt gerade 501 rausgekommen und 501 fixt halt einen Security-Bug, der mal wieder von diesem unfassbaren Charlie Miller, der, weiß ich jetzt schon, Track Record hat, der scheint auch irgendwie der Einzige zu sein, der das iPhone irgendwie regelmäßig aufmacht, zumindest der Einzige, der darüber berichtet, wie es geht. Die anderen machen dann immer gleich Jailbreak. Und jetzt hab ich's aber schon wieder vergessen. Hat sich jemand das genauer durchgelesen? Also er hat einen Bug gefunden im WebKit.
Also es ist so, dass das WebKit hat ja mit schon mit 4.0, was? 4.0? 4.3? Die neue JavaScript-Engine, die irgendwie just in time compilert und halt Code erzeugt. Und da auf dem iPhone aber kein Code ausgeführt werden kann, der nicht signiert ist, mussten sie sich da so ein kleines Loch aufbohren, was sie dann gemacht haben. Und der Charlie Miller hat halt rausgefunden, wie er durch dieses kleine Loch durchkommt und weil die bei Apple nicht aufgepasst haben. Da gibt es irgendwie ein Command, das heißt M-Map, was irgendwie Memory irgendwo hinmappt im Speicher, wo dann ausgeführt werden kann, aber nicht. Ich red wahrscheinlich schon wieder total im Blödsinn, aber es sei der hergebunden. Und jedenfalls hat der Charlie Miller diese Löcke gefunden und konnte dadurch wohl Code ausführen, den man, also nachladen und ausführen, was sonst nicht gehen würde. Dann hat es ja wirklich nicht lange gedauert. Acht Tage waren es, glaube ich, oder? Bis das Albes Update rauskam? Oder waren es elf Tage? Es waren weniger als zwei Wochen auf jeden Fall. Und ich glaube, Apple hatte ja eh das Update schon in der Planung wegen dem Battery-Fix oder dem versuchten Fix besser gesagt. Und dann haben sie es halt sofort wieder dicht gemacht. Das heißt, jeder, der jetzt auch noch einen 5.0 hat und später mal einen J-Break haben möchte oder was auch immer, der sollte dann nicht das Update benutzen, weil der nächste J-Break wird wahrscheinlich durch dieses Loch durchgedrückt werden. Falls sie nicht ein anderes haben. Die rücken ja keine Exploits. Also jeden, den die benutzen, der ist ja danach tot, weil Apple den dann dicht machen wird. Das heißt, die werden natürlich erstmal den benutzen, weil der ist eh schon bekannt, solange der halt noch geht bei den Leuten, die es halt haben. Die versuchen ja immer möglichst ihre Exploits zurückzuhalten, weil die danach gefixt werden.
Du meinst, dass du den nächsten erst mit 5 Weins dann quasi, wenn sie einen haben?
Ja, so machen die das immer. Die müssen ja auch sparsam mit ihren Exploits umgehen.
Was natürlich an der Situation ein bisschen blöd ist, wie ich ja finde, ist, dass Apple ihm erstmal aus dem Developer-Programm rausgeschmissen hat, dafür zum Dank, weil er gegen die App-Store-Regeln ver- also er hat ja zur Demonstration seiner Sicherheitslücke, hat er nicht einfach nur gesagt, guck mal, ich hab hier einen Bug gefunden, sondern er hat eine App geschrieben, die diesen Bug enthält und hat sie in den App-Store submitted und konnte dann schön an einer App-Store-App beweisen, wie er eigenen Code einschleust. Sehr eindrucksvoll. Also es ist auch sozusagen, es wäre auch durch die, es wäre auch bei dem Review nicht aufgefallen.
Aber die App kann man eigentlich immer noch runterladen?
Ich nehme an, dass die mittlerweile gesperrt ist.
Die ist doch rausgeflogen.
Also ne, genau, was ich gelesen hab, ist, dass Apple bisher noch nie Remote sozusagen auf den Device des Apps gelöscht hat. Und das heißt, wer das runtergeladen hat, der müsste es noch haben, oder?
Naja, aber wahrscheinlich, wenn er 501 drauf hat, ist dann auch die Sicherheitslöcke flöten. Müsste er zumindest.
Wenn er 501 drauf hat, schon.
Genau. Und, ja, da haben sie ihm erstmal seinen Developer-Account zugemacht, weil wegen Verstoß gegen die AGBs quasi, also gegen hier. Was ich mal ziemlich bekloppt finde, also so. Hey, danke, dass du uns einen Fehler gezeigt hast. Hier, hauen wir die eins in die Fresse.
Na, er hat ja wahrscheinlich nicht den Fehler gezeigt.
Also er hat den direkt, nachdem er es rausgefunden hat, hat er denen eine Mail geschrieben, die haben irgendwie acht Wochen oder wie lange nicht reagiert. Das übliche.
Acht Wochen?
Naja, ob es jetzt acht Wochen sind, darauf nagele mich nicht fest, aber schon eine relativ lange Zeit. Und erst dann ist er damit an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Und daraufhin haben sie ihn halt rausgekickt.
Und das ist ja nun mal nicht so ein extrem Verantwortungsfall.
Sie haben mich ja nicht mehr geantwortet, die haben überhaupt nicht reagiert.
Ja, ich höre immer, dass Apple halt diese Erpressernummern nicht mitmachen will. Also dass Leute Hacks finden, denen sagen, hier guck mal Hacks, hier kannst du uns so viel bezahlen. Weil so läuft ja diese Exploit-Finding-Industrie irgendwie. Und Apple hat da wohl keinen Bock drauf.
Naja, aber ich meine Google machen diese Bounties, mit denen du dann irgendwie, dass du ein bisschen Geld kriegst dafür, je nach Schwere des Bugs, finde ich angemessen. Also ich meine, dann hast du einen legalen Umgang damit. Wenn jemand Bugs bei dir findet, dann kann er sich ein bisschen Geld damit verdienen. Oder ganz schön viel Geld. Und Chrome in dem Fall wird dadurch sicherer. Also eigentlich ist es ja für alle Seiten gut. Insofern finde ich eigentlich schade, dass Apple das nicht macht. Dafür können sie noch mal einen Teil von ihrer massiven Kohle einsetzen. Und mal alle paar Monate ein paar hunderttausend raus schmeißen für irgendwelche Kunde.
Kann ich den Übergang zum nächsten Thema machen? Bitte. Weil wir gerade bei Chrome sind und bei WebKit und so. Ich habe ja letztens festgestellt, ich habe mich leider erst mal eine Zahl verlesen, aber ich habe ja dieses WebKit Nightly. Und da steht dann mal die Revisionsnummer da. Also Apple hat das ja in den SVN irgendwie geschmissen, als die mann, keine Ahnung, 2002 oder 2003 wieder angefangen haben. Mit Safari. Was ja Makar hatte im 11er. Und die haben jetzt inzwischen 100.000 Revisionen gekodet. Also committed. Und da hat mir jemand dann getwittert, dass das auch daran liegt, dass halt Google, weil der Chrome ja nämlich auch mit WebKit läuft, also auf der WebKit Engine basiert, dass die bei Google da Developer wie blöd draufschmeißen auf dieses WebKit-Team. Und dass die bei Apple aber ein bisschen pissed sind, weil die bei Google halt einfach Leute draufschmeißen, die halt auch noch keinen Plan haben und dann da voll loslegen. Und bei Apple ist es so, wenn da einer anfängt, der kriegt erst mal so eine ganz kleine Ecke von WebKit, kann sich da irgendwie austoben oder das erst mal kennenlernen und dann langsam Schritt für Schritt sozusagen weitet da seine Fähigkeiten auf den Rest des WebKit-Codes aus. Und die bei Google, die werden einfach voll draufgeschmissen und können da voll loslegen. Und da sind die gerade ein bisschen ärgerlich. Deswegen gibt es auch 14 Chrome-Versionen, weil die da einfach wie blöd rumcoden.
Krass, was da abgeht, ne? Also, ich hab überhaupt... Also, auch Firefox dreht ja irgendwie total durch. Das letzte Mal, als ich Firefox geupdatet habe, so auf einmal ist das irgendwie so 3 oder 4 Major-Revisions weiter. Ich blicke überhaupt nicht mehr durch.
Das ist irgendwie so, jedes Mal, wenn du es startest, hast du ein neues Update.
Naja, die...
Ein neues Major-Update.
Firefox, die haben ihren Update-Zyklus halt geändert. Die haben den jetzt so ein bisschen Chrome angepasst. Chrome ist jetzt allen anderen ganz schön weg damit gerannt. Mit dieser, mit diesem...
Was heißt weggerannt? Womit weggerannt?
Naja, Chrome legt schon ganz schön vor, was so Features und Geschwindigkeit angeht und so. Und das halt einfach die haben.
Ich kann überhaupt keine Änderungen feststellen.
Die ändern die, äh, ändern ständig alles Mögliche.
Die ändern irgendwas, aber ich kann keine feststellen.
Naja, aber bloß weil du als Nicht-Chrome-Nutzer das nicht bemerkst, ist das ja...
Nee, ich hab nicht gesagt, dass es keine gibt. Ich kann nur sagen, ich stelle keine fest.
Naja, die machen aber, die schmeißen sehr, sehr häufig, alle 6 Wochen oder so was, schmeißen die eine neue Major-Version raus, die nummerieren die halt alle durch. Die haben halt nicht so dieses Update-Prinzip, so dieses, ah, jetzt haben wir mal nicht so viele Änderungen gemacht, sondern die knallen dann einfach eine Zahl drauf. Warum auch nicht? Ich meine, es ist ja im Endeffekt wurscht. Und dann zählen sie halt alle 6 Wochen um 1 nach oben. Und dann gibt es halt eine neue Version. Oder was auch immer.
Ich weiß nicht, ich finde das nicht so wurscht. Ich meine, wenn Versionen nur mal aussehen wie IP-Adressen, dann hat man wie keinerlei Orientierung mehr, was man überhaupt benutzt.
Ja, eben. Und darum schön einfache Zahlen, nur 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, also 17, 18, 19.
15.0.874.120.
Nur die erste Zahl ist wichtig.
Ja, wenn nur die wichtig ist, warum schreiben sie alle vier hin?
Weil das irgendwelche internen Bildnummern sind. Weißt ihr Teufel warum? Also sie haben häufig Major Releases, genauso wie Firefox jetzt. Firefox hat sich dem angepasst. Und macht auch sehr häufig Major Releases.
Und haben die jetzt auch so komische Nummern?
Naja, klar. Also bei denen heißt jetzt, die aktuelle Version ist glaube ich 8.
Also jede Software, die so IP-Adressen als Versionsnummer benutzt, ist bei mir so ein bisschen verdächtig. Vielleicht macht das auch, ja.
Wie viele Stellen meinst du?
Ich weiß nicht, was sollen mir das sagen.
Vielleicht ist die 938 die Bildnummer der entsprechenden.
Ja, was ist die Information für die Benutzer?
Warum zeigen sie mir das an?
Du brauchst nicht zu wissen, welche Version von Chrome.
Sie zeigen mir das an.
Es steht da.
Bei Apple gibt es auch 501 und eine Revisionsnummer gibt es auch noch eine Bildnummer.
Ja, aber 501 ist eine klare Aussage.
Ach guck mal, wenn ich hier bei Line, wenn ich bei meinem Line hier drauf klicke auf die 1072, dann steht da 11C71. Das ist die Bildnummer. Das ist auch nicht besser als bei...
Nee, die Bildnummer ist das nicht. Da gibt es eine Bildnummer, gibt es nochmal extra.
Also bei mir steht hier Bild 11C71.
Nee, aber wenn du ein New Name machst, dann ist die Bildnummer von Line, aber wenn nicht, ist der Colonel 1699.24.8-1.
Aber immerhin sind es keine IP-Adresse, wir haben einen Strich drin.
Ja, das gilt ja sogar in dem Fall.
Ja, aber ich finde, ich muss sagen, ich finde, dass Versions-Major, Miner und Subminer, ich weiß gar nicht, wie nennt man den dritten Teil. Patch ist noch...
Da ist nicht wirklich so. Doch, also du hast ja Major, dann hast du deine Miner, also die Feature-Version sozusagen. Auch wenn du neue Features hast, die die API nicht brechen sozusagen. Das ist die zweite Stelle eigentlich. Und wenn du Patches für diese Version hast...
Okay, das ist die dritte Stelle.
Also so...
Ja, das finde ich nachvollziehbar. Da weißt du irgendwie, wo du bist.
Ja, aber du bist auch ein alter Nerd.
Nein, ich meine, das kann ich auch einem normalen Menschen erklären, was das bedeutet und wie man das zu interpretieren hat.
Ja, aber weißt du jetzt bei Safari 503...
Ja, da weiß ich, dass es die dritte Bug-Fix-Variante ist von dem, was sie als Safari 5 als erstes neu rausgebracht haben. Steht da im Prinzip drin. Aber 15.127.870.14, ich meine... Hallo?
Das ist Version 15.
Fertig. Ist doch auch nicht wichtig. Also, entschuldigung, reden wir jetzt wirklich über die Versionsnummer?
Haben wir sonst keine anderen Themen?
Wichtig ist, warum steht es da?
Also bei Firefox wollten sie das die Versionsnummer weglassen. Da ist dann die Community aufgesprungen. Ihr könnt doch nicht die Versionsnummer weglassen, so dass jetzt die Versionsnummer da steht.
Meiner Meinung nach sind ja auch Chrome Nutzer auf dem Mac, sind Leute, die hätten bei Linux bleiben sollen.
Wieso? Ich nutze Chrome sehr gerne. Chrome ist halt ein schneller Browser.
Die Leute, die sich über eine zu kurze Versionsnummer beschweren, das sind doch bestimmt welche, die vorher einen Kernel selber gebaut haben.
Wie, ich hab jetzt gerade mal meinen Firefox gestartet.
Wer hat sich denn über kurze Versionsnummer beschwert?
Hast du doch gerade gesagt, dass die Google das weglassen wollten und dann?
Mozilla wollte das weglassen.
Achso, gleiche.
Jetzt hab ich gerade meinen Firefox gestartet und da meinte ich bin Version 5.0, hier ist das Update und das ist 8x.
Ja, du hast heute lange schon nicht mehr Firefox gestartet, ich benutze das nicht.
Firefox war nicht letztens, wo noch die mir gesagt haben, dass ich 3.5 habe und ich muss mal 3.6 installieren.
Genau, die haben jetzt ihr Prinzip geändert.
War das nicht erst vor ein paar Monaten? Ich guck mal, was hab ich denn gemacht?
Wollen wir jetzt die allen ernsthaft, die haben halt sich gedacht, die haben...
Ich hab Firefox 7.01, ist das einjermaßen aktuell?
Das ist die aktuelle.
Das gilt aber auch nur noch für eine halbe Stunde nach der Sendung, das ist schwer.
Ist anders.
Die sollten sich mal hier... KoloQuaia, wann haben die das letzte Update rausgebracht? Wahrscheinlich einfach nur so, weil jetzt auch Intel rauskommen muss, so ein Update rausbringen.
Sollte ich mal ein Beispiel, ein TextMate nehmen. Genau.
7 Jahre die gleiche Version.
Oder?
Schon sein Opa hat nur ein TextMate 1.1.3 gecoded.
1.5 mein Lieber.
Wo kann man ja dieses scheiß Firefox erupdaten?
Ich hab mir neulich so angemeldet, dass es TextMate 2 tatsächlich gibt.
Normalerweise müsste die Update stehen, ne? Ja, ne, nicht nur das.
Ich dachte... Ich hab eine Bitte. Lasst uns das permanent durcheinander Geschreie und Gerede und Unterbrechen ein bisschen reduzieren.
Und wieder über Versionsnummer diskutieren.
Jaja, nur ein bisschen weniger unterbrechen.
Also wann kam die 1.5 raus? 2006. Januar 2006.
Also 6, also 5 Jahre.
Okay, es ist bald Januar, so könnte man dann auch sagen.
Also zum 6. kommt dann vielleicht eine neue Version.
Aber 5 Jahre, verstehst du 1.5?
Das stimmt, das waren noch Zeiten.
Gut, kommen wir vorwärts hier. Das iOS 501 Update hat noch eine andere Änderung mit sich gebracht. Hat Max gesagt.
Ja, hab ich gesagt.
Weil...
Das war eine Sache, über die sich Tim beim letzten Mal sehr, sehr aufgeregt hat und jetzt ist er schon weg. Und zwar, dass ja Apple mit 5.0 eingeführt hat, dass alles, was im Documents-Folder einer App ist, automatisch gebackupt wird in die Cloud. Dass sie aber gleichzeitig gibt es noch diese Cache Directory, in der Sachen gepackt werden, die nicht gebackupt werden, aber die auch zu beliebigen Zeitpunkten gelöscht werden. Das heißt also, wenn irgendwie man seinen Podcast-Client hat und er kommt auf die Idee, seine Podcasts in die Cache Directory zu packen, was ja der einzige Weg ist, den Apple zugelassen hat, und der Speicher des iPhones wäre voll geworden, dann hätte das iPhone einfach diese Daten gelöscht. Nach dem Motto, liegt in der Cache Directory, musst du hier bedingungslos wieder herstellen können. Da hat sich Marco Amendt ganz furchtbar drüber aufgeregt. Sicherlich zurecht. Und jetzt haben sie in einer Version 501 nachgelegt, indem sie da irgendwie so ein kleines Fallsystem-Flag eingeführt haben, so Do Not Backup. Das heißt, das kannst du jetzt in deinen Documents-Folder legen. Wird nicht weggeschmissen, wenn die Platte voll ist. Und wird aber gleichzeitig nicht Backupped. Also, tadaaa, so wie es sein soll von Anfang an. Haben sie vermutlich nur vergessen. Wahrscheinlich irgendjemand, nicht mehr zu Steve, sondern zu Tim gerannt. Dann hab ich vergessen, weil ich so trau...
Ja, aber endlich wird Instapaper, wenn du es einmal runtergeladen hast, nicht ständig wieder gelöscht.
Ich hab ein 64 GB iPhone, ich glaub ich hab da 16, 17 GB drauf belegt.
Kannst du mir ein paar GIG abgeben? Meins ist permanent voll und dementsprechend wurde mein Instapaper-Folder permanent gelegt.
Krass, ok, du hattest das Problem.
Ich hatte das Problem ganz arg.
Ja, bei Instapaper, es dauert auch ewig, bis er es wieder herstellt.
Ich kann...
Das Größte, was beim Vierer geht, was ist denn das? 32, dann ja. Und es sind einfach zu viele Podcasts drauf und ja.
Hörst du die auch alle?
Ich hab ein 16 GB iPhone und da ist vielleicht drei oder so sinnvoll.
Machst du mit deinem Telefon, hast du keine Musik, Alter? Doch, aber... Hörst du etwa Lossi Music?
Alle beiden Alben?
Ja doch, doch, natürlich hab ich Lossi Music. Ich hör so selten mit dem iPhone unterwegs Musik tatsächlich.
Leider kein Netz an die Wassernetze.
Nee, entweder fahr ich Motorrad oder Auto oder...
Hast du keinen iPhone-Anschluss im Auto?
Nee, tatsächlich nicht.
Das war das erste, was ich nachgerüstet hab.
Ja, das war nicht mein Auto.
Das ist das, was ich bestanden habe, als ich es gekauft hab.
Ich hab einen iPhone-Anschluss, aber kein Auto.
Du kennst ja schon unser Prinzip so, ne?
Ja, ich hör ja regelmäßig zu.
Ach du bist das.
Dennis hat sich beklagt, dass wir letztes Mal nicht über Fight My Friends geredet haben. Und hat ein bisschen geweint.
Habt ihr nicht erwähnt, dass das Design ganz furchtbar ist?
Ja, da war ich ja sogar dabei, als wir darüber schon gesprochen haben.
Echt, war das während der Sendung oder war das davor?
Winnie, du hast uns nicht darüber geredet.
Winnie, du hast doch alle unsere Folgen gehört, im Gegensatz zu uns.
Ja, dann reden wir, wenn überhaupt jemand überfällt, dann ist das doch okay. Tim hat uns jetzt, wir mussten uns jetzt vor der Sendung schon...
Übrigens seid ihr alle in der Show durch, Wikistraße, Nummer, haste nicht gesehen.
Weil Tim hat vor der Sendung gestern uns nämlich alle unsere Positionen abgefragt, damit er...
Da kam ich schon voll in Panik und ich dachte, die Sendung ist gestern...
Gleich war alle Kanäle auch über, was, wie?
Genau, was bei mir noch stand...
Das stört mich zum Beispiel an diesem temporären Dingsbums, man kann zwar sagen, man ist auslauter, aber man kann nicht sagen, wann es anfängt.
Weil es instant anfängt dann?
Ja, es ist immer so ab jetzt bis irgendwann...
Welche Uhrzeit hast du eingegeben, wann es aufhört?
Heute 22 Uhr.
Und du hast auch keinen Fehler gemacht?
Oh, in der Viertelstunde sind wir frei!
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir...
Weil bei mir stand 13 Uhr.
22.
Ja, als ich es dann aufgemacht habe auch, aber diese erste Request, der ganz vorne so auf dem Dings war, da kommt ja hier so Notification an, die das jetzt, da stand 13 Uhr. Und dann hab ich gedacht, hä? Und dann hab ich überlegt, Cupertino, neun Stunden Zeitversatz, 22 Uhr, minus neun, ja.
Du meinst, sie kriegt schon wieder ihre Zeitzone nicht in Griff?
Ja, logisch.
Sag mal echt, ey.
Ja, jetzt, wo die Zeitzone dann mal kaputt ist.
Dennis, du fliegst hier ganz schön rum.
Wir sind ja Russen, oder was?
Die haben die doch irgendwie abschalten lassen, wie möglich.
Wegen Urheberrechten?
Ja, genau.
Hast du das nicht mitbekommen?
Die Zeitzonen sind vorrheberrechtlich geschützt?
Ein Astrologie-Verlag hat eine Primärquelle für Zeitzonen vor 1990 oder so was aufgekauft. Also so ein Buch, wo Zeitzonen drinstehen.
Ein Astrologie-Verlag?
Genau.
Solche Lunis.
Genau, um möglichst gute Positionen, also um dein Geburtsdatum und Zeitpunkt exakt ermitteln zu können. Und die Open Source Zeitzone-Datenbank, die basiert auf diesen Daten unter anderem. Und darum haben die den mal schön die MCA-Takedown geschickt. Ui, mein Zwei-Stoß! Und darum gibt es jetzt diese Datenbank nicht mehr.
Und das ist so die Quelle gewesen für...
Willkommen in Amerika!
Alles.
Aber was macht die genau? Da kann man sagen, man ist in folgender Stadt, welche Zeitzone oder die Folgenstadt. Ich würde gerne wissen, welche Zeitzone oder wie.
Ja, die haben irgendwie eine API, auf die du zugreifen kannst, wo du dann abfragen kannst, was.
Aber so für das Land, die Stadt, welche Zeitzone?
Die Zeitzone ändern sich ja ständig, was ich auch nicht wusste.
Die wusste ich auch nicht genau.
Die werden regelmäßig mal geändert.
Ach, das ist jetzt hier keine Software?
Das sieht man, wenn man Colonel Commits und so liest, weil da müssen, oder überhaupt für so ein Betriebssystem. Aber auch bei Linux-Fribiers seh ich dann immer, ja, hier Kasachstan ist jetzt nicht mehr so wie die, sondern die haben es jetzt entschieden, sie machen jetzt mal so. Und Kuba zum Beispiel letztens, die haben irgendwie ihre Sommerzeit irgendwie, dauert jetzt bei denen einfach mal zwei Wochen länger als letztes Jahr, weil haben sie gerade mal so Bock irgendwie. Und lauter so eine Sache sieht man immer.
Wenn du Updates machst, da kommt dauernd TZ-Data-Updates.
Ich guck da nie so richtig drauf. Also ich hab mal gehört, ich weiß von einem Fall, dass in Australien, so die Olympischen Spielen in Australien, die Zeitzonen kurzerhand vereinheitlicht worden sind, um es den Touristen ein bisschen leichter zu machen. Und das in irgendwelchen Krisensituationen, wie wenn irgendwie du hast ein Erdbebengebiet und es geht über eine Zeitzonengrenze rüber, und dann sagst du kurz, alles klar, dass jetzt ab sofort eine Zeitzone, bis diese Krise beseitigt ist, weil...
Das heißt, sie stellen dann mitten in der Krise auch noch mal um, hervorragend.
Damit die Helfer nicht so, ja bist du jetzt links oder rechts von der Zeitzonengrenze, damit es da keine Probleme gibt.
Können wir das auch noch mal mit dem metrischen System machen?
Das wäre praktisch.
Vielleicht schaffen sie es dann nämlich doch noch mal zum Mond, weil sie es nicht irgendwie wieder mit den Meilen und den Kilometern vertun.
Die Zeitzone-Datenbank ist wieder online.
Nicht mehr in Amerika. Pirate Bay. Und jeder, der aus seiner Anwand Uhr guckt, wird erst mal abgemahnt.
Find my friends waren wir, glaube ich, gerade.
Warum hast du Winnie nicht eingeladen gestern?
Das hat er dann gemacht, als ich schon hier war. Aber das war die falsche Adresse.
Und bei Huckel kam das nicht an, oder wie?
Na ich hab ja, doch, als ich die App aufgemacht hab, kam es an, aber ich hab ja Location Services für Find Friends aus und jetzt grade angemacht, als du mir im Chat gesagt hast.
Nee, aber warte, warte, du hast die Notifications denn für Find Friends ausgemacht.
Wahrscheinlich auch.
Weil man kann ja in Find Friends, kann man ja da drin, hier bei Me, da kannst du es an- und ausschalten. Das heißt, du musst die Notifications nicht ausschalten.
Ja, irgendwann hab ich ausgemacht.
Mach das einfach hier aus und dann kriegst du trotzdem, wenn ich einer einlädt, kriegst du... Kaum davon alleine. Wahrscheinlich von GameSender oder so, kann das sein?
Ich kenn dieses Foto von dir.
Hey, das Bild ist auch dein Twitter-Bild, ne?
Ach so, doch, das hast du mal im Club gemacht und das hab ich mal in deinen Chattings irgendwie reingemacht.
Zeig mal. Inzwischen kann ich ja vielleicht was über Find My Friends erzählen. Ich hab das kurz nachdem es rausgekommen ist mit den Kokoheads in Wien ausprobiert. Und es war ganz cool, weil es gegen Gruppen Nachrichten dann auch und dann kannst du halt mit der Gruppe... Aber es ging vorhin nicht... .Eye-Messages lustig hin und her schicken, was ich total praktisch finde, weil die haben dann glaube ich so Pizza-Bestellungen und sonst was darüber zu machen.
Wollte ich genau machen, ging aber nicht.
Und das war echt praktisch.
Und das Coole ist, wenn Tim die Gruppe macht und Tim irgendwie die, keine Ahnung, zehn Leute einlädt, dann muss ich nur noch in die Gruppe mit reinspringen und sehe dann automatisch alle anderen, ohne dass ich jetzt extra einzeln ein- und ausschalten muss. Und vor allem, er sagt, zehn Uhr ist vorbei und dann ist auch zehn Uhr, sind alle wieder weg. Das ist halt das einzige, was voll blöd ist. Und ich hoffe, wir hatten es jetzt nicht in der letzten Sendung. Das einzige, was halt ein bisschen blöd ist, wenn ich dieses Fine for Friends, ich hab das natürlich aus, damit die mich nicht beobachten können, wo ich bin, meine ganzen Kumpels. Und wenn Tim mir dann hier diesen Request schickt und ich sag, ja, ja, okay, ich mach bei dieser Gruppe mit, dann sieht mich trotzdem keiner, weil nicht automatisch für die Gruppe mein Fine Friends funktioniert, weil ich es ja für alle anderen aus hatte. Also man kann es noch nicht so fein trennen und tunen, wie man es gerne hätte. Ich finde also das Programm ist ziemlich cool, es hat Potential, aber sie müssen da noch ein bisschen nachlegen.
Aber wofür hast du es jetzt abgeschaltet? Das verstehe ich nicht.
Weil ich nicht will, dass jeder rund um die Uhr gucken kann, wo ich bin.
Na, du musst doch jeder Person, die das Zeug explizit bestätigen.
Ja, aber da sind ja Leute, denen ich will ja auch nicht alle einzeln irgendwie an- und ausschalten, sondern ich bin einfach dauerhaft aus, außer ich will, dass man mich halt irgendwie sehen kann. Also stell dir vor, du hast ja 50 Kumpels, die irgendwann mal angefragt haben, die dich mal sehen wollen. Du kannst jetzt nicht die alle an dauernd einzeln ausschalten und einschalten, oder? Das heißt, du musst jedes Mal einzeln auch immer wieder einladen, wenn du dir einmal zeigen willst, wo du bist.
Also ich hätte auch lieber so Gruppen, die nicht dann, oder bestimmte Levels, sowas wie Familie.
Oder was ich noch gerne hätte, ist so ein Stadtlevel, dass man sehen kann, okay, der ist immer noch in Berlin, oder ist noch nicht losgeflogen, oder weißt schon, oder...
Dass man die Genauigkeit sagt.
Ja, oder in welchem Bezirk er so ungefähr ist. Genau, das wäre noch cool. Dass man sagen kann, okay, so ein groben könnte er schon wissen, dass ich in Europa bin. Falls man mich mal sucht. Ja, er weiß schon, dass man sich halt aussuchen kann, dass sie nicht genau sehen.
Ich bin auch manchmal wirklich gerne die Möglichkeit haben, es so für einzelne abschalten zu können. Oder zumindest ja. Irgendwie so.
Also wie gesagt, für deine Gruppeneinladung hätte ich gerne, dass wenn ich da ja sage, dass es dann auch angeht, aber für die anderen eventuell nicht. Und das ist einfach ausgeblieben, weil ich es halt gerade aus hatte. Dann bemerkst du es halt auch erst mal gar nicht, weil er sagt auch nichts. Der sagt nicht, naja, ist ja ganz gut, dass du zu der Gruppe gehst, aber eigentlich hast du es gerade aus. Da müsste ja so ein Warning kommen. Nee, nix sagen sie und dann kriegst du es gar nicht mit. Also es ist so ein bisschen halbherzig noch, finde ich. Und ich finde, da geht mehr. Die haben sich wieder zu viel auf ihre Lederoptik da gestürzt, als dass sie mal ein bisschen irgendwie an der Technik arbeiten.
Das ist halt ein Basisprodukt. Wenn du was besseres haben willst, such dir eine andere App.
Naja, das geht aber nicht so easy, weil die ist schon ziemlich integriert, die App.
Nein, Latitude funktioniert anders. Latitude liefert die ganze Zeit deine Position an einen Server. Das macht Find My Friends nicht. Find My Friends wird erst aktiviert, wenn du wissen willst, wo ich bin. Das ist im Prinzip genauso wie vorher Find My iPhone. Dann fragst du erst nach. Find My Friends ist kein permanentes Tracking, wo du bist, sondern nur, wenn jemand es fragt. Und ehrlich gesagt, was ich auch cool fände, ist, wenn ich angezeigt bekomme, wer gerade angefragt hat, wer meine Position angefragt hat. Ich würde gerne bei der Person sehen, wann er das letzte Mal geguckt hat, wo ich bin.
Das ist aber auch schlicht, weil manchmal guckt man ja für alle. Wenn jemand die Map aufmacht, dann fragt man ja alle ab.
Oder auch bei der Liste fragt er alle ab.
Dann hast du auch nichts mehr davon, weil dann steht immer vor ein paar Sekunden, vor ein paar Sekunden, vor ein paar Sekunden und das bei allen.
Nee, also jedes Mal, wenn du find my friends offener, würdest du den Nachricht kriegen.
Ich geb irgendwie meine Position. Er kann mir ja sagen, wenn meine Position angefragt wird, ob er das nun irgendwie bewusst getan hat oder ob er das irgendwie, warum auch immer getan hat, steht ja auf einem anderen Blatt.
Ja, das war bei diesem Echo Echo so cool, dass wenn da die Position von mir angefragt wurde, dann hat man noch nicht gesehen, wo der andere ist, sondern erst wenn man dem anderen gesagt hat, wo man ist, dann hat man auch gesehen, wo er ist. Also es war sozusagen immer beide Seiten oder gar nicht.
Das fand ich eigentlich ganz cool. Gibt es das Programm nicht mehr?
Doch, doch, aber ich nutze es nicht mehr.
Was war mit diesem WhatsApp?
Machtest du das auch?
Oder ist das nur Messaging?
Nee, da schickst du einfach explizit die Position rüber.
Genau, aber WhatsApp ist ja jetzt so ein bisschen dann mit iMessage. Okay, es gibt noch Leute, die haben WhatsApp auf Android. Da gibt es auch nämlich andere.
Die gibt es sogar für Blackberry, WhatsApp.
WhatsApp gibt es sogar für Windows Phone.
Ja, okay, also kann man es schon noch behalten, aber eigentlich also mit iMessage jetzt ist schon cool.
Es gibt auch Freunde von mir, die haben es noch nicht verstanden, dass es iMessage gibt und die schreiben wir weiterhin Nachrichten über WhatsApp.
Was hast du denn für Freunde?
Nicht-Nerds, weißt du?
Die haben dich geupdatet.
Aber was bist du denn für ein Freund, dass du deinen Nicht-Nerd-Freunden erklärst, was da Sache ist?
Hey, seh ich aus, als würde auf meiner Stirn Technik-Support stehen?
Also ich bin vorhin eine Freunde.
Das ist ja auch in deinem eigenen Interesse.
Nein, ich kann damit leben, dass sie mir über WhatsApp schreiben.
Ich saß vorhin im Café mit Kollegen zusammen und wir haben da irgendwie gearbeitet. Plötzlich kommt so ein Typ auf uns. Ihr seht doch so aus wie so Freaks bei meinem iPhone. Was muss ich denn da machen, um Tethering einzuschalten? Ja, das stellt sich dann... Ja, und dann hab ich hier diesen Hebel und dann steht der an diesem Schalter und dann sagt er mir, dass ich nicht den entsprechenden Vertrag hätte, um das zu machen. Dann wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht den entsprechenden Vertrag haben, das zu machen. Ja, aber der im Laden hat mir gesagt, ich hätte den Vertrag. Er hat mich belogen. Er war bei Clara Mobil. Klar Mobil. Klarer, Klar Mobil. Klar Mobil? Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Das ist wohl eher unKlar Mobil.
Dann hast du gesagt, geh mal in den Laden und scheiß den Typen zusammen.
Ich hab dann gesagt, geht nicht. Oder er hat das irgendwie gefragt und ist auch schon von alleine abgedackelt.
Fick dich?
Geht nicht. Ich bin jetzt nicht so aus wie so ein Freak, der sagt, fick mich.
Ich kann das schon.
Du kannst das höflicher formulieren.
Ich fände es jetzt sehr angemessen, wenn du die Geschlechtsfickier in deiner eigenen Barsphäre abwickeln würdest.
Und dann hat er nochmal seine Begleitung erklärt, was sein iPhone übers Tessering ist. Das hat auch ein bisschen länger gedauert. Also es gibt auch Leute, die sowas...
Wo wir schon bei Applikationen sind. Ich fühle mich zwar noch nicht wirklich reif. Das ist für eine Podcast-App. Bevor ich es jetzt komplett unter den Tisch fallen lasse, könnte ich ja mal meine ersten Erfahrungen mit Instacast zum Besten geben.
Na dann.
Das entwickelt sich langsam zu so einer Bondage-Szene.
Das war ein Quake-Zitrat.
Wirklich?
Schwierigkeitsgrade bei Quake 3 Arena. Einer davon ist Hurt me plenty.
Der Vorletzte, der nachtern Helmholt oder sowas, oder?
Grundsätzlich muss ich sagen, gegenüber dem Schiffbruch, den da gerade Apple mit seinem Podcast betreibt, mit iOS 5, beziehungsweise auch schon seit langer Zeit, da irgendwie im Geisterschiff unterwegs ist, ist es in gewisser Hinsicht schon mal grundsätzlich besser? Also es hat Vorteile, sagen wir es mal so.
Es ist nicht völlig scheiße.
Also Tim findet Instacast besser, als auf Vinyl zu hören.
Wenn man eine App hat, die befreit einen, also ein Podcasting-App befreit einem einfach schon mal von einem Schmerz, und das ist einfach dieses iTunes-Podcast-Directory, dieser Zwang, darüber zu gehen. Das Ding ist ja an sich ein Segen, gerade wenn ich jetzt, und darüber hatten wir ja zum Beispiel letztes Mal gesprochen, beziehungsweise ich hab ja gerätselt, woher, nimmt den Instacast überhaupt die Information, welche Podcast es gibt. So, und da hatte ich ja noch gesagt, das rückt doch Apple nicht raus. Wie es sich rausgestellt hat, lag ich total falsch. Es gibt sehr wohl eine Search-RP und darüber kann man sehr wohl auch das Podcast-Verzeichnis abfragen. Das heißt, Programme können einfach im Podcast-Verzeichnis das Notwendige herausholen, insbesondere die Feeds. Und aller Wahrscheinlichkeit nach ist es das, was Instacast auch benutzt. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ein Podcast im Verzeichnis auftaucht, ist auch Instacast findbar und abonnierbar. Ja, also das mit dem User-Interface, finde ich, ist bei Instacast nicht wirklich gelungen. Also das ist sehr verwirrend, wie ich finde. Also da sind Merkwürdigkeiten drin, die ich schon eher unter Anfängerfehler abspeichern würde. Solche Sachen wie, du tippst da was an, was spielt, dann kommt da, dazu drückst du dann, jetzt muss ich mal kurz nochmal das hier nochmal kurz nachvollziehen, dass ich jetzt hier keinen zu offensichtlichen Scheiß erzähle. Moment, ich spiel mal hier was ab. Genau, dann sagt man hier irgendwie, spiel mal. Genau, dann kommt dann irgendwie so von unten so ein, so was hochgefahren und dann sieht es eben so ähnlich aus, wie bei dem normalen Podcasting-Player oder dem normalen Music-Player von iOS. Das heißt, du hast da das Cover ganz groß und dann eben unten diese Pause-Play-Controls und so weiter. Und um das dann zu schließen, hast du dann so links oben so ein Dreieck, wo ich sowohl jetzt dieses Dreieck schonmal für extrem fragwürdig halte, weil ein Dreieck ist für mich ein Disclosure-Triangle. Das ist etwas, was anders...
Es hängt davon ab, in welche Richtung es zeigt.
Genau, aber das zeigt jetzt irgendwie nur nach unten und wenn du es dann draufklickst, dann taucht das Ding nach oben zeigend auf, aber dann auch noch auf der anderen Bildschirmseite. Also das ist irgendwie völlig Banane. Also User-Interface-mäßig ist da einfach eine ganze Menge im Argen. Was ich aber grundsätzlich schon mal gut finde, ist, du kannst halt Sachen runterladen auf dem Telefon, das ist ja klar. Und vor allem kannst du auch, ohne das komplett runtergeladen zu haben, hören. Also wenn ich feststelle, hier Podcast, ich war irgendwie jetzt unterwegs, letzte Woche wieder, dann kam irgendwie ein Podcast raus, den ich echt hören wollte. Und es war jetzt keine Option, den im Zug komplett runterzuladen. Aber ich konnte einfach sagen, stream mal. So, und dann hab ich mir so wie die erste halbe Stunde einfach so direkt über 3G angehört. An der Stelle sind wir wieder bei der Bandbreitendiskussion. Also da kriegste halt schnell mal in einer Stunde so deine 50, 60 Megabyte auch zusammen, ganz problemlos. Und das hat relativ gut funktioniert. Also das hat so gut funktioniert, wie eben das Netz funktioniert hat. Es gab dann auch so ein paar Hakelichkeiten. Man muss das Ding dann auch mal neu starten, wenn es sich irgendwie zu sehr verhakt hat. Also Stabilität, da kann man auf jeden Fall noch was dran drehen. Was ich eigentlich total krank finde bei Instacast, ist diese Unsitte vom iPhone, haben sie dann hier auch gleich fortgeführt. Wenn du dann eine Sendung durchgehört hast, springt er dann automatisch in die nächste und springt dann natürlich dann auch genau da, wo du zuletzt aufgehört hast. Das heißt du merkst überhaupt nicht, dass eine Sendung zu Ende ist. Du hörst einfach weiter, wunderst dich irgendwie. Worüber reden die denn jetzt irgendwie? Ich dachte, das kann man einstellen.
Bei Downcast kann man es einstellen.
Bei Instacast geht es nicht. Bei anderen Podcasts, die ich mir noch nicht so genau angeschaut habe, ich glaube Downcast ist einer davon, da kannst du es dann eben auch ausschalten. Das ist etwas, das geht einfach überhaupt nicht.
Bei Downcast kann man die meisten Einstellungen sogar auf einer per Podcast Basis einstellen, was ich sehr angenehm finde. Also entweder global oder für jeden Podcast. Weil für manche Podcasts ist das ja für sehr kurze Folgen, irgendwie so drei Minuten länger. Das ist ja auch ganz praktisch, wenn man automatisch weiter macht.
Was hilfreich ist, du kannst grundsätzlich schon mal deine Podcasts in eine Reihenfolge bringen. Das macht mich auch total irre, auf dem iPhone bei dem normalen Podcasting klein. Das ist einfach alphabetische Sortierung und Face-it. Und das ist alles, was du hast. Du kannst einfach nicht die Sendung in eine Reihenfolge bringen, in der du sie am liebsten hörst. Und dass du siehst, hier gibt es was Neues. Und du hörst sie wirklich so in der Reihenfolge deines Interesses. Das ist nicht drin. Dann gibt es auch noch diesen View, alle Folgen. Das macht es dir sogar dahingehend noch einfacher, als dass du die in der Reihenfolge der Veröffentlichung bekommst. Was auch ganz interessant ist. Oder zumindest manchmal. Dass du dann auch wirklich siehst, wenn die gerade runterladen. Beziehungsweise überhaupt siehst, was ist runtergeladen worden, aus welchem Programm. Dass es also so eine gemischte Ansicht ist. Und was mir aber fehlt, grundsätzlich, ist so ein, also was ich immer wieder habe, ist, ich höre irgendwas und dann werde ich unterbrochen.
Continuous Playback kannst du ausschalten.
Ja, ich hab's auch gerade im Chat gesehen, dass man das, wo denn eigentlich?
Was ist denn Continuous Playback?
Wo sind denn diese Settings?
In der Settings-App.
In dem iPhone-Settings? Welcher Idiot bei Apple ist auf die Idee gekommen, dass man die Settings auslagert?
Was erlauben Strunz?
Ja, was erlaube.
Können wir jetzt erstmal ein Thema, was ist Continuous Playback, wovon redest du?
Continuous Playback ist, dass er, wenn du eine Folge fertig gehört hast, einfach auf die nächste ungehört bist.
Ach so, ach das kann man in dem Anschluss nehmen. Das ging ja auch nicht über die Fertigsten.
Okay, siehst du mal, das ist das, worum ich eigentlich nicht drüber reden wollte. Weil ich einfach so viele Sachen noch nicht entdeckt hatte. Aber da war ich doch irgendwo. Das hab ich übersehen. Na okay, gut, alles klar. Super. Ich hab nix gesagt. Grundsätzlich, was mir noch fehlt, ist ein Recently Played. Also ich hätte einfach gerne eine Übersicht der letzten Sachen, die ich gespielt habe. Also angehört habe. Das passiert mir immer wieder, dass ich irgendwie was anderes abspielen muss. Was weiß ich. Dann gehst du in Twitter, dann klinkst du auf irgendeinen bekloppten Link, dann musst du dir doch nochmal ein YouTube-Video anschauen und dann bist du irgendwann wieder in diesem Modus, so jetzt könnte ich mal meinen Podcast wieder weiterhören. Und dann gehst du in diese Abreihen und du hast einfach keinen Plan, was du gerade gehört hast. Und wenn du so die 25. Folge von HR2 der Tag, die drei Monate alt ist und das ist bei dir irgendwie an der 20. Stelle gehört hast, dann hilft dir einfach dieses Programm überhaupt nicht, dabei herauszufinden, was du vor 5 Minuten als letztes gerade noch gespielt hast.
Hat nicht so ein Now Playing-Button wie?
Ja, Now Playing, aber wenn es nicht Played, dann findest du es halt nicht mehr.
Na ja, aber auch wenn du Pause gemacht hast.
Ja, manchmal will ich aber auch das Vorletzte, was ich nochmal und weißt du, nochmal, also ich will einfach mehr arbeiten können mit meinem Podcast. Das ist, gerade wenn du mit kleineren Sachen arbeitest, wäre das sehr sinnvoll. Also ich denke, an der Stelle könnte sich die Software noch nennenswert verbessern.
Ich frage mich, ob du es gerade wo ins Interface einbauen würdest, aber das ist eine andere Frage.
Ich würde auf der Hauptansicht, ich finde die Hauptansicht ist schon mal so ein bisschen verwirrend. Die könnte schon mal so verschiedene Views haben. Also wie zum Beispiel diese Recently Published, was da oben alle Folgen ist, was nochmal so ein eigener Eintrag ist, das könnte man auch mit Taps machen. Weil das, was er da unten hat, ist so ein bisschen verwirrend. Das Plus, dann dieses komische Sternchen und das verwirrt mich einfach, was da ist.
Also User-Interface technisch finde ich die App grausam. Nicht funktional. Ich sehe da überhaupt nicht durch. Auch teilweise gehe ich in irgendwelche Podcasts rein und der fängt automatisch an, sie runterzuladen. Bei anderen macht er das aber nicht und ich verstehe irgendwie überhaupt nicht, warum er das jetzt bei einigen tut und bei anderen nicht. Ja. Und dieses Standard-Blau lässt sich jetzt auch darüber streiten, ob das schön ist oder nicht.
Was aber grundsätzlich richtig gemacht wurde, ist so dieses, was zum Beispiel das iPhone selber überhaupt nicht richtig hinkriegt, also dieser Podcast-Player. Du kannst halt hier eine Sendung auswählen und kriegst dann eben erstmal den ganzen Info-View mit der kompletten Beschreibung, mit allen Show-Notes, ohne dass du es starten musst. Richtig. Das ist wirklich großartig. Und du kriegst auch die Beschreibung des Podcasts vollständig. Du hast hier einen Link auf die Webseite etc. Also das, an der Stelle finde ich, was so die Metadaten-Präsentation betrifft, geht das schon mal in die richtige Richtung.
Bei mir verformt die ganze App überhaupt nicht. Die ruckelt ohne Ende und sie lässt sich überhaupt nicht gut bedienen bei mir.
Auf einem iPhone?
Vier.
Das ist bei mir nicht so. Ruckelt immer oder was, überall?
Na gut, jetzt gerade natürlich Vorführeffekt geht es einigermaßen.
Nee, es ruckelt trotzdem.
Hilft halt nichts. Und vor allen Dingen gerade, wenn er updated, wenn du sie gerade mal frisch gestartet hast, ganz grausam, da lässt er sich überhaupt nicht bedienen. Da kannst du auf einen Podcast klicken und er geht einfach mal fünf Minuten nicht rein, gefühlt.
Naja, ich werde das auf jeden Fall noch weiter fortsetzen. Ich werde mir auf jeden Fall noch mal zwei Wochen Instacast geben, denke ich. Und schauen, wie das Leben damit ist. Achso, ja, was grundsätzlich ein Problem ist, hier bei Feeds, die ein Passwort brauchen, das funktioniert nicht. Da sei wohl vor ein paar Updates mal ein Fehler gekommen. Der ist irgendwie nicht... Du kannst da nicht ordentlich Username, Passwort eingeben und so. Das muss auf jeden Fall gefixt werden. Da frage ich mich, was das Problem ist. Benutzt er irgendwie nicht die eingebauten HTTP-Access-Routinen an der Stelle? Macht er da irgendwas eigenes?
Vielleicht haben sie ihren Delegate vergessen zu setzen. Man muss ja auch immer die entsprechenden Methoden abfangen.
Ja, wie auch immer. Das funktioniert nicht. Ja, ich glaube, das ist jetzt erstmal alles, was ich mir so notiert habe. Trotzdem, man kann das ausprobieren. Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal eine Verbesserung.
Zum Thema Instacast kann ich sagen, ich bin ja der Beta-Tester quasi. Und jetzt kommt da demnächst, durfte ich erzählen, ich habe gerade nachgefragt, Instacast HD. Muss wohl ein paar Tagen kommen. Also die iPad-Version.
Das kommt dann als Separate ab, oder was?
Das kommt als Separate ab. Ich finde es... Ich finde es... Also es hat iCloud-Synchronisierung mit Instacast. Ich finde so... Ich glaube nicht, dass ich Podcasts auf dem iPad hören werde, aber ich finde es bisher die gelungenste Podcasting-Umsetzung, was das User-Interface angeht. Also wir haben hier so eine vertikale Liste mit so schönen Vorschaubildchen. Ich halte das hier gerade mal so hoch, damit ich das auch zeigen kann. Dann hat man hier so eine riesengroße Tafel, wo quasi die Show Notes stehen, dann kann man hier so... Rutsch, Swipen durch die einzelnen Folgen. Hat unten nochmal, kann man auch nochmal hier so jede Folge extra sehen. Hat hier nochmal ein Menü, falls man mag, mit allen Folgen. Und die nutzen den Platz also auch wirklich vernünftig aus. Also es ist, und ich hab das Gefühl, dass es ein kompletter Rewrite from scratch ist. Ich vermute auch stark, dass es das ist, dass deswegen eine HD-Version ist, um so die Fehler, die sie bei der alten Version gemacht haben, ein bisschen ausmerzen zu können.
HD-Version, du meinst eine separate Version?
Ja genau so. Ja, also diese separate Version.
Heißt das wirklich so?
Was? Ja, das ist doch so üblicher, dass... iPad-Version heißt HD.
Ich glaube, ich lade das.
Wie heißen die Versionen, wenn die welche für das Retina-Ding machen?
Das ist die, wo sie gedownloaded wurde. Retina-Explorer, die sind schon eingeladen.
Gut zu wissen, dass sie da... Wieso bist du ein Beta-Tester eigentlich?
Und warum ist da kein Mobile-Max dran?
Bist du da eigentlich eingeladen worden oder so? Hast du Privilegien?
Ich bin mal net gefragt worden. Also nein, eigentlich bin ich darauf hingewiesen, weil, hey, schreib mal da eine E-Mail hin, wenn du ganz nett bettelst, hier ist meine Device-ID und da war es mal nicht so schön.
Das ist eigentlich die einzige Podcasting-Up, die aus Deutschland kommt?
Ich kenne sonst keine. Mich auch nicht. Jetzt mache ich schon mal ein Witz, wenn ich der Beta-Tester bin.
Ich halte dir das jetzt auch jedes Mal vor.
Doch doch und da hat Tim gesagt, ich will kein Beta-Tester sein, ich will fertige Software haben.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt auch. Wolltest du mal ein bisschen aufziehen?
Wie hast du das mit dem Umstieg gemacht? Ich hab ja noch Sachen in iTunes drin und jetzt hab ich da Sachen drin.
Clean Slate. Ich hab einfach alles, ja das war für mich auch mal sehr gut, um mal wieder mit darüber im Klaren zu sein, was ich eigentlich wirklich hören möchte und was ich wirklich abonnieren möchte. Ich hab halt Dinge vermisst und dann hab ich sie da eingetragen. Das kann man auch anders machen. Also ich schätze mal, wenn ich jetzt auf andere Clients umsteige, dann wird vor allem das ein Thema sein, dieses Exportieren, Importieren von Podcast-Subscription-Listen. Da gibt es ja allerlei Möglichkeiten mit OPML und so weiter.
Ja, um die Subscriptions ging mir jetzt gar nicht. Die Episoden, die du gehört hast, die hab ich nicht.
Genau. Ja, das gleiche. Einfach Clean Slate.
Da würde so viel Gutes herunterfallen, das find ich nicht gut.
Hast du da wirklich so ein komplexes...
Dein Hören, schon bereits gehört, startest du?
Sachen, die ich noch nicht gehört hab, die jetzt im Instacast einfach nicht mehr auftauchen würden.
Was du machen kannst ist, die haben... Also iTunes hat ja ein OPML-Export.
Ja, aber da sind die Episoden nicht mit drin. Da hast du nur die URLs von Podcast-Videos.
Achso, also quasi den gehört Status schon, den hättest du gern. Okay, ja, der ist da nicht dabei.
Wobei Instacast ja auch durchaus die iTunes-Library durchgehen könnte, da müsste es ja eigentlich drinstehen.
Ja, aber sie bieten das nicht an.
Also sie haben offensichtlich irgendeinen Trick, mit dem sie rauskriegen, welche Podcast du hörst. Also zumindest bei Instacast gab es so einen Button, soll ich mal nachgucken für dich, und das dauert irgendwie ein bisschen länger. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie sie da genau vorgehen. Ich nehme mal an, dass sie irgendwie auf den iPod-Modus zugreifen und dann die Liste der Songs durchgehen.
Ja, aber das sind auch nicht alle bei mir drin. Also ich bin echt über OPML und...
Was ist mit dir?
Das geht sehr gut.
Ja, das geht, es ist halt jedes Mal nerviger Aufwand. Also ich find's ein bisschen...
Also besser als einzeln hinzufügen. Dafür geht es erstaunlich gut.
Also die URLs reintippen, das geht gar nicht. Das hat mich von diesem Podcaster auch immer ein bisschen abgehalten. Das geht bei Instacast. Die haben halt dieses Discovery-Feature. Und das hat Downcaster auch. Also dass man anfängt einen Namen von Podcast einzugeben. Dann ist er halt drin und dann kann man ihn automatisch subscriben. Das geht super. Und so viele hör ich jetzt nicht. Also ich probiere das ja immer ein bisschen begrenzt zu halten. Aber im Endeffekt komme ich doch irgendwie dazu, das zu hören. Das kostet ja die Leute, bei denen man es auch lädt, kostet es ja auch Bandbreite. Ich probiere das mal so ein bisschen knapper zu halten. Lieber nur das, was ich wirklich höre. Und dann mal lieber eine einzelne Folge von irgendwas.
Flipper. Voll 3D.
Neues oder ein altes? Neues, ne?
Das ist total spannend, die Sendung gerade für dich, oder?
Das iPad ist neu, sondern altes.
Du bist mein altes Sender, mein Freund.
Ein altes.
Aber deswegen will ich jetzt bei Sachen, wo ich mich überhaupt gar nicht auskenne, keinen Schluss.
Aber ich kann mal über ein iPhone-Spiel, das mich sehr gefällt. Ich kann mich mal über ein iPhone-Spiel, beziehungsweise iPad, ich hab es auf dem iPad gespielt, das ist bestimmt auch in eurem App-Store fast auf Platz 1. Wo ist mein Wasser? Where is my water? So ein Disney-Spiel, klingt wirklich ganz furchtbar. Ich fand das sehr süchtig machend. Kostet irgendwie 79 Cent, läuft hervorragend auf dem iPhone und auf dem iPad. Das einzige, was nicht geht, ist, dass er den Spielstand automatisch synchronisiert zwischen beiden Geräten, was ich eine totale Katastrophe finde, weil wenn ich so ein Level auf dem iPad angefangen habe, dann würde ich das gerne mal auf dem iPhone weiterspielen an der selben Stelle und nicht wieder von vorne anfangen müssen.
Ist es denn dieselbe ab?
Ist dieselbe ab, ja. Aber das ist auch nicht so ein großes Problem, weil ich hab's komplett durchgespielt mittlerweile. Ich hoffe jetzt, dass wir bald ein paar neue Level kommen. Das ist... Also es ist so ein... Das Maskottchen ist ein kleines Krokodil, das in der Kanalisation lebt, was in die Badewanne möchte. Und dann ist irgendwo Wasser und du musst ihm die richtige Wasserverbindung graben, damit das dann das Wasser in seine Badewanne läuft und du musst dabei Versen Hindernisse überbringen. Also so ein Puzzlespiel mit ein paar Leveln, mit ein bisschen so auch Geschwindigkeit und Geschicklichkeit fand ich sehr angenehm.
Ein schönes Puzzlespiel, was ich auch, wo ich extrem lange schon darauf war, dass mal neue Levels kommen, ist ja Colorbind.
Warte mal, bist du sicher, dass das Where is my water heißt?
Ich finde da auch nichts brauchbares.
Irgendwas mit...
Du wederst.
Gib mein Wasser ein.
Dennis.
Wo ist mein Wasser?
Wo ist mein Wasser? Auf Deutsch.
Oder Where is my water?
So Schnieschnaschnappi mit.
Also ich hab da, ich hab's natürlich nicht insofern durchgespielt, dass ich mir alle Bonus-Level frei gespielt habe und so was, für die man dann auch eine ganze Menge anderes zeugt. Ich hab so jeden Level gespielt und...
Ich hab jeden Level gespielt.
Ich hab alle schon gesehen. Ja, aber ich find's nervig, so ein paar Spiele, die echt cool sind, wo dann niemals neue Levels rauskommen, ist voll nervig. Also das Colorbind, das fand ich auch total schönes Spiel, also einfach auch ästhetisch sehr ansprechend.
Colorbind oder blind?
Das, wo man immer die drei gleichen oder komplett unterschiedlichen Dinger finden musste?
Nee, nee, da musste so... Color... Also so links oben genau. Musste eigentlich so Punkte verbinden, dabei entstehen aber immer sehr ästhetische Muster und Patterns dann am Ende. Du denkst ja halt so am Anfang, oh Gott, wie soll ich die jetzt alle sinnvoll verbinden? Aber am Ende macht es dann total Sinn. Und die sind halt echt cool, die Puzzles und die Levels, aber keine neuen Levels. Hast du einmal durchgespielt und dann verschenktes Geld, ja? Die könnten einfach neue Levels rausbringen. Peng. Einfach gleich wieder...
Die ganzen 80 Cent im Orkus.
Ja, nee, aber ich mein, für Levels, also ich würde auch für neue Levels was bezahlen. Also zum Beispiel dieses Labyrinth ganz am Anfang, das erste Spiel, was da so... Die haben das so cool gemacht, dass alle User erst mal sich selber Levels bauen können, dass du die Levels da auch, dass ihr noch Levelpacks nachladen kannst und so, die war... Kannste endlos spielen, bis du keinen Bock mehr auf dieses scheiß Labyrinth insgesamt hattest.
Also damals hat dieses Labyrinth... 150 Levels. Hatte sich von den Kids in seiner Nachbarschaft machen lassen.
Oh man.
Aber da kann ich ja mal erzählen, wo ich davon überhaupt erfahren habe, von diesem Spiel. Und zwar war ich da hier in Berlin auf dem Apple iOS 5 Tech Talk.
Der war jetzt kürzlich, ne?
Genau, war so eine Art Mini-WWDC. Und ich war eine der Glücklichen, der da hingekommen ist. Also offensichtlich wurde hart gesiebt. Wir haben uns bei uns in der Firma, haben sich fünf Leute beworben, da hinzugehen. Zwei davon sind zugelassen worden. Wir haben sehr stark das Gefühl, wer noch nicht auf der WWDC war, ist da vorgezogen worden.
Mich haben sie nicht reingelassen.
Ich war auf der WWDC. Das war so eine Veranstaltung von Apple, erstaunlicherweise kostenlos, wo man so ein paar WWDC-Talks live vorgeführt bekommen hat.
Also von Band?
Nein, nein. Die Leute fahren durch die Welt. Mit den echten Leuten, die das auch auf der WWDC machen. Genau, mit den Leuten. Die kommen vorbei und stellen sich hin. Die kannst du dann auch nach der entsprechenden Veranstaltung noch anquatschen. Es gab noch das Lab, wo du mit deinem Code hingehen konntest und sagten, ich hab hier ein Problem, helf mir mal weiter.
Hands on.
Und dann hätte der Typ, wenn du Glück hast, der Typ, der dir den Code geschrieben hat auf Apples Seite, hätte beschreiben können, warum das so funktioniert. Oder hätte sagen können, oh, oh, funktioniert ja gar nicht. Das war eine sehr, sehr krasse Veranstaltung, muss ich sagen. Vor allen Dingen war die extrem äppelig. Also was ich nicht gedacht hätte...
Was ist denn das?
Die Playlist, die gespielt wurde, wenn in einem Raum keine Veranstaltung stattfand, war von Apple vorgegeben. Jede Wette, da war so viel Coldplay dabei. Und hier diese ganzen Sachen, die die immer in einem Werbespot spielen. Die Talks waren... Also bei einigen hat man gemerkt, dass sie gejetlagged waren ohne Ende. Berlin war die erste Tour hier. Die waren einfach todmüde. Das hat man bei ein paar gemerkt. Dann kann es natürlich sein, ich habe mir über OpenGL ES da einen Vortrag angehört. Der war so... Ich habe wirklich nichts verstanden, warum es dagegen ging. Über Airplay gibt es auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu sagen. Aber die hatten halt alle ihren fetten, riesen Bildschirm auf der Bühne stehen. Die hatten perfekt gemachte Slideshows dabei. Das hat Stringent, das hat ein Tempo. Du hast alles verstanden. Also du hast, wenn du von dem Thema Ahnung hattest, hast du alles verstanden. Es kam nicht so eine Scheiße wie, ich fange jetzt hier mal an, auf der Bühne Kot zu tippen, um zu zeigen, wie einfach das ist. Sondern hast halt die Slideshows, so sieht der Kot aus. Ihr wisst schon, dass der Kot... Ich meine, davon geht man dahin, dass es funktioniert. Das hat einfach wirklich gestimmt. Die Tiefe war absolut okay. Einen Vortrag, den fand ich sehr großartig, der war hier mit Instruments, also diesem Tool zum Finden von Leaks und Geschwindigkeitslöchern und Grafikkarten, also Grafikoptimierungsmöglichkeiten und so was. Und das war der Vortrag, den ich mir unter den WWDC-Videos, habe ich da keinen zugefunden. So einfach quasi eine Einführung in Instruments. Also einer, der sich auf die Bühne stellt, so benutze ich das, so funktioniert es. Das hier sind die Ansätze, wie man so seine Performance-Bugs findet und wie man seine Leaks findet und so müsste er vorgehen. Und das müsst ihr machen, wenn ihr Grafik schneller kriegen wollt und so ein bisschen. Das fand ich ziemlich gut gemacht, hatte ich so bisher.
Und wo war das eigentlich?
Auf dem WWDC gab es da auch schon ganz gute Videos.
Ja, also ich hab jetzt bei der letzten, da hab ich jetzt geguckt, hab da überhaupt nichts gefunden. Das war hier in der Friedlstraße, ich weiß nicht, wie das Hotel heißt.
Ich war nicht wieder in einer FU da unten, irgendwie in Dalem.
Muss um einiges besser gewesen sein, als das war vor zwei Jahren. Essen war fantastisch. Also es gab auch Essen. Also es hat sich so richtig gelohnt. Ach, also wirklich so die Detailversessenheit, was um jetzt so zum Thema, das war sehr äppelig. Da hingen so neben der Bühne, zumindest im Hauptraum, hingen so Vorhänge und die waren so blau angeleuchtet. Und das hab ich schon in einigen so Keynote-Videos und sowas gesehen. Das war hundertprozentig aus Cappatino eingeflogen, haben die das mitgebracht, den Vorhaken hingehängt, Scheinwerfer aufgestellt und sowas. Die Mitarbeiter waren alle eindeutig als Apple-Mitarbeiter zu erkennen, aber jetzt nicht total hässlichen Klamotten und so, das war...
Also bei diesem FU-Ding, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das da auch schon ums iPhone ging oder noch nicht, warst du da auch?
Nee, ich war da nicht.
Und was ich ein bisschen blöd fand, glaube ich, dass da halt eine Menge einfach nur da waren, weil es cool war. Also ich glaube, wahrscheinlich war die Hälfte überhaupt gar keine Developer oder so.
Deswegen haben die da diesmal wahrscheinlich gesiebt. Auch, sowieso, ja.
Keine Ahnung, ob das da die Developer waren. Wen ich kennengelernt habe, den Entwickler von Tiny Wings. Der ist sehr nett.
Aber wenn sie den reingelassen haben, der war auf der WWDC.
Aber der ist auch furchtbar reich geworden mit so einer kleinen Sasa als Motivation, ja guck mal, da ist er. Also es gab eine Handvoll Leute, die waren offensichtlich da, die auch auf der WWDC waren, aber ich glaube, das grobe Sieb war, wer auf der WWDC war, hatte schlechte Karten. Und ich dachte so, okay, also ich hab von Leuten, die aus der Schweiz...
Aber deine Kollegen waren da wieder alle bei der WWDC, ne?
Genau, drei davon und einer halt nicht.
Also der Neue mit dir.
Genau, der Neue mit mir und der war auch mit da. Und das war, ja.
Ich war auch noch nicht auf der WWDC.
Ich muss mich mal in Central Dispatch reinarbeiten, das ist mir aufgefallen bei der Gelegenheit.
Du musst ja mal für irgendeine Firma arbeiten, die dich dahin schickt.
Ach und was ich...
Meldet euch, ne? Firma melde dich.
Arbeite doch mal bei einer Firma, der dir...
Was bist du für einen?
Ich bin unter Null.
Mach mal einen Pitch, Mann.
Einen Pitch, was ich für einen Job brauche?
Ja.
Na einen für so einen Faulen, sag ich, so ein bisschen Reverse-Engineering. Weil ich bin ja schon so ein bisschen Hacker und ich mag gerne Sachen irgendwie rausfinden, wo man fummeln muss. Also zum Beispiel gegen, weiß nicht, irgendein Zeug porten, wo es schlechte Doku gibt oder keine Ahnung.
Falls die Bundesregierung ihren Trojaner nicht versteht.
Plattform ist dir egal.
Ach so, Richtung?
Objective-C.
Aber egal, ob iOS oder Mac? Aber eins von beiden?
Du bist plattformunabhängig also für beide.
Ja, ich hab ja auf dem Mac angefangen und dann bin ich ja zum iPhone rüber und dann auch wieder zurück.
Nicht, dass das irgendwie falsch verstanden wird.
Na, ich bin nicht so ein guter 9 to 5 Typi.
Sondern mehr so 5 to 9.
Also ich bin schon auch ein 9 to 5, aber dann 9 p.m. und 5 a.m. Na ja, also 5 to 9. Nee, das ist zu lange. Aber neun Uhr abends bis fünf Uhr morgens. Nee, aber ja.
Ein Mann für spezielle Fälle, ich kann ihn nur empfehlen. Wenn es wirklich knifflig wird, Dennis, bleib dran. Das kann ich bestätigen, Dennis. Ich will jetzt nicht zu viel ausplaudern, aber wir haben schon harte Action gesehen bei dir.
Wo denn?
Ich schon sagte, ich will nicht zu viel ausplaudern. Es gab da schon ein paar energische Projekte.
Wenn ich mich in so ein Projekt reinfummel und mir das Spaß macht, dann bist du nicht aufzuhalten. So wie zum Beispiel bei meinem Display gerade.
Da hab ich mich ja auch zu Tode gefummelt.
Woanders schon, jetzt macht er das schon wieder rum. Denen ging das schon alles auf den Sack die ganze Zeit.
Und jetzt läuft's.
Und wie das läuft?
Kinotauglich. 40 Frames, wenn ich will.
Diese Gründe.
Rock'n'Roll.
Rock'n'Roll. Noch jemand ohne Fahrschein?
Der Rest ist verdient. Was ich krass fand, was ich das erstmal so verstanden hab, wie ernst Apple das eigentlich mit diesem Post-PC-Era meint. Also das ist so, das war so das, also erstens macht alles mit ARK was geht, das war so die Ansage, dieses Automatic Retain Counting. Darauf wollen sie, aber dieses Post, so oft ist das gefallen. Hey Leute, wir leben in einer Post-PC-Era, das müsst ihr hinbekommen. Ihr müsst immer Dokumente in die Cloud speichern, das und das und das. Wir wollen komplexe App haben. Also das ist...
Ja, das mit den Dokumenten in die Cloud speichern, ich glaube, da wollen die halt auch ihre User bei den Eiern packen. Oder, ja, jedenfalls. Also ich muss jetzt mal kurz da reinspringen, ja? Ich hab ja irgendwie kein iCloud, weil ich meine... Mein Personal-Data und alles, was ich so mache, ich will das nicht irgendwie bei Apple gespeichert haben, deswegen speichere ich das auf meinem iPhone. Und wenn ich dann halt eben demnächst, irgendwann, den nächsten Jahren ein iPhone mit mehr Gigabytes kaufen muss als andere, weil ich irgendwie alles lokal speicher, das würde ich noch einsehen. Aber wenn natürlich jetzt alle Programme anfangen, alles immer grundsätzlich in der Cloud zu speichern, dann würde auch ich irgendwann halt, wenn man das nicht abschalten kann, und das ist ja, wo es hingehen wird, würde ich auch mit diesen freien 5 Gigabytes nicht mehr hinkommen. Und dann wird man gezwungen auch noch irgendwie abzudaten demnächst. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das so das Tolle ist.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube keine Sekunde lang, dass Apple dich irgendwie zu irgendwas zwingen wird. Meinst du? Also ich, es ist, ähm, warum sollten sie? Also ich meine...
Na weil die doch an den Subscriptions für den Speicher verdienen, wie blöd.
Ach! Ich glaube, also ich meine, da sind 5 GB dabei, das reicht. Wir haben ja gerade gesprochen, was alles in so einem Backup dabei ist und was nicht dabei ist. Die Apps sind gezwungen dazu, da möglichst sparsam mit umzugehen mit diesen 5 GB Speichern. Das heißt, ich hab da jetzt ein iPad und ein iPhone jeweils komplett gebackupt in diesen 5 GB. Hab noch...
Du, das iOS ist jetzt seit seit 4 Wochen draußen. Wart's mal noch ein paar Monate ab, wenn alle Programme es erstmal auch nicht einsetzen.
Wieso die Sätze? Also ich meine, es wären doch alle Daten, also alles was die im Documentsfolder haben, wird doch schon jetzt gebackupt.
Bei mir liegt es wahrscheinlich an dem Instapaper, weil bei mir war es irgendwie 4,8 nur das iPhone. iPad ging überhaupt nicht.
Vielleicht irgendein Podcast-Client, der da noch besaugt hat oder sowas?
Zu der Zeit.
Also bei mir hat es wirklich... Ich hab noch... Ich kann gleich mal gucken, wie viel ich da noch frei habe. Aber das hat hervorragend funktioniert. Und ich glaube, denen geht es darum, wirklich so billig, wie es klingt.
Aber das geht doch nicht nur ums iPhone. Das geht doch im Prinzip... Ich meine, wenn iCloud wirklich eine Perspektive für your stuff in the cloud ist, dann gehört ja auch das, was ich zwischen meinem Mac und meinen anderen Macs sharen will dazu. Das, was ich derzeit mit Dropbox mache.
Ja, aber das machen sie ja auch explizit nicht, weil sie es noch nicht können, offensichtlich.
Ja, das kommt auch.
Und dann brauchst du auch mehr Speicher.
Ja, dann gibts halt mehr Speicher.
Die das machen sie nicht, weil sie es nicht können.
Sie haben ja auf der, bei der, das hat ja noch Steve erzählt bei der WWDC-Präsentation damals, warum sie zum Beispiel nur die letzten 1000 Fotos von dir da in den Foto-Stream packen, weil mehr Speicher haben wir einfach nicht. Und die müssen halt ein bisschen mit dem Speicher umgehen. Und natürlich ist das ein Login, also es soll möglichst komfortabel sein und wenn du ein iPhone hast und ein iPad, dann möchtest du, dass da alle Daten immer synchronisiert sind, dass ja auf deinem Mac die Daten auch da sind. Das ist ja auch geil. Ich finde es mittlerweile schon sehr angenehm, dass ich nur noch iPhotostarten brauche, da das Foto aufmache, was ich gerade auf meinem iPhone geschossen habe. Und es ist da und ich muss nicht gucken, wie ich es auf mein iPad rüberkriege, sondern es ist einfach da. Wenn ein O2 geht. Nee, das geht ja eh nur über WLAN.
Aber so nicht, das funktioniert bei mir nicht. Also bei mir auf dem Mac, in der Aperture, tauchen die Bilder nicht sofort auf. Es dauert teilweise eine Stunde.
Also das ist bisher bei mir so.
Dann sind deine Fals vielleicht in der Opium Cloud.
Verzögerungen hab ich da auch gesehen. Wobei ich hab jetzt diese ganze iCloud-Transition noch gar nicht so richtig mitgemacht. Das ist auch ein völlig unklarer Zustand. Ich hab zwar irgendwie so iCloud, da wo es so Features gibt, die nur iCloud sind und alles andere hab ich noch bei MobileMe. Also mein Primary Sync ist auf jeden Fall noch MobileMe, aber er synkt dann teilweise und das hab ich gar nicht so eingeschaltet, sondern es hat es einfach eingeschaltet. Dieses Lien, dieses Drecks-OS, über das wir eigentlich auch nochmal reden müssen. Dieser Quatsch. Ich hasse Lien mittlerweile. Es macht mich wirklich verrückt. Ich hasse es nicht, aber ich bin nicht zufrieden. Dann ist es mal so.
Jetzt kommt der Rant.
Ja, noch nicht ganz.
Er ist noch nicht warm.
Ich hab ein bisschen Angst davor, jetzt komplett auf iCloud zu gehen. Ich warte jetzt einfach nochmal ab, wie viele Leute noch irgendwie schreien, dass sie alle ihre Kalendereinträge verloren haben und so weiter. Bisher kam noch nicht so viel.
Für Kalender, Mail und Adressen und so bleibe ich erstmal bei Gmail. Das ist eine funktionierende Lösung und bisher bin ich von Google noch nicht angepisst genug, um da wegzugehen.
Na gut, das hat für mich noch nie funktioniert.
Ich war angepisst genug, nicht hinzugehen.
Ich verliere halt Sachen, wenn ich jetzt zu iCloud gehe, dann gibt es halt keinen Keychain-Sync gegen. Ja, was denn?
Gibt es auf dem Mac und auf dem iPhone.
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt, ich bin...
Aber du hast die neueste Version nicht getestet. Ich hab mit ihm noch mal drüber geredet. Dass du nur in der Beta bist.
Ich hab ganz furchtbar geschwimmt.
Na toll.
Das Beta-Häschen hier.
Und ich weiß noch nicht mal, dass es das gibt.
Ja deswegen bin ich hier.
Ist das nur Beta?
Nee, das ist draußen.
Auch das noch? Ich gehöre wohl nicht mehr zu den coolen Kids oder was?
Du bist raus.
Podcast-Oper. Podcast-Oper.
Da kann man ja auch mal Werbung machen für Jolly's Fast VNC, den wahrscheinlich schnellsten VNC-Klein überhaupt. Und den besten. Der kann SSH über SSH mit Public Keychain, na wie heißt das gleich? Hier die entsprechenden Files mit Keychain. Egal. Also ohne Passwort. Ohne SSH-Passwort. Wie heißt das?
Egal.
Also alles VNC.
Alles. Alles. Hab ich alles gesehen. Damit kannst du die Schlüsselbünde synchronisieren.
Genau. Von deinem Mac aufs iPhone und dort was reinpacken und wieder zurück zum Mac und alles over VR und Magic.
Du meinst, wenn ich auf meinem Mac was in meine Keychain eingebe, dann taucht das auf meinem iPhone auf? iPhone auf.
Und wann?
Eigentlich...
Muss ich dann dieses Programm starten?
Einmal musst du es einrichten auf beiden Seiten und dann macht das das over VR und...
Über iCloud?
Über WLAN.
Du musst das direkt machen.
WLAN Sync?
iCloud kommt bestimmt auch noch.
Jetzt wo es iCloud gibt, WLAN Sync?
Da müssen ja erstmal alle umcoden, die Jungs.
Du darfst in iCloud auch keine sicherheitssensitiven Daten abspeichern.
Du musst ja nicht da ewig liegen lassen. Du musst ja nur kurz und dann holt sich der Andri und dann sind sie wieder weg. Nur so als Temp-Cloud.
Also eigentlich, diesen Sync, den mach ich auch sehr sehr glücklich seit Jahren. Hat mich zwar eine Stange Geld gekostet, One Password, das finde ich ja dafür.
One Password arbeitet nicht auf der Keychain.
Arbeitet in der Keychain. Nein. Speichert sein Zeug aber in der Keychain.
In einer Keychain.
Nein. In einer Keychain, aber nicht in der Keychain. Nicht in der Mac OS X Keychain, wo Programme halt ihre Sachen ablegen.
Ich benutze auch One Password und ich bin glücklich damit, also...
Ja, aber es funktioniert halt nicht immer. In iTunes zum Beispiel benutzt es nicht.
Korrekt.
Das ist richtig, aber ich kann mit dem Copy-Paste leben.
Ja, so ähnlich mach ich das auch.
Copy-Paste?
Ich hab die paar Passworte...
Passwort rausholen, in iTunes in den Dialog reinkopieren.
Da gibt's ja extra so einen Copy-Button, dass du auch nicht mal Apfel C drücken musst, sondern dieses Passwort. Und daneben ist der Copy-Button, dann hast du es erst mal. Also es ist sozusagen so ein Passwortverwaltungstuch. Du magst so eine Dinge auch nicht, und ich benutze es sogar.
Das ist ja genau das, was ich nicht tun will, deswegen benutze ich ja Syncing, weil es sind dann halt...
Aber ihr kriegt es auch nicht in den iPhone Keychain rein, oder? Sondern es ist dann nur in der App drin?
Genau, das ist nur in der App, das ist nicht die iPhone Keychain.
Ansonsten wär es total geil.
Ja, aber ich glaub, dafür gibt's keine API, dass du draufzugreifen kannst.
Eben, deswegen war ich jetzt auch so überrascht.
Ja, aber du hast unterwegs wenigstens deine Passwörter.
Ich glaube, Huckel bestätigt gerade ein iPad.
Na gut, das mach ich ja derzeit schon mit One Password. Also das ist halt gut. Aber schöne Option. Gut, super. Wieder was gelernt. Worüber haben wir eigentlich gerade geredet?
Nein, wollte ich gar nicht sagen.
Naja, ich hab ja nur gesagt, ich geh da langsam.
Er will nur weiterspielen.
Ich hab ja hier auf dem Rechner immer noch Snow Leopard drauf.
Schnee Leopard.
So glücklicher.
Und ich denk mir dann immer so, wann vermisse ich was? Und es war bisher bei allen Mac OS X Releases so, eine Woche nachdem ich das installiert hatte, wollte ich auf keinem anderen Computer mal irgendwas anderes haben.
Jetzt ist es genau andersrum. Eine Woche nachdem man es hat, will man fast schon wieder zurück.
Jetzt ist es schon, wie lange gibt es Line? Monate gefühlt, oder?
Juli irgendwann. Du, ich hab vor anderthalb Wochen geupdatet auf meinem iMac.
Und?
Na ja, ich hab schon eine Stelle mitbekommen, wo ich gesagt hab, okay, scheiße. Was denn? Mein R16, mein Aufnahmegerät für ein Podcast hat keinen Treiber verleihen und der ist immer noch nicht nachgeliefert worden.
Diese USB-Audio-Geschichte?
Da hab ich dann mal kurz...
Ist das nötig, um mit dem Ding überhaupt zu sprechen?
Der wird noch was nicht erkannt.
Na großartig.
Welcher Hersteller? Was ist das R16?
Zoom R16. Also es gibt einen Installer, der angeblich funktionieren soll, aber der Install-Button wird ausgegraut und du kannst halt nicht installieren.
Für Dennis wollte ich gerade sagen, genau. Engagiert, Dennis.
Ich muss noch die Körner-Extensions in System Library Extensions schmeißen, deinen Cache zur Not löschen, das heißt mit Shift starten, sowieso ab und zu mal eine gute Idee, und dann räumt er einmal kräftig auf, integriert ihn und zack, fertig. Oder erst mal von Hand laden. Kekst, load, kekst, unload.
Du bist da bestimmt in der Shell zu Hause, oder?
Na bedienen reicht ja für einen Anfang.
Sag mal, bist du nicht auch in der Shell zu Hause?
Hab ich dich nicht neulich in der Shell gesehen?
Übrigens muss ich auch noch kurz was nachlegen. Ich hatte letztens einen Kunden, der hatte eine Hardware, wo ein Key-Span-Serial-USB-Adapter dran ist. Der sollte unter Leihern laufen. Dann haben wir es nicht hinbekommen, dieses Zeug zum Laufen zu bringen.
Werden die noch verkauft, oder ist das jetzt Legacy-Technologie?
Ich glaube, die werden noch verkauft. Die wurden von irgendwas aufgekauft. Ich weiß nicht, wie die Bude jetzt heißt, aber die gibt es ja, Triplight. Die haben die irgendwie gekauft. Jedenfalls danach eine Stunde fummeln, irgendwie mit ich Kunden am Telefon, der sein Kunden am Telefon, haben wir dann festgestellt, dass sie doch tatsächlich im Oktober die 10.6-Version gepublished haben für diesen Key-Span-Adapter. Also die gibt es jetzt.
Hier steht aber Including 10.7 Lion.
Ach jetzt auch schon, ja? Dann klickt mal irgendwie auf Downloads. Ich könnte schüren, dass da 10.6 stand. Vielleicht war es ja auch ein Schreibfehler.
Vielleicht musst du einfach die neue Version kaufen.
Vielleicht ist es da dabei.
Auf CD? Der zweite von oben ist doch schon 10.6.
Beta, Beta-Driver.
Na dann haben sie jetzt nochmal einen nachgelegt.
Großartig, Beta.
Jedenfalls der 10.6, der neuere von Oktober, der funktioniert auch unter 10.7. Aber die sind ein bisschen hinterher da, die Jungs.
Das ist wie immer so bei diesen Brüdern. Das ist wirklich furchtbar.
Vor allem tausend mal aufgekauft.
Ich meine, habt ihr keine Probleme mit LINE?
Ich hab genau ein Problem. Und zwar, dass er sich, wenn ich irgendwo hinkomme und der das WLAN schon kennt, dass er sich nicht damit automatisch verbindet. Das ist total...
Und dann kommt immer dieses Fenster, man muss es nochmal neu auswählen.
Das bekomm ich nicht mal. Ich muss dann explizit dieses WLAN nochmal auswählen.
Dann hab ich die schönste Variante. Bei mir geht dieses Fenster auf, ich sage einmal verbinden, dann sagt der Connection timed out und danach kann ich dann über das Menü auswählen.
Was für Station habt ihr denn?
Ich hab keine Probleme.
Ich hab keine. Eine Fritzbox hab ich doch.
Ah, Fremdprodukt.
Nicht supported. Und du?
Also ich hab auch hier das Problem. Ich hab's mit Tims, was hast du hier? Womit bin ich jetzt gerade verbunden hier?
Das kann ich dir gerade nicht sagen. Du könntest auch mit der Fritzbox verbunden sein gerade.
Okay. Also auf jeden Fall zu Hause hab ich auch eine Fritzbox. Kann sein, dass das ein Fritzbox-Problem ist. Keine Ahnung. Also ich bin ja hier hingekommen, aber es hat mit 10.6 funktioniert und jetzt mit 10.7 funktioniert's nicht mehr. Und mit allen anderen Geräten geht's. Also ich würde mal sagen, das war das Fritzbox-Passwort.
Das passiert mir aber nur mit dem Air.
Ich hab nur das Air. Also ich hab keine Ahnung. Kann auch an dem Air liegen.
Aber die haben noch eine spezielle Version von Lion, wenn ich da richtig informiert bin. Weiß ich nicht, ob sie die immer noch haben oder ob sie inzwischen auf dem Air sind.
Weil das eher nach dem Lion rauskam.
Nee, es gab irgendwie so ein Update, was es nur fürs Air gab. Aber ich glaub, das ist dann mit 10.7, 10.7.1 oder so was, sollte das dann die selbe Version gewesen sein. Aber das ist das Problem, was ich habe. Auf meinem MacBook Air mit Lion.
Aber dass ab und zu das WLAN nicht erkannt wird und ich dieses scheiß Fenster mit der Liste bekomme, das hatte ich, glaube ich, unter 10.6 auch schon. Und ich hab zu Hause eine Express. Und das andere WLAN, das ich benutze, ist ein Extreme.
Also ich hab das Gefühl, das ist entweder an dem Rechner oder anders.
Das sind echt alle Probleme, die ihr habt. Ich hab so viele Probleme. Also zum Beispiel dieses komische Auto-Terminate. Das beendet mir dann immer mein Preview. Dieses Tool, was Programme automatisch deaktiviert und aus dem RAM rauskickt. Das macht er zum Beispiel bei Preview, obwohl das Dokument er offen hat. Und dann mach ich irgendein PDF auf, dann versucht der Preview zu starten, aber weil das Ding irgendwie in so einem verschrotteten Hibernation-Modus ist, kommt es nicht mehr hoch. Und ich muss es dann immer killen, damit es sich wieder starten lässt. Ich hab einen Computer, der kann nur line, der kam mit line. Und so was. Dann auf meinem alten Mac, meinem weißen, so ziemlich das erste Modell, was jetzt überhaupt noch line kann. Vorher, mit 10.6, kein Flash auf dem Teil. Immer schön, alles irgendwie mit HTML5-Video abgespielt und total geile Performance und Fullscreen und Volles Programm. Seit line, Zustände wie bei den Hotten Totten. Alles ruckelt, alles funktioniert überhaupt nicht mehr, keine Performance beim Video abspielen, einfach ein totales Desaster. Also so richtig schlecht, schlechter, irgendwie Flash in seinen allerschlimmsten Zeiten, aber ohne Flash. Dann auch so Fullscreen umschalten von Videos. Das hab ich auf verschiedenen Rechnern. Das ist so beim ersten Mal nicht klappt, weißer Bildschirm. Nochmal irgendwie Escape, nochmal probieren, dann geht's irgendwie. Ja, so ne Sachen. Dann Abstürze von System, Software permanent, irgendein Tool ist immer irgendwie dabei und wirft mir irgendwelche Crashes vor die Nase. Also ich weiß, ich hab da wieder so das Händchen dafür, dass es irgendwie immer nicht funktioniert, aber ein abgehangenes OS ist was anderes als das. Und das ist definitiv auch schlechter als wie Snow Leopard gestartet ist. Also ich hab da irgendwie viel so Klangraum. Und vor allem, ich frag mich die ganze Zeit, wenn das mit diesem Full-Disc-Encryption nicht wär, ich frag mich die ganze Zeit, was ist eigentlich das Feature, was ich geil finde?
Die neue Optik.
Die find ich furchtbar.
Voll geil.
Zum kurzen find ich diese Chrom-Buttons. Ich will Icons, die ich mir auf den ersten Blick entdecke. Ich will irgendwie rote Fahnen, die rot sind. Und ich will irgendwie... Die Icons und das Snow Leopard, da hab ich niedergekniet so großartig für dich das. Und jetzt ist alles weg. Jetzt ist alles so ein Grayscale-Mélange, Wischi-Washi, wo man immer hingucken muss, so was ist jetzt eigentlich wirklich genau. Was soll das?
Was erlauben Strohs?
You fixed something that wasn't broken.
Was mir jetzt so einfällt, was ich unter diesen Leidenschaften schätze, auf dem MacBook nutze ich auch den Fullscreen-Modus gerne. Was ich nervig finde, ist, dass ich nicht, sobald ich das Thunderbolt-Display anschließe, dass dann automatisch nicht mehr Fullscreen-Modus geht. Also weil da nutze ich ihn halt nicht.
Ja, da hast du irgendwas Fullscreen und der andere Bildschirm ist tot.
Ja, aber auf dem internen Bildschirm mag ich den Fullscreen-Modus, nutze ich ihn auch sehr exzessiv, also für diverse Programme. Also für Chrome auf jeden Fall, für Mail, für Reader, das sind schon mal die drei Standard-Apps, die ich immer im Fullscreen-Modus laufen habe. Ich finde das neue Mail unerträglich, das neue finde ich echt gut. Also vorher ist Barrow benutzt und weil das mitgelieferte Mail eigentlich schon seit Jahren unerträglich war, der Leidensdruck war so groß, dass ich zwischen Gmail und Webinterface genutzt habe. Das neue ist wesentlich schneller. Es kann mir zum Beispiel alle Mails, die in einem Thread hängen, anzeigen. Es kann mir die Bilder aus meinem Adressbuch nachladen. Ich finde es wesentlich besser. Es kommt meinem Anwendungsfall wesentlich näher. Ich kann die Seitenleiste ausblenden, wenn ich sie gerade nicht brauche.
Und du brauchst diese neue Optik?
Wie die neue Optik?
Diese Column-View? Das habe ich gleich wieder ausgeschaltet.
Ja, ich hatte früher hier ein Weitmehl-Plugin für Mehl, mit dem ich das dann auch in Mehl hatte. Und dann wurde das kaputt gemacht. Also das hat nie so richtig funktioniert. Und jedes Mal, wenn eine neue Mehl-Version rauskam, ja klar, ich sehe endlich mal viele Mehls. Und nicht nur da irgendwie vier Mehls oben, weil die über einen halben Bildschirm gehen. Ich finde diesen Column-View wesentlich besser. Und ich habe den schon vorher gerne genutzt, sozusagen, per Nachrüstung. Und das ist so eines. Also ich finde Mehl ganz, finde es sehr gut. Full Disk Entruption, klar. Dann, ähm...
An Sie, Colors in Turf. Ich weiß.
Dieses, dass alle Programme, wenn sie hochfahren, also wenn mein Rechner neu startet und alle Programme wieder neu starten und alles wieder so ist, wie es vorher war. Und wenn ich mein Programm nicht brauche und es beende, zum Beispiel Preview oder Text-Edit oder so, ich muss nicht jedes Mal, ah, ich will einen Neustart machen, ah, jetzt muss ich dieses Dokument hier speichern und muss mir erstmal dafür einen Namen ausdenken, sondern es geht zu und wenn es hochfährt, ist es wieder da und ich brauche mich nicht um nichts Sorgen zu machen. Finde ich großartig.
Ja, solange du eine SSD hast. Nein, auf meinem iMac zu Hause noch nicht. Und das ist einfach so...
Jungs, alle mal flattern.
Neustarten ist einfach so die Hölle.
Ja, weil er alles hochreißt wieder, ne?
Also ich meine, das ist schon vorher mitzumachen.
Aber das stimmt, das muss ich sagen. Ich bin da noch nicht zu so einer abschließenden Bewertung gekommen, aber grundsätzlich, das hab ich ja auch schon immer gesagt, bin ich ein Freund von dem Persistent Desktop. Also ich meine, an sich ist das der richtige Weg. Es hat so ein bisschen Kollateralschäden. Ich bin überrascht, wie gut es funktioniert, sogar unter der Bedingung, dass man viel mit Dropbox macht. Also ich hab so wirklich furchtbare Angst gehabt, dass dieses Autosave mich in so eine Konflikt-Copy-Hölle bringen würde. Das kann einem schon so mit Dropbox ganz gut grundsätzlich schon mal passieren. Komischerweise hat das nicht dazu geführt und ich kann mir sogar vorstellen, dass das Autosave an der Stelle hilfreich war. Weil selbst während ich noch an so einem Dokument rumtippe, und nicht sage, speicher mal ab, sondern irgendwie die Änderungen eigentlich noch ungespeichert sind, speichert er es trotzdem ab. Und dann geht es in die Dropbox. Und wenn ich dann dieses Dokument noch offen habe auf einem anderen Rechner, dann ist es trotzdem gesaved. Und wenn ich dann an einen anderen Rechner gehe und mit dem Dokument weiter arbeite, dann, naja, funktioniert das. Obwohl es grundsätzlich ein Problem ist, was ist dann, wenn du auf beiden Seiten Änderungen hast?
Ich finde, das ist zu transparent. Man kriegt es irgendwie nicht mit und hat selber dann keinen Überblick mehr. Und ich finde, die können wir den Überblick auch nicht so wirklich geben, mit diesem billigen Time Machine Interface. Das ist mir nicht genau genug. Und vor allem funktioniert es auch nicht immer. Mit 10.7.2 ist es ein Stück besser geworden. Immerhin sehe ich schon mal eine von beiden Seiten, aber da müssten eigentlich zwei Versionen angezeigt werden. Bei Xcode. Also nicht in Xcode selbst, sondern halt die Dateien. Weil manchen, wenn ich keinen Version-Control irgendwie habe, und ich habe immer keins. Autsch.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich in meinem Arbeits-Workflow brauche dieses Versions-Feature halt genau in Null. Also ich habe es noch nicht einmal gebraucht, weil ich habe eh alles. Aber die Local Time Machine Snapshots, die haben ja schon einmal...
Wenn Dennis gerade überlegt hat, den Job zu geben.
Die haben ja schon einmal den Arsch gerettet.
Eine Version-Control haben System-Managements, kein Ding.
Stimmt, das findet er die ganze Zeit statt.
Kannst du auf deinem eigenen Rechner machen.
Muss man das eigentlich einschalten?
Das ist automatisch an.
Also die Local Snapshots von Time Machine?
Ja, habe ich auch. Interessant.
Ich habe bestimmt im Podcast erzählt, wie mir das den Arsch gerettet hat an einem Tag, weil ich meine SSH-Keys gelöscht habe aus Versehen. Oder überschrieben, was er gesagt hat. Dann dachte ich, die sind nur zu Hause auf der Platte und ich muss jetzt mit dem Motorrad schnell hinpesen. Dann dachte ich mir, Local Time Machine Snapshots. In der Tat waren meine SSH-Keys in diesem Snapshot mit drin und ich musste nicht nach Hause fahren. Obwohl ich monatelang nicht gebackupt hatte auf einer Platte.
Er schiebt dir ja auch diese Snapshots rüber auf die Platte, wenn du dann ein Backup machst. Okay, mag jetzt auch daran liegen, obwohl ich auch vorher eine SSD hatte. Das ist dieses Time Machine Backup, wenn ich mal eins mache, geht das deutlich schneller. Sie sind wesentlich schneller geworden als 110.6. Obwohl eigentlich ja auch noch Versionen gebackupt werden. Du bist glücklich.
Ich habe auch tatsächlich so gut wie keine Probleme. Ich nehme in meinem Umfeld auch diverse Issues wahr, aber so in meinem Benutzerprofil, also ich habe keine WLAN-Probleme, keine Crashes, nichts. Also das Einzige, was ich auch hatte, ist tatsächlich dieses gekillte Fenster im Terminal, weil das mal eine Zeit lang nervig war. Und dann haben wir natürlich alle das große Problem, das mit C anfängt und mit Allender aufhört.
Nein, nein, nein!
Jetzt guck, ob das höherer Meter, wie sie alle weggenähen, die Nadel schlägt genau auf. Ich hol mir auch mal ein Getränk, das ist eine super Idee. Warte noch mit dem Kalender.
Wie viel haben wir denn? 500.
Bring mal einen O-Saft mit, Huckel, einen kleinen.
O-Saft der Herz.
Ja, irgendwas nicht halber, sondern weniger. Was gibt's denn da alles so?
O-Saft.
Ja, kalter O-Saft wär super.
Kannst du noch mal eine Mate in den Kühlschrank nachlegen? Ich glaub, die sind dann ein bisschen ungekühlt. Tja, was hier alles gibt, wa? In der Metaebene, in der Mateebene. Ja, zum Thema Kalender. Also, erstmal hat mir jemand ein Video zugespielt, weil ich sowas ja nicht benutze, aber so Outlook, unter Windows, diese Kalender-Software von, wissen schon, Microsoft, Office und so.
Ich bin raus.
Die kann das, ne? Also, die kann tatsächlich so durch Wochen, also, ich muss noch mal kurz zusammenfassen, was mich generell stört, ist, Kalenderübersichten sind immer so Kalendermonatsorientiert und was ich möchte, ist in einem... Die mögen das Thema nicht, ne?
Wir machen jetzt Occupy Mobile Max. Hier sind die 99 Prozent. Oh Mann.
Ich mach jetzt mal hier einfach mal alle anderen Mikrofone da raus. Das ist das Beste. Jetzt kann ich hier mal ein bisschen in Ruhe reden. Wollt ihr wieder?
Erzähl.
Wir schlafen auch.
Was ist denn daran jetzt so schlimm? Ich mach eine eigene Podcast.
Bei Outlook Mac gibt es das nicht, weil jemand sagt, es gibt natürlich für Mac ein Outlook, aber Mac Outlook gibt es dieses Feature aus dem Computer.
Windows Outlook willst du nicht benutzen?
Nein, das willst du alles nicht benutzen. Ich habe jetzt einfach nur gesagt, dass es das da gibt und das muss man ja auch anerkennen.
So, fertig.
Dann habe ich noch einen Tipp bekommen und zwar kann, ich weiß nicht seit wann, aber dieses Busy Cull, was ja so ein ziemlich cooles Drop-in-Replacement ist für iCal, wobei ich bisher immer so das Gefühl gehabt habe, naja, dann hast du halt was anderes als iCal, aber es macht eigentlich genau das gleiche falsch. Das hat tatsächlich diese Option. Ja, wenn ich das mal...
Das ist einfach die letzte Folge.
Ich habe es immer nicht verstanden. Okay, pass auf, also ich erkläre dir folgendes.
Du schaust...
Wo beziehest du es?
Jetzt sei doch mal ruhig bitte. Also, man schaut auf mehrere Wochen. Gemeinhin wird das als Monatsansicht gepriesen. Und du kannst dann auch immer nur in diesen Kalendermonatsprüngen da durchgehen. Also mal vier Wochen, mal fünf Wochen, je nachdem wie das gerade irgendwie gelegen ist. Und das empfinde ich einfach als hochgradig unpraktisch, weil meine reale Zeitplanung ist eine Zeitplanung von Woche zu Woche. Und dabei ist es vollkommen egal, ob da jetzt gerade in der nächsten Woche irgendwie ein Kalendermonat endet oder nicht. Das ist einfach die nächste Woche. Und es ist für mich eigentlich selten ein Thema, ob der Dienstag jetzt der Erste oder der Zwölfte ist. Er ist halt da, er kommt. Und die letzte Woche war die aktuelle Woche, die nächste Woche ist da. Und das ist das, was ich gerne sehen würde. Und ich erwarte einfach nur, dass mir Software diese Zeit so flüssig darstellen kann, dass ich da einfach durchscrollen kann. Und ich rede wirklich von scrollen und nicht hüpfen. So mit so auf Buttons klicken und dann ist einfach auf einmal alles anders. Und ich werd scrollen. Du wirst durch einen Webbrowser, wenn du auch durchscrolle.
Du siehst eine Woche und scrollst dann so seitlich?
Nein, ich sehe mehrere Wochen und sie scrollen einfach von unten nach oben durch. So wie in einem Webbrowser. Das kann doch einfach nicht so schwierig sein, das zu implementieren.
Und das haben wir jetzt nur noch wirklich schon bestimmt fünf oder sechs Episoden lang genauso gefordert und bisher...
Ja, es kommt. Ich habe ja schon diverse Updates gegeben. Es gab so ein, zwei iOS-Anwendungen, bloß mir ging es nie um iOS. Mir ging es vor allem immer um den Mac, geht es auch immer noch. Und ich kann euch das ja mal kurz mal hier zeigen, wenn das nicht gerade schon wieder abgelaufen ist, hier dieser ganze Rotz. Na, wo ist es denn hier? Ich hab das nicht hier installiert, doch da.
Aber BusyKyle ist auch so bunten, ne?
Schieb es mal rüber auf den Bildschirm, damit man auch sehen kann. Mittlerweile ist es einfach so schlecht.
Jetzt seh ich halt hier den ganzen November und jetzt kann ich hier auf den Dezember gehen und so kennt man das. Das Schlimme hier ist schon mal so, wenn ich von November auf Dezember gehe, dann scrollt er von rechts nach links, als ob der Monat daneben liegen würde. Tut er nicht. Na ja, Zeit geht von oben nach unten. Schau doch dahin. Die eine Woche ist ganz oben, und die nächste Woche ist da drunter. Also es ist eine vertikale Geschichte. So, und jetzt kannst du tatsächlich...
Ein Tint-Stone, das das hier so... Das hier so selbstbezeichnendes Bild nach Hause bringt, möchte ich nicht dabei sagen.
Muss ich gleich mal gucken, wo ich...
Mit den Brauen!
Das ist jetzt auch schon ein Busy Kyle, ja? Ja, tatsächlich.
Das ist dieses Busy Kyle. Das muss ich gleich mal kurz mal schauen hier. Was ist denn das hier für ein Quatsch? Sync... Wo ist denn das jetzt schon wieder mit diesem...
Scheiß...
General... One week... Wo ist denn das jetzt schon wieder? Ist das irgendwie eine andere Version? Irgendwie ist hier schon wieder alles anders.
Bist du sicher, dass das ein Busy Kyle war?
Ja, ich bin mir total sicher, dass es ein Busy Kyle war, aber ich finde es gerade nicht wieder. Aber warte mal, das war wahrscheinlich hier im Menü. Ja, genau, das war hier im Menü. Und zwar, das seht ihr jetzt hier gerade nicht, weil das natürlich auf dem Hauptbildschirm ist.
Die Hörer sehen es nicht, weil das kein Video-Podcast ist.
Scroll by Weeks, genau, das kann man hier einfach im Menü einschalten. Tut mir leid. So, wenn ich jetzt hier durchgehe... Gucken wir mal, da sieht man, das ist ja auch nicht mehr nur der Oktober, sondern er sagt mir, dass das, was ich jetzt sehe, Oktober bis Dezember ist. So, und jetzt geht er halt... muss man halt immer fünf Mal hingucken, was da eigentlich passiert, weil er scrollt. Scrolligen kann man das nicht nennen. Er hüpft dann eine Woche, aber er schiebt einfach von unten die nächste Woche nach. So ist das...
Jetzt liegt keiner mehr durch.
Bitte? Ja, vielleicht ist das der Grund, warum so viele, warum das normalerweise im Monatskalender sind.
Wo liegt keiner mehr durch?
So wie das da jetzt funktioniert. Ich bin gespannt, dass das nicht angeschaltet ist.
Ja, wieso? Aber wenn ich jetzt hier smooth durchscrollen könnte und man nicht nach jedem Hüpfen irgendwie seine Optik neu ausrichten müsste, dann würde das wunderbar funktionieren. Ich meine, beim Webbrowser hast du ja auch nicht einen Pfeil nach rechts, wo du dann die nächste Seite von rechts nach links reinschiebst.
Aber Zeit endet nirgends. Wo hast du dann deinen Scrollbar? Gar keinen Scrollbar.
Er hat keinen Scrollbar. Er soll einfach nur scrollen.
Von unten nach oben. Und von oben nach unten.
Ach Tim, das muss ich noch selbst schreiben.
Wieso? Ich meine, wenn du deine Uhrzeit einstellst, dann notieren doch da auch die Stunden von unten nach oben in so einem Rädchen. Das ist auch vollkommen intuitiv. Zeit läuft einfach voran. Das weiß man doch. Das kann alles so schwänig sein. Wie auch immer. Zumindest kann man wochenweise voranschreiten. Aber Scrolling ist wirklich was anderes. Und wir müssen einfach mehr meckern. Wir müssen einfach mehr an Software rummeckern. Vor allem, wenn uns Developer zuhören. Das ist einfach... Ich kenne auch jemanden, der mir extra nochmal eine Mail geschrieben hat. Deswegen, der das auch in seine Software eingebaut hat, dieses Feature, das ist dieses Continuous, was ich neulich schonmal erwähnt habe. Was für ihn mehr so ein Hobbyprojekt ist. Und er meint, das wäre... Ja, es wäre einfach wichtig, dass einfach Qualität, auch in Bezug auf User Interfaces, thematisiert wird. Dann muss geredet werden.
Ja, aber das machen wir doch die ganze Zeit.
Ja, das machen wir die ganze Zeit. Ich werde da jetzt auch nicht...
Hört ihr das? Es wird nicht eher enden, bis einer von euch dieses verdammte Scroll Feature eingebaut hat. Wir klehen euch an! Tut euch selbst einen Gefallen. Macht einfach dieses Software und dann ist die Welt ein besserer Ort. Für alle von uns.
Na ja, also für uns, weil Tim nicht mehr meckert und für Tim, weil er einen Kalender hat. Ich wollte es nur mal klar machen, nicht, dass irgendjemand außer jemand, der einen Kalender hätte.
Diese Kalendersoftware, die hat sich seit Jahrhunderten nicht verändert.
Ist eh tot.
Ach, guck an, auch unser Überraschungsgast ist der Meinung, wir sind nicht allein.
Plus zumindest, plus ist so was von tot. Da passiert doch überhaupt nichts mehr.
Doch, doch, doch.
Da reden die Leute, die noch einen Account haben, die reden auch miteinander.
Ich hab einen Account, ich geh da nie rein. Es sei denn, ich krieg irgendwelche Notifications, damit ich sie auf iOS dann nicht mehr aufploppen, weil es nervt mich, wenn da die Bubbles oben sind. Und ansonsten hab ich das Gefühl, da passiert nichts.
Aber es posten auf Hacker News ganz viele belesene Leute, irgendwelche Rants und so weiter, auf Google Plus in irgendwelchen Documents.
Ich glaube, so wenig läuft da gar nicht ab.
So wenig läuft da gar nicht ab.
Na, dann können sie es doch unbedingt in Google rants. Dann wäre das Plus auch wieder frei für die Suche.
Oh ja, bitte.
Also das ist jetzt irgendwie abgeschaltet, ne?
Ja, hab ich gehört in einem anderen Podcast.
Ach so.
Du hörst noch andere Podcasts außer unseren?
Dann hast du diese Information, die uns bei uns immer vermisst werden.
Welchen Podcast hörst du denn noch?
Ja, Qualitätsarbeit.
Jaja, ich weiß. Das kennen wir nicht.
Qualitäts-Podcasts, weißt du.
Also was ich bei Google Plus am nervigsten finde, ist, dass dieser blöden Leist, diese Notification, eigentlich immer auf eins ist, weil er dir immer anzeigt, dass dich zehn Leute irgendwie hinzugefügt haben. Und es gibt keine Möglichkeit, das abzuschalten. Und jeder, der ein Google-Plus-Account hat, weiß, dass einen immer zehn Leute hinzugefügt haben. Weil immer sind irgendwelche SEO- und Social-Media-Experten, die unbedingt in 5.839 Kreise wollen, oder weißte teure was. Und dass man das nicht abschalten kann, dass man einfach sagen kann, bitte halt die Schnauze, wenn ich irgendwo hinzugefügt worden bin.
Das kann man nicht abschalten?
Das kann man nicht abschalten. Das ist, ich bin wirklich, also weil wenn da so was rot leuchtet, das ist bei mir so ein, das hat sich wahrscheinlich nicht gedacht, dann gilt das für mich als wichtig. Dann muss ich da auch draufklicken, muss ich es jedes Mal wegklicken. Und ich suche ja manchmal auch mit Google, dann ist bei der Suchung Google-Suche ist plötzlich dann dieses Notification-Link da.
Also wenn ich von Google weggehe und die Google-Suche nicht mehr, dann ist im Augenblick der Grund dafür dieses dämliche Notification-Zeichen da oben. Das ist, und ich weiß nicht, was daran so schmerzhaft ist, also dass man das Abschalten machen kann.
Hat jemand eigentlich schon mal Dr. Go benutzt? So wirklich wirklich?
Ich nicht, aber ich kenne jemanden, der das benutzt hat.
Dr. Go, was ist das?
Daktak Go, diese Suchmaschine.
Das ist die neue aufstrebende Suchmaschine.
Die gibt es schon super lange.
Die gibt es echt schon. Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente, Lauf.
So wie von Duck-Typing bestimmt.
Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente.
Ja, magst du es die Leute mit den weißen Westen kommen, die da sind?
Die ist Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente.
Nein, ich kenn nicht die.
Such mal nach Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente.
Und, was ist das?
Na, die neue Suchmaschine.
Und was kann die?
Also die neue alte. Na, gut suchen scheinbar.
Wohl nicht so viel Werbung wie in Google drin. Und so viel scheiß Zeug.
Er ist ein German Event Manager.
Ja, wahrscheinlich schaltet er auch einfach keine Werbung.
Da, da, go!
Sind jetzt aber nicht so relevante Links dazu. Tim Pritlavs Fotostream bei Flickr.
Mal gucken, was er zu mir so findet.
Sowas finden die wichtig. Und dann findet er irgendwie meinen Twitter-Account, meinen Twitpick-Account, meinen Vimeo-Account, meinen LinkedIn-Account, meinen...
Also eher so eine Stalker-Suchmaschine, ja? Das ist ja denn das kordische Bibelstunde, schmeiß ich gleich mal in den Chat.
New Hampshire, Public Radio, Internet-Television, Cortesee, Tim Pridler.
Ich wusste bis eben gar nicht mal, dass ich einen Quora-Account habe. Und die Suchmaschine findet den. Ed Nation, Menschenskinder.
Tja, Duck, Duck, Ghost, schon lange dabei.
Die haben alles aufgezeichnet.
Aber ich find ganz nett, dass sie an der Seite so diese Search-Ideas mit drin haben, die du dann einfach, glaube ich, per Klick hinzufügen kannst.
Max Winde, 343 Max.
Search-Ideas?
An der Seite gibt es da.
Ach so, Ideas.
Ideas, spreche ich, mein Englisch ist offensichtlich undeutlich.
Entschuldigung, es liegt am Mikrofon.
Also die Suchergebnisse sind nicht besonders. Es kommt wahrscheinlich drauf an, was man so sagen darf. Also er findet zum Beispiel meine Homepage gar nicht.
Ja, meine findet er auch nicht.
Und das ist schon ein bisschen strange.
Seinen Blog findet er doch.
Mal gucken, was passiert, wenn ich...
Er findet irgendeine Archivunterseite meines Blogs an der zehnten Stelle.
Krass, wenn ich nach 343 Max suche, dann findet er mein Flash-Blog Plugin, was ich mal für Chrome geschrieben habe. Weißte schon seit wann, ist das nicht mehr aktualisiert worden? Seit 2009.
Gleich verklagen.
Okay, also DuckDuckGo überzeugt mich null.
Alles ist per Tastatur bedienbar. Du kannst die Suchergebnisse, die dir nicht gefallen, per Tastatur durchscrollen.
Ah cool, mit VI-Bedienung, ist ja geil. Oder?
Ich hab die Cursor-Tasten benutzt.
Cursor-Tasten? Du bist ja überhaupt nicht oldschool mein.
Der findet meine Fotos von Montreal, der ist ja geil.
Scrollen macht man mit J und K. So, warum hast du jetzt diese Webseite überhaupt erwähnt?
Weil wir gerade über Suchmaschinen geredet haben.
Nee, davor haben wir über irgendwas anderes geredet.
Google hat unter anderem eine Suche.
Aber wir wollten ja nicht auf den Niedergang von Google zu sprechen kommen.
Ja, ich glaube, das wird bald zugemacht. Was soll ich dazu sagen? Also ich sehe da nichts mehr, dass da Großwasser passiert, außer dass sie jetzt irgendwie Firmen hinzugefügt haben.
Du meinst dir hier in den Weg das Google Wave?
Aber es ist doch Sergys Poster Child hier. Child?
Poster.
Ja, also sein Steckenpferd.
Ja, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass es gut sein muss.
Nee.
Und das andere Leute benutzen.
Aber ich glaube, das ist halt nicht so schlimm.
Aber das sollte das heißen.
Ich glaube, da wird noch eine Zeit lang vergehen, bis sie das bemerken, dass es nicht so doll ist.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, im Einempfinden ist das da nicht mehr wirklich was passiert und es eigentlich schon fast tot ist.
Meinst du jetzt Google als solches? Du redest nur von Google plus.
Ja, den Rest, solange ich meinen eigenen Servern nicht habe, sollen sie noch nicht sterben.
Ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass es ja, bevor das gestartet ist, das ist das Produkt, auf das Google seine Existenz verwettet und so. Und im Augenblick würde ich sagen, keine gute Idee, da alles drauf zu setzen. Und wie sie alles andere da reinvergewaltigen, dass das auch mit Google plus, also ich, haben wir eigentlich schon mal über dieses Reader-Desaster hergezogen, hier ein bisschen.
Das heißt, das, was mich als Features rausgenommen haben.
Dass da die Sharing-Funktion weg ist. Und mir fällt erst, also ich dachte immer, ja, ich nutze ihn manchmal, aber ich nutze ja hier Reader und dann immer S für Sharing. Dann geht das automatisch an ein paar Leute rüber. Und ich hatte da so irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 200, 300 Follower, die haben sich das dann angeguckt oder haben sich das nicht angeguckt. Und ich hab mir deren Vorschläge angeguckt, weil da teilweise extrem geile Sachen dabei war. Jetzt ist das einfach weg.
Aber wodurch haben sie denn das jetzt ersetzt?
Durch Google-Reader-Integration. Also erstmal, wenn du ein Sir-Party-Client benutzt, dann, äh, Quatsch, durch Google-Plus-Integration. Du hast da jetzt so ein Google-Plus-Sharing drauf. Und wenn du das Webinterface nutzt...
Also dieses Plus-Eins-Ding, diese Plus-Eins-Band.
Ja, Plus-Eins oder Sharing. Und Felix Schwenzel hat da auch einen längeren Artikel drüber geschrieben, wie er da überhaupt nicht durchblickt, nach welchem Prinzip das da wie bei Google dann aussieht. Und was für mich halt das extrem Unangenehme ist, ich will das gar nicht in Google Plus reinhauen. Ich möchte das mit... Also ich fand das halt gut, dass ich das andere, das von mir in ihrem Reader lesen konnte und dass ich deren Zeug im Reader lesen kann. Weil der Reader, der funktioniert offline, der hat ein schönes Interface, wo man lange Texte drin lesen kann.
Also wenn du der Reader sagst, dann meinst du jetzt die Macintosh-Anwendung Reader mit E? Oder du meinst Google Reader mit EA?
Es hat in beiden Fällen funktioniert. Also Sharing war in Google Reader drinnen und in Reader mit E auf dem Mac.
Okay, also unabhängig von der App.
Das war einfach sozusagen, man konnte Artikel miteinander teilen. Und das war ein sehr schönes Feature, was aber total nicht genutzt war und leider sehr, sehr unterrepräsentiert war. Man konnte auch nicht leicht neue User entdecken und so was. Das war alles sehr, sehr schlicht gemacht. Und anstatt es einfach besser zu machen, haben sie es jetzt gekillt und haben es durch etwas total unbetutztbares ersetzt. Und das nur, um ihr dämliches Google Plus voranzubringen.
Ja, also mir ist dieses Google Plus auch irgendwie unklar. Ich meine, zu dem Zeitpunkt, als sie diese Real Name-Debatte da losgetreten haben und einfach Leuten ihre Accounts sperren, ich meine, wie kann man nur auf so eine Idee kommen? Also das macht mich wirklich fassungslos. Und in dem Moment war für mich das Produkt tot. Ich meine, was ist ein Social-Network wert, wo nicht jeder da sein kann?
Aber Facebook macht es doch genauso.
Ist es so?
Ja klar, bei Facebook, da hat sich niemand darüber aufgeregt. Das ist halt das Lustige eigentlich daran.
Kannst du schon ein Fake-Name eingeben.
Ja, dann wird deine Account auch gesperrt.
Ich habe jetzt eh entlang bei Facebook ein Fake-Stalker-Account.
Solang dich niemand anzeigt oder sowas, da ist das, also ich meine, du musst dich da ausweisen, aber wenn dich, wenn irgendjemand sagt, also hier Michael MS Pro, der ist definitiv, ist dem schon mal sein Account gesperrt worden bei Facebook wegen falschen Namen. Ich glaube bei Enomane ist das auch passiert. Also ich kenne schon ein paar Leute, denen der Facebook-Account auch weggesperrt worden ist. Und ich habe da, das war sehr lustig, ich habe da mal einen sehr schönen kleinen Vortrag über dieses ganze Privacy und Internet und sowas gehört und da ging es auch darum, dass es, es geht ja gar nicht darum, dass du wirklich deinen echten Namen angehst. Es gibt, dass du einen glaubwürdig klingenden Namen angeben würdest. Also wenn ich da Maximilian Winde reinschreibe, regt sich da keiner darüber aus, obwohl ich ihn nicht so heiße. Und das hat ja hier Enno hat das ja sehr schön gemacht, der hat das ja auf Google Plus, der hat ja dann unter seinem echten Namen, Enno Park, hat da einen Account angelegt, wo er überhaupt nicht er selbst ist, sondern wo er irgendein CDU-Mitglied, Teppichverkäufer aus irgendwas spielt. Aber Hauptsache der Name stimmt, dann ist Google glücklich. Und das ist, und Hauptsache ist irgendwie so ein wohl klingender Name und ja Hauptsache du passt in das Bild, was ein Roboter von dir hat.
Genau.
Ich hab Peter, ich hab, ich war Peter von dort auf Facebook ganze Zeit lang. Ja.
Und jetzt gibt es eine ein und Facebook linkt dich einfach jetzt so.
Man kann dich überhaupt nicht verstehen gerade.
Na toll. Stundenlang erzähl ich ihr die voll super Beiträge und keiner hat was gehört. Doch doch.
Ich muss aber sagen, ich hab die Leute auch rausgekickt und angezeigt. Im Google+.
Angezeigt?
Warum?
Ja.
Gemeldet meinst du?
Ja gemeldet.
Echt?
Welche, die mit Pseudonym?
Ich kam Bock drauf. Ich weiß auch nicht.
Wie bist denn du drauf?
Weil ich das Gefühl hatte, das waren Spam-Accounts. Und Spam-Accounts? Kam Bock drauf.
Hm. Also ich meine, bei Facebook mag das ja auch so gewesen sein, aber bei Facebook war für mich schon immer was anderes, ja. Also Google hat ja so ein bisschen dieses Versprechen mit, wir machen das jetzt anders.
Von Google hat man mehr erwartet.
Ja, zumindest was anderes erwartet.
Es verstößt übrigens auch quasi gegen Googles eigene Policy. Die haben irgendwann mal eine Policy aufgestellt, wie sie mit Identitäten umgehen und so. Und deren eigene Regel war sozusagen, jeder hat die Identität, die er sich selber ausgesucht hat. Und dann verstoßen sie ohne guten Grund dagegen. Und ich weiß nicht wofür, weil Spam-Accounts verhindert es nicht. Also ungefähr 98 Prozent von dem, was mir da folgt, sind Spam-Accounts, die offensichtlich keine echten Namen haben. Also der Nervfaktor ist definitiv da. Keine Ahnung, was die damit wollen. Aber ich finde es sowieso, dieses Google+, das ist so, das riecht nach getrockneten Angstreis. Das ist so, oh mein Gott, da ist jemand in einer Sache besser als wir. Und anstatt sich wie vielleicht vor fünf Jahren noch zu überlegen, hey, wie können wir zum Beispiel einen Mail-Service anbieten, der besser ist als der Rest. Oder einfach das Ding auf die nächste Ebene und weiterzudenken und sich sagen, hey, wir haben ja ein gut funktionierendes Geschäft und das wird auch erst mal eine Weile funktionieren. Und wir können uns auch mal Zeit lassen. Und wir können diesen ganzen Socialzug, können wir auch einfach mal an uns vorbeifahren lassen. Dann sind wir einfach mit dem nächsten. Ich glaube nicht, dass Facebook jetzt das Ende der Internetentwicklung ist, sondern auch ich.
Also jetzt, ich habe ein bisschen nachgedacht. Ich glaube, jetzt weiß ich auch, was mich so stört an Google+. Ich meine, Google ist etwas, was ich so von der Suche her, ich meine, wenn wir uns alle noch an das Ur-Google erinnern, und da sind sie ja noch mit ihrer Such-Homepage relativ nah dran, da ist halt diese Suchbox und das Google-Logo und das war's. So, und dann suchst du irgendwas und dann kriegst du irgendwas. Und Google kennt dich nicht und du kriegst aber irgendwie das Internet dargelegt. Und die Suche hat relativ gut funktioniert. So, irgendwann gab es dann Accounts, irgendwann konntest du dann auch das benutzen und du konntest deine Settings machen und das ist ja auch ein Angebot. Ja, auf einmal machst du dich quasi der Maschine gegenüber bekannt und du hast dann irgendwie deine Historie, wenn du das haben willst und so. Datenschutzimplikationen jetzt mal beiseite, einfach nur was diesen Komfort und mein Verhältnis mit Google betrifft. Und für mich war in gewisser Hinsicht dieses Google Plus, auch so wie sie das integriert haben, so mit diesem Bar, wir schließen jetzt alle Dienste zusammen und so ganz vorne ist so dein Account. Das war für mich so eine Zusammenfassung ihrer Dienste mit der Möglichkeit, auch wenn ich es denn möchte, meine Personalität mehr zu zeigen. Aber ich hätte natürlich erwartet, dass es vollständig von mir abhängt. Wie weit und auf welche Art und Weise ich das tue. Und dieser Schritt mit realen Namen, und jetzt bin ich aber auch wirklich verlässlich derjenige, von dem ich behauptet zu sein. Und zwar in einer stimmigen Identität mit meinem Namen, aber eben auch mit allem anderen, was ich da so repräsentiere, mit meinen Links, mit meiner Homepage, keine Ahnung, was auch immer da geschrieben steht etc. Das ist ja auch so ein Statement. Das ist so ein Bewusstes so, ok, ich bin jetzt nicht nur gegenüber Google bekannt und ich mache hier so ein Deal mit meiner Suchmaschine oder mit meinem integrierten kostenlosen Internetdienstleister, der Google ja so in der Regel ist, sondern ich nutze das auch, um selber öffentlich zu werden. Und dann würde ich einfach erwarten, dass Google mir bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt alles einfach erlaubt. Ja, ich kann einfach irgendjemand sein. Und wenn sie der Öffentlichkeit gegenüber, und das ist also dieses Argument der Öffentlichkeit gegenüber, eine Verlässlichkeit dieser Informationen erreichen wollen, dann hätten sie einfach einen Prozess einleiten sollen, wo man das eben verifizieren lassen kann. Wo man sagen kann, so, jetzt wirf doch mal hier deine Roboter an und jetzt mach mal diesen Check, den du da machst. Und wenn der irgendwelche Fehler wirft, dann sag mir das und dann versuche ich das irgendwie zu begradigen. Und wenn das durch ist, dann kriege ich so einen schönen kleinen Verified-Button da dran oder wie man das auch immer nennt, so ein Check. Ja, genau so wie bei Twitter, wobei das Verified ist schon so dieses wir sind uns total sicher und wir haben einen größeren Aufwand getrieben, um wirklich festzustellen, du bist der und der. Sagen wir mal so bei Celebrities, Bundeskanzler etc.
Da bist du wirklich du, ja?
Ja, das finde ich okay und das fände ich z.B. auch okay, dass das kostenpflichtig wäre. Dass man sagt, das kostet 100 Dollar und dann bist du Google plus Verified. Aber einfach nur so checkt im Sinne von, der Roboter hat mal geguckt und ob das irgendwie Sinn macht und im Zweifelsfall gibt es ein bisschen Kommunikation mit dem Support und dann kostet das irgendwie 10 Dollar, wäre so ein anderer Level, aber das würde dann auch für jeden klar sein. Und das wäre meine Erwartung gewesen, dass niemand ausgeschlossen wird. Und zwar ist es für mich deshalb was anderes als Facebook, weil Facebook ist einfach so per se so ein...
Böse.
Nein, das ist einfach so ein geschlossenes System und es will ja auch gar nichts anderes sein.
Doch, natürlich. Die wollen ja überall rein jetzt. Also das ganze Web wird ja durchdrungen von Facebook, Buttons, Widgets und Apps und...
Ja, na klar, aber du bist dann trotzdem doch da. Deine Kommunikation läuft innerhalb von Facebook etc. pp. Und das ist ja auch in Ordnung. Das kann man ja machen. Wenn man das unbedingt will, dann kann man das machen. Nur das kann nicht der Google-Weg sein, wo sie sich quasi so mit allem integrieren. Und ich hab plus in seiner ersten Inkarnation gesehen als okay, alles klar, sie docken mit der Funktionalität, wie man sie aus Facebook kennt, an in das offene Web. Und da macht das ja durchaus Sinn mit diesen ganzen Diskussionen und dass du da so ein dynamisches Web-Forum hast, wenn du eins brauchst. Aber they spoil it. Das ist irgendwie keine Ahnung. Mit dieser vollkommenen Stock im Arsch-Haltung haben sie einfach da die Elite abprallen lassen. Und dann geht es dann halt für Google nicht weiter, weil sie einfach nicht dieser Facebook-Mainstream werden können.
Na, das ist halt irgendwie auch sowieso so ein bisschen so Facebook, war ja vorher sozusagen das geschlossene System und geht jetzt so in alle Ecken nach außen. Und Google hat ja im Prinzip auch schon E-Mail und Reader und was nicht noch. Also sie wissen ja schon extrem viel über die User, die Kontakte von den Phones und so weiter. Und das sozusagen jetzt in eine so eine Plattform gießen, hat man so den Eindruck, also sozusagen der umgekehrte Facebook-Weg. Facebook macht es jetzt genau andersrum und dockt immer mehr externe ab sozusagen mit an, direkt oder indirekt. Und Google versucht es halt andersrum. Und irgendwie haben sie es aber auch überhaupt nicht raus dabei. Also ich bin ja hier, eins unserer Spiele ist ja, oder nee, drei unserer Spiele sind ja sogar auch bei Google+, da haben sie ja ganz am Anfang hier ja auch Firmen, so die auf Facebook erfolgreich sind, irgendwie gleich versucht mit an Land zu ziehen, um dann gleich so ein paar User mit abzuwerben. Aber es ist halt auch einfach so, dass die Early Adopters, die spielen halt auch nicht auf Google+, und die benutzen auch diese ganzen Upstar nicht. Und das ist halt echt ein trauriges Bild sozusagen. Dann hast du da halt auch Spiele, wo echt nur so ein paar hundert Leute spielen. Wobei Facebook zwei oder drei Millionen Leute am Tag spielen, das ist schon... Ne, also sie haben es und, also ich meine, sie haben ja da dieses Open Social, das haben sie ja schon eine ganze Weile irgendwie in der Schublade liegen und dieses Google Plus benutzt ja auch immer noch ganz viel von diesem Open Social und die Apis dafür und so, das ist auch alles... Also die Facebook-Apis sind auch Schrott, das ist jetzt nicht, aber die Google-Plus-Apis sind noch mal schlechter fast, überhaupt, ne?
Das geht?
Die sind doch neu!
Ja, aber, ne, eben nicht, weil es halt Open Social ist. Oder keine Ahnung, sie schrauben jetzt da dran, um es besser zu machen, aber ich kann euch versprechen oder versichern, dass der ganze Entwicklungsprozess gerade am Start auch so extrem holprig war, dass das nicht Spaß macht.
Ich guck nur gerade, wie viele Hörer wir so mit der ganzen Debatte eingebüßt haben, aber es hält sich in Grenzen.
Tja, Google Plus macht bald zu und wann macht Google zu?
Wollen wir mal, das ist doch eigentlich ganz gut, jetzt mal über Logitech. Ja, ja, mit diesem Google-Technik.
Ich mach mal so ein bisschen Fenster aufnehmen bei, ja?
Die Luft wird langsam dick. Also die, die erzählt haben, dass wir mal eben, in short, Logitech executed a full-scale launch with a beta product and it costs us dearly. Wir haben 100 Millionen verblasen mit dem Google, mit dem Google-TV-Start Logitech. Das ist, das ist mal eine schöne Latte Geld. Und der CEO von Logitech hat auf der, was war das, bei welcher Gelegenheit war es? Bei irgendeiner Veranstaltung mal darüber hergezogen, wie, also was aus Logitech Revue geworden ist. Revue, ich weiß nicht, wie es heißt.
Du kannst es so aussprechen, weil so heißt es.
Und der CEO hat es selbstständig als A Mistake of Implementation of a Gigantic Nature, also es ist wirklich, er hat es als...
Snafu...
.als so schlimm fehlbezeichnet, wie es gar nicht geht. Und jetzt scheinen sie ja eine neue Version von diesem Google TV nachgelegt zu haben, wo jetzt jetzt auch Apps gehen, tada, tada, tada, aber immer wieder die gleichen Apps wie fürs Telefon. Und keine Unterscheidung zwischen Telefon-Apps und Fernseh-Apps. Ich hab ne Ahnung, wie gut das funktioniert. Das ist echt traurig.
Ja, man merkt schon, wie ermüdend dieses Thema auf die Teilnehmer hier der Debatte wirkt. Das ist auch wirklich... Ist nicht so exciting, das was Google da gerade macht?
Nee, ist alles nicht so exciting. Ich meine, mich hat Android ja noch nie so richtig vom Hocker gehauen. So und diese ganze Selbstbeweihräucherung funktioniert nicht. Und ich finde auch dieses ganze Modell funktioniert auch nicht. Dieses ganze Android-Modell funktioniert nicht. Und ich frage mich eigentlich wirklich bei fast allem, was sie gerade so machen, was eigentlich gerade so, wo ist die Innovationskraft dieses Ladens irgendwie hin?
Das klingt fast abwärts, oder?
Das ist total komisch. Jetzt irgendwie dieser Vorschlag mit, wenn du dein WLAN nicht in der Location-Database hast, habt ihr das gelesen? Schlagen sie jetzt vor, man soll doch an seinen WLAN-Namen hinten einen No-Map hinten dranhauen.
Das haben sie wirklich gemacht?
Toller Vorschlag, oder?
Spidering von Wensis.
Hallo, ich hab was zu verbergen. Ich möchte nicht wahrgenommen sein.
So eine Robots-TXT für WLAN-Namen.
Kann ich ja meinen Netz gleich Streisand nennen. Was ich mich ja noch frage ist, ob wir eigentlich noch Mac-Themen haben.
Ich guck mal.
Dass wir schon so verzweifelt in der Google-Bohnensuppe fischen.
Ich hab keine Mac-Themen mehr. Ist ja auch nicht viel passiert.
Ja, das stimmt.
Doch, das sind Updates rausgekommen. Ja, mehrere sogar, oder? Ein EFI-Update ist gekommen.
Ach so Software-Updates meinst du?
Ja, dann so ein SMC-Update für die MacBook Pros. Und hatten wir vorhin schon ein bisschen Basisstation, ist dieses AirPod-Update gekommen. Und da hatte ich seit so, ich weiß nicht, ob es mit Lion zu tun hat. Bin mir nicht so sicher. Aber ich sitze zu Hause im Bett, so wie immer, schon seit Jahren. Bin am WLAN nutzen.
Ich sitze zu Hause im Bett, so wie immer, schon seit Jahren.
Und jedenfalls bricht mir das WLAN weg. Also man sieht richtig oben hier in dieser Anzeige da, im Menü, dass alle Balken aus sind. Und dann kommt das WLAN irgendwie zurück. Und in der Zeit Adium sozusagen schmeißt mich raus. Alles steht und so weiter und so fort. Und das hatte ich halt früher nicht. Und ich hab meinen Express schon ziemlich lange. Und dann kam dieses Update und seitdem ist es verschwunden. Und ich hab das Gefühl, es liegt da dran, dass sie es auch jetzt erst bemerkt haben, weil mein Schlafzimmer geht sozusagen zum Hinterhof raus. Und das ist sozusagen da, wo alle ihre WLAN-Stationen anscheinend zu stehen haben.
Was, Apple hat bemerkt, dass sein Schlafzimmer so mit aufgeräumt hat?
Nee, aber wenn ich in meinem Schlafzimmer meine WLAN-Liste aufmache, sind da ca. 40 Stationen, die ich sehe. Und ich bin noch nicht mal ans Fenster gegangen. Also der Screen ist voll bis unten hin. Und Berlin Mitte, sag ich nur. Und ich glaube, dass die Software nicht mehr in der Lage war, die ganzen Stationen zu verwalten. Und dass ich deswegen immer rausgeflogen bin. Anders kann ich es mir nicht vorstellen, weil vor Monaten lief alles super. Und es ist auch unter Windows ein Problem gewesen, weil noch jemand, der Windows benutzt mit meinem WLAN, da war das wohl auch. Und das war ja vom halben Jahr eigentlich der gleiche Windows-Rechner, die gleiche Station und da war das Problem noch nicht. Also ich denke mal, es ist irgendwann halt einfach voll. Ja, Nachbarn.
Und denen gehst du Zugriff auf deinen WLAN?
Sharing is caring. Und jedenfalls dieses Update hat es gebracht, glaube ich. Seitdem keine Probleme mehr.
Okay, ich könnte jetzt noch keine Unterschiede feststellen, obwohl ich hier ein paar Geräte habe, die sich dadurch updaten ließen. Wobei, jetzt wo du es sagst, meine Straßen-WLAN-Verbindung funktioniert wieder seitdem. Und hier ist auch viel WLAN.
Vielleicht hat es damit zu tun. Also hier so, Berlin ist ja schon WLAN-mäßig ganz schön vollgeknallt.
Ah, jetzt wo ich es sage, läuft es wieder gelb.
Funktioniert nur, wenn man es nicht braucht.
Tja, wenn es gelb ist, dann leuchtet es gelb.
Keine Ahnung, was sie mir damit sagen wollen. Du machst da WDS zur anderen Seite, oder?
Es ist gerade WDS, ja.
Aber apropos Updates. Ich fand es ja sehr schön, wie dieses iOS 5.01-Update. Overseer. Und das scheint ja auch bei allen geklappt zu haben. Und ich kenne, ich hab's bei ein paar Leuten...
Aber Herr Lehrer, kurze Frage. Also ich hab das ja, weil halt überall stand, dass es da ist irgendwie dann nachts, hab ich's halt von selber geklickt. Hat sich das dann auch selber so mit einer Notification gemeldet? Okay, das hab ich nicht gesehen.
Aber er ist einen Tag später bei mir.
Wir haben noch keine Notification.
Du hast das auch immer noch nicht?
Okay, dass der ja jetzt ja kann, weil er bei der Telekom ist.
Bist du sicher, dass es nicht vielleicht geheim ist, was er einfach so im Hintergrund gemacht hat? Sollte es Telekom auf war, da fragen die doch nicht. Die machen einfach.
Also ich bin ja, ich wette ja, dass da irgendjemand bei Apple ziemlich Schiss gehabt hat, dass dieses Update in die Hose gehen könnte und schon wahrscheinlich.
Ja, hat doch jetzt keiner Schiss mehr, wo es die weg ist.
Was bist du wieso Schiss?
Das erste OVZR-Update.
Nee, die haben doch die Developer alle schon updaten lassen über OVZR. Doch, haben sie.
Ich musste immer voll installieren, habe ich was falsch gemacht.
Ja, die Betas, die habe ich auf einen gewissen Punkt alle OVZR gemacht. Aber das war auch am Anfang rucklig, dass das so wirklich so smooth wie das jetzt funktioniert hat und dass es auch bei jedem funktioniert.
Du bist also eingetragene Apple-Developerin, ja?
Hab ich bis jetzt was erzählt?
Erzählt dir überhaupt irgendjemand irgendwas? Nicht mal. Ich sag gar nichts von Vögelchen.
Das lief auf jeden Fall super mit diesem Oversea-Update. Hab ich auch gleich gemacht, das ist cool.
Ich liess ja normalerweise über jeden Furz, der bei Apple schief sitzt, liest man ja auf Twitter sofort irgendwie was und kriegt dann so, ja, es hat nicht funktioniert. Ich habe keinen Fall mitbekommen, in dem es nicht funktioniert hätte.
Leute regen sich auf, dass es mit der Batterie ja wohl nicht funktioniert oder besser wurde oder so.
Sie haben wohl noch nicht alle Bugs gefixt, die die Leute jetzt gerne gefixt bekommen hätten. Ich meine, sie zeigen immerhin, wie das hier reagieren wird. Was sie am beeindruckendsten fand an diesem 501-Update war die Größe.
44 MP.
Bei mir war es ein bisschen größer. Was war es, 50, 60? In dem Update war drinnen, dass jetzt Australien besser mit Siri können.
Dass mit dieses Eleven Problem gewesen sei.
Das war ein Schotten.
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Wir haben die so weggeschmissen.
Hattest du übrigens nicht verlinkt, ne?
Was?
Diesen Eleven, ich hab den letzten Mal gesucht.
Stimmt, da haben sich auch Leute angeschwert.
Mobile Max hab ich nicht gefunden und musste dann YouTube fragen.
Hab ich nachgetragen dann?
Ja, ich hab vorgestern erst gesucht oder vor drei Tagen.
Ihr habt es direkt abgespielt, das reicht doch.
Die Leute wollen es gerne nochmal sehen und weiter checken.
Stimmt, konnte nichts gefunden werden. Wo war denn das in welcher Sendung?
Das war die letzte, wo ich dabei war. Die Vorletzte.
Echt? Also die 74, Teil der Tränen. Wo wir alle so toucht waren.
Wo alles auch, vor allem den ganzen Spieler.
Stimmt. Okay, trage ich gleich nach. Ich trage immer nach, wenn mich einer drauf hinweist. Man kann sich ja nicht immer alles nutzen.
Nachtraggemut die Heft.
Aber ich nutze ja Siri immer mehr. Immer mehr. Es ist nach wie vor ein bisschen merkwürdig und ich bin nach wie vor jedes Mal positiv überrascht, wenn es funktioniert. Also es ist jetzt noch nicht so dieses Vertrauen da. Wofür ist ganz hervorragend...
Wollen wir eine U-Bahn?
Ich fahre eigentlich nie U-Bahnen. In der Öffentlichkeit?
Und wenn du jetzt hier so nach Hause läufst...
Na, kein Noturnetz auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube aber auch das Telekom Netz ist in der U-Bahn ziemlich schlecht.
Ich dachte, in Berlin würde das funktionieren und bei uns in München ging es halt nur eine Ewigkeit nicht.
In Berlin haben wir gar nichts. Wir haben ja nur Autobahnen.
Bananen gibt es mittlerweile.
Bananen auch. Wir müssen immer schon in der U-Bahn telefonieren.
Na ja, geht so. Also auf der U2, ich bin auch schon ewig nicht mehr U-Bahn gefahren, muss ich auch sagen. Ich fahre mit dem Rad. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob ich es... Also ich nutze es dann, wenn es mir sinnvoll erscheint. Also wie gesagt, dieses berühmte Timerstellen mache ich nach wie vor, wofür es sehr praktisch ist, wenn man abends irgendwie im Bett liegt, nochmal kurz was, wollte ich noch, ich habe das in der Wikipedia nachschlagen, und dann keinen Bock hat, dann irgendwie so die, hat man gerade die Hände so unter der Bettdecke und dann... Weil es so kalt ist in meinem Schlafzimmer.
Ich dachte, was erzählst du denn hier?
Wikipedia, Wikipedia!
Und dann eben hier so, Wikipedia und schlag nochmal den Begriff nach und dann schlägt er das nach und zeigt die Seite an. Also da funktioniert es ganz hervorragend. Und so zum schnellen SMS-Versand funktioniert es gut.
Und muss man immer noch so... Siri, sende eine SMS. Also muss man immer noch so...
Nein, schicke eine Nachricht.
Also man kann schon locker flockig sprechen.
Nein, man sollte ein bisschen...
Nicht so weniger Berlinern, so ein bisschen Hochdeutsch.
Und ein bisschen vor allem Worte probieren, halbwegs sauber zu trennen. Das ist sowas, was bei mir regelmäßig mal scheitert. Aber so alles in allem ist das...
Kannst du dir wirklich vorstellen, dass das mal so ein Ich suche bei Google-Ersatz wird, wie es immer so weit debattiert wird? So ein, als erstes frage ich erst mal Siri, bevor ich auch nur auf die Idee komme, einen Webbrowser zu starten und Google-Suche anzugeben. Du fragst Siri und sagst nicht, suche in Google nach...
Es funktioniert ja nicht mit Wolfram Alpha hier. Das funktioniert in Deutschland nicht so gut wie woanders. Es kann ja mir kein Taxi rufen, es kann mir nicht sagen, wo das nächste Restaurant ist und diese ganzen Späße. Das geht ja leider nicht, das kann ich noch nicht sagen.
Siri kann einen Taxi rufen?
Ich glaube, Siri kann...
Auf Google Taxi rufen, da habe ich eine App-Empfehlung, die echt geil ist. Super, ich habe das letztens ausprobiert und es macht so einen Spaß.
Hat es funktioniert? Supergeil.
Die Taxi ist schon alle rum, diese Zentralen.
Die Zentralen, die Taxis selber hören gar nicht rum. Die Taxis selber freuen sich.
Hatte ich My Taxi nicht schon mal thematisiert?
Man kann sich mit My Taxi auch angucken, wo Taxis gerade sind. Man kann jetzt aufmachen und sehen...
Hingegen, diese Taxi ab von Würfelfunk ist der letzte Dreck.
Eigentlich müsste man eine Taxi-App haben, die einfach nur einen gelben Bildschirm macht. Dann hält man hoch und jedes Taxi, was sie sieht, weiß, ich will ein Taxi haben.
Das macht sich doof, wenn man gerade in der Wohnung sitzt.
Ich hab auch My Taxi nicht in den Show genutzt. Haben wir da wirklich schon drüber geredet?
Ja, haben wir.
Weißt du noch in welcher Folge? Verdammt.
In einer der letzten.
Schreib es einfach in die nochmal rein.
Genau, scheiß drauf.
Dann können wir es ja nochmal sagen. Ja, die MyTaxi macht ja auch gerade so ein bisschen Welle.
Zu Recht.
Ja, als ich es runtergeladen hab, war es halt noch so okay, es kommt dann bald in München und jetzt dachte ich, ja, jetzt probierst du es halt einfach nochmal aus.
Jetzt heißt es dir gleich mal runterladen. Das ist cool.
Ich muss zugeben, das erste Mal, wo ich es wirklich selber für mich, also ich hab mehrere Male anderen Leuten dabei zugeschaut, wie sie mit MyTaxi uns einen Taxi bestellt haben. Das erste Mal, als ich es gemacht habe, war das halt Samstagnacht um vier in Berlin. Und dann kam so dieser Effekt, dass er irgendwie sagt, ja ich vermittel und jetzt hab ich vermittelt und dann kam irgendwie gleich so eine Fehlermeldung hoch und dann so, oh jetzt hab ich es aber wieder verloren und dann nochmal und jetzt hab ich wieder verloren. Das war irgendwie total confusing. Und dann hab ich es noch irgendwie dreimal probiert und er meinte immer, er könnte mir jetzt keinen Taxi finden. Was wahrscheinlich daran lag, dass einfach gerade keins da war, aber es war so ein kurzer Moment, wo er sich nicht so richtig schlüssig war, ob er jetzt eins für mich gefunden hat oder nicht. Aber grundsätzlich funktioniert das.
Na gut, ich hab Taxi benutzt und ich hab mich mit dem Taxifahrer drüber unterhalten und er meinte, es fahren so in München 40 Stück damit rum zur Zeit und es wären wohl immer mehr. Nach wohl auch ungefähr so um die 40. Insofern sollte das schon relativ gut funktionieren, zumindest wenn du im City-Bereich bist. Also München ist ja jetzt auch nicht so groß.
Welches My Taxi ist es denn? Da gibt es ein bisschen zu viele.
Das ist das Gelbe.
Da gibt es auch Gelbe ganz viele.
Das, was nur My Taxi heißt.
Zwei von oben, ja?
Der ist schon mit den Bewertungen.
Anyway, wir waren bei Siri.
Dann hat man ja gar nicht mehr die sexy Stimme von der Taxi-Zentrale.
Ich hatte noch nie eine sexy Stimme am Telefon.
Aber so was.
Ach, wirklich?
Bei welcher Taxi-Zentrale rufst du denn an?
Bist du sicher, es ist nicht eine Porn-Nummer?
261026. Würfelfunk, glaube ich.
Hallo, hier ist dein Nachtaxi. Wenn ich es dir direkt besorgen soll, drück die 1.
Wer muss eben keine 1 drücken?
Oder wenn du eine andere Nummer schieben willst, drück die 2.
Okay, wir haben es verstanden.
Naja, ein bisschen kreativ sein. Wäre vielleicht auch mal eine Nummer.
Also ich meine.
Ja, schon klar. Verstanden.
Entschuldigung, ich habe mir aus meiner Porno-Zeit ein bisschen Humor ruhig behalten, den nicht jeder nachvollziehen kann, aber hatten Spaß.
Keine weiteren Kommentare.
Keine weiteren Fragen, aber ja.
Gut, MyTaxi. Wie sind wir da jetzt gerade hingekommen?
Über Siri.
Über Siri sind wir nicht zum Taxi gekommen, sondern zum MyTaxi gekommen. Ja, aber du kannst nicht ein Taxi mit Siri bestellen.
Ich glaube, in Amerika geht alles.
In Amerika geht alles.
Das ist das Land der unbegrenzten Möglichkeiten.
Auf jeden Fall kannst du dich mit einem Taxi-Dienst vermitteln lassen. Das geht, garantiert.
Kann man mit Siri Programme starten?
Ist es creepy? Ist es creepy? Oder denkst du dir, ach, scheiß drauf, super?
Wenn es besser funktionieren würde, würde ich mir denken, ach, scheiß drauf. Also es funktioniert halt nicht perfekt. Es muss halt perfekt funktionieren.
Nee, es ist creepy. Null. Du hast kein Problem damit, mit deinem Telefon zu reden.
Ich hab kein Problem damit, mit meinem Telefon zu reden.
Und du hast kein Problem damit, dass es irgendwie so mit Kekken, Antworten dazu kommt und so. Hast du schon mal Witze gerissen? Ich meine, kann man mit Siri auch einfach mal so Konversation führen?
Das hängt davon ab, wie bekifft man ist.
Habt ihr diesen schönen Blogpost gesehen, wo jemand Eliza und Siri miteinander hat reden lassen?
Nee, ich hab bloß zwei Siris, die sich miteinander unterhalten haben.
Das ist glaube ich eher tranig, aber dieses Eliza-Siri-Ding, das fand ich wirklich großartig.
Ich möchte noch jemanden, dass ich nochmal vorführe, wie, will noch jemand noch mal Siri vorgeführt haben? Achso, das brauchen wir aber eigentlich nicht, oder?
Hatten wir schon. Alles ist wirklich super hier. Hello, I'm Eliza.
Gibst du nicht als Audio?
Na, Eliza ist ja nicht Audio. Also du müsstest sozusagen da noch so Text-to-Speech draus machen und dann original Siri rein machen. Also wirklich gute Sachen drin. Eliza, how are you today? What would you like to discuss? Siri, I'm fine, thanks for asking. Und Eliza, how long have you been fine? Thanks for asking. Eliza, you're not really talking about me, are you? Siri, should I look for business with that name? Eliza, I don't care about names. So geht das hier weiter. Das ist wirklich großartig. Weil diese Methode von Eliza ja auch immer so ist, wenn es unklar ist, und die Gegenseite versucht so ein bisschen reinzupoken, dann wird das irgendwie einfach genommen und in Frage gestellt und dreht einfach die ganze Zeit über diesen Spieß um. Das funktioniert natürlich super bei so einem System, das immer so auf Antworten ausgerichtet ist.
Also das ist halt bei... Das ist tatsächlich, also nicht creepy, aber das nervt ein bisschen bei sie. Also zum einen, die waren ja irgendwann zwischendurch down, so wie sich das so für Apple gehört, und war der Server plötzlich weg. Und ich wollte tatsächlich genau...
Hast du da was gesteckt gerade?
Ja, der Stecker ist gerade rausgefallen und jetzt hab ich's wieder reingesteckt.
Deswegen hat's da die ganze Zeit geknackt.
Und genau zu dem Zeitpunkt wollte ich Siri nutzen. Und dann kam da halt nicht sofort eine Nachricht, sondern so von wegen, Hallo, Siri ist down. Bitte benutze ich später nochmal. Sondern es kommt halt so was so, ich sag Siri irgendwas, nimmt das auf, rödelt, rödelt, rödelt. Irgendwann so plötzlich, ich konnte dich leider nicht verstehen, bitte versuche es noch einmal. Und so, was war denn jetzt?
Das haben sie jetzt geändert, ne?
Ich glaub mittlerweile haben sie es geändert, dass sie wenigstens bessere Antworten von sich geben. Offensichtlich haben sie mit dem Zustand überhaupt nicht gerechnet, dass ihr Dienst mal down ist. Und das war sehr ätzend.
Da war letztens so eine Meldung, dass sie es geändert haben, dass Siri jetzt einem höflich mithält, dass sie einem gerade nicht helfen kann.
Genau.
Und das ist glaube ich hier mein Knacken.
Ja, der Stuhl knackt auch hier noch.
Ist dein Stecker fest?
Ja, das hatte ich eigentlich schon mal geprüft. Da ist alles schön drin.
Was ist das hier braun?
Bei dir sind wohl ein paar Stecker locker.
Das wollen nicht alle Stecker in der Buchse haben.
Das ist völlig strange. Das ist nur immer irgendwie bei dir und Max und dann auch gleichzeitig.
Was ist denn hier nur mit dem Link? Wollt ihr nicht mal klicken oder wie du hast?
Welchen Link denn jetzt?
Vorletzten.
Twitterback?
Wir reden über andere Sachen hier.
Ich dachte, er hat da hingezeigt und meinte, klick mal.
Ich klick doch selber.
Ich klick doch nicht auf jeden Link, den mir hier folgen würde. Wo wir aber keine Themen mehr haben, über die wir reden sollen, müssen wir nicht auf jeden Link klicken. Aber wir können auch einfach aufhören, wenn wir alles durchhaben. Ich hab hier nur noch eine Notiz. Ich auch. Du hattest noch was zum Thema Finanz-Ups.
Ich hatte auch noch den Jawbone-Up. Finanzen.
Finanz-Up kann ich da noch was machen.
Jetzt geht es richtig los. Jetzt ist Tim fertig, jetzt machen wir erst mal.
Ok, ihr hattet euch ja auch schon mal über Finanz-Ups unterhalten. Ich benutze zurzeit Unity Budget. Großer Floor da dran.
Plattform?
Unabhängig, soweit ich weiß, weil es läuft auf Air.
Na großartig.
Ich finde es aber großartig, weil es halt nicht wie die normalen Finanz-Software-Ansätze so funktioniert. Sodass du ein Budget festlegst und am Ende des Monats wird es resettet. Nein, in diesem Fall kannst du das Budget halt übernehmen auf den nächsten Monat. Wenn du halt irgendwas übrig hast oder wenn du in einem Budget-Raum zu viel ausgegeben hast. Und so siehst du halt entweder, dass du Schulden hast, weil du einfach zu viel ausgegeben hast. Oder wie sich dein Geld in einer bestimmten Kategorie anhäuft und du halt sehen kannst, dass du da vielleicht überhaupt nicht so viel Geld brauchst oder was angespart hast. Und du siehst, wie dein Geld wächst.
Oder sinkt.
Oder sinkt. In meinem Fall eher wächst.
Was ich ganz gut finde.
Wachsen finde ich super. Aber damit kannst du halt zusehen, dass du deine Schulden zum Beispiel abbaust, was für die Amerikaner wahrscheinlich total wichtig ist. Und die haben super, super Support auf der Seite. Die haben geile Videos. Die haben extra irgendwelche Tutorials und Meetings, wo du online mitmachen kannst und deine Fragen stellen kannst und so weiter. Also da unterstützen die einen richtig gut, um in die Software da reinzukommen, weil ich glaube, es ist nicht ganz so einfach, weil es halt ein anderer Ansatz ist. Ja, aber ich bin einfach total begeistert davon. Es gibt eine iPhone ab, genau. Die musst du allerdings dann immer über Wi-Fi mit der App auf dem Mac syncen. Bin auch nicht sicher, ob sie das noch einbauen. Was auch noch nicht ganz so toll ist, ist Import, wenn du jetzt von irgendeinem Konto oder so Geld importieren willst, da ist importiert nur Quicken, Open Financial, Exchange und CSV, und CSV aber nur in einem bestimmten Format, was sie dir vorgeben. Das heißt, ich musste mir jetzt erstmal mit Objective-C schnell was zusammen schreiben, was mir meine Bankdaten rüberpasst in deren Format, damit ich es importieren kann.
Also der eigentliche Clou hier ist, dass man quasi so Trends, Ausgaben, Trends gleich visualisiert und dass man sieht, wie du gerade Geld ausgibst, wenn das so weitergeht, dann würde es sich so und so entwickeln, versteht das richtig?
Ja, du siehst halt auch ganz genau, wieviel du noch Budget in einem bestimmten Bereich übrig hast. Warte mal, ich kann ja das mal hier zeigen, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist das einfacher. Du hast natürlich deine ganz normalen Konten, die du anlegen kannst, wo du sagen kannst, hier das habe ich ausgegeben und hier in dieser Kategorie habe ich was ausgegeben und wieviel und so viel ist reingekommen. Und du hast deine Budgetansicht, die lädt jetzt gerade und dann kannst du halt für einen Monat festlegen, wofür du ausgeben willst und siehst halt sofort, ok so und so viel habe ich zu viel ausgegeben und so viel ist reingekommen und du kannst das von Monat zu Monat rübernehmen.
Und wie kriegt man da Daten rein?
Ja, CSV zum Beispiel. Also sie empfehlen allerdings, dass du von Null anfängst, das heißt, dass du mit frischen Daten reingehst, dass du nicht irgendwie anfängst, aus irgendwelchen anderen Programmen was zu importieren, sondern du sollst echt einen clean Start machen. Vielleicht einfach mal anschauen, die haben 14 Tage Testlizenz irgendwie, was mir eigentlich nicht so wirklich ausgereicht hat und dann habe ich es einfach mal gekauft und ich habe es bis jetzt nicht bereut.
Kann ich ja noch was gleich zu dem Thema sagen. Ich habe ein neues, genauer gegenteiliges Problem von deinem gehabt, nämlich mein Geld wurde auf dem Konto nicht mehr, sondern ich hatte das Gefühl, es wurde von Monat zu Monat weniger. Mit anderen Worten, ich gebe etwas mehr aus, als ich eingenommen habe.
Da hast du ja erstmal ein Programm gekauft.
Einen Tag später hat mich jemand angehauen, ob ich nicht sein Programm testen möchte. Finanzblick HD heißt das, was sich quasi genau auch so um Budgets kümmert. Was ist jetzt iPad? Die importieren so von allen Banken. Das ist eigentlich so dieses, was auch iOutbank zum Beispiel hat. Sie kriegen auch dieses DKB-Kreditkartenkonto rein. Ich habe da alles. Postbank, DKB, zweimal. PayPal habe ich da drinne und das kriegen die alles rein. Das ist auch dafür gedacht, dass man so ein bisschen einen Überblick darüber behält, was ich bei iOutbank total vermisse. Nämlich so, wie viel Geld habe ich eingenommen diesen Monat? Wie viel Geld habe ich ausgegeben? Wofür habe ich es ausgegeben? Und das haben die. Man kann jetzt direkt sehen, wie viel Geld hatte ich vor einem Monat? Wie viel Geld habe ich jetzt? Wann ist es eingebrochen? Es hat so ein Regelsystem dahinter, mit dem sie Buchungen automatisch kategorisieren. Also wenn in der Überweisung drin steht Geburtstag, dann wird das, wenn es drauf geht, als Geschenk gebucht. Wenn irgendwo Gehalt drin steht, dann ist es eine Gehaltsabbuchung. Wenn Finanzamt drin steht, dann wird es für Steuern gewesen sein. Also eine halbwegs brauchbare Vorkategorisierung vor. Was leider ganz furchtbar funktioniert, sind Barabhebungen. Das Interface ist leider nicht so toll. Das ist der Teil, den ich sehr nachteilig finde. Ich finde es echt komplizierter, einen Überblick zu behalten. Wenn man irgendwann mal die Daten gefunden hat, die man sucht, dann ist es tatsächlich ziemlich angenehm. Man kann so sehen, wofür ich mein Geld ausgegeben habe, wie viel gebe ich eigentlich. Es gibt hier eine eigene Kategorie Ausgabe für iTunes. Die hat mir doch einen kleinen milden Schock verpasst, als ich mal gesehen habe, wie viel ich jeden Monat für iTunes ausgebe. Also was da bei Apple landet, ist schon ganz ordentlich. Und kostet auch nicht so die Welt. Kostet irgendwie 5 Euro oder so was?
Aber du hast es dann nur dort drauf.
Ich hab's nur dort drauf, das reicht mir total.
Nee, ich brauch das schon auf mehreren Preisen. Ich hätte das Ding auch mal kurz im Test.
Dieses Finanzblick?
Das ist nicht immer nur du, Betatessa. Ja, wobei ich zugeben muss, dass ich an diesem User-Interface enorm abgeprallt bin.
Das könnte durchaus...
Und ich auch generell finde, wenn es um so was wie Kategorisierung von deiner Scheiße geht, das muss sinken. Also, dass einfach die Zeit mit Datenbestände nur auf einem einzigen Device festhalten, das ist einfach vorbei jetzt. Das kann man sich jetzt einfach gar nicht mehr leisten. So ein Software von vornherein mit dieser Einschränkung auszuliefern.
Ich brauch das nur auf dem iPad. Was soll ich damit auf dem Mac?
Ja, da könnte ich dir so viel erklären, warum man das auf dem Mac braucht.
Und vor allen Dingen kannst du halt keine Barsachen... Also, wenn du irgendwelche Bar-Ausgaben hast...
Das stimmt, aber ehrlich gesagt, das würde ich eh nicht tun. Also, ich merk mir nicht, wofür ich mein Bargeld ausgegeben habe. Das ist bei mir...
Aber beim iPhone würde ich das vielleicht schon machen.
Also, das ist bei mir... Also, ich kenne Freunde, die das probiert haben und dafür kenne ich mich im Laufe der letzten 30 Jahre doch gut genug zu wissen, dass funktioniert bei mir keine 2 Sekunden lang.
Aber wenn du jetzt wirklich in einer Schuldensituation bist und wenn du generell wirklich mit einem echt knappen Budget am Start bist, also wenn du nicht so weißer Scheiß drauf, oh, was, ich hab 2000 Euro auf iTunes ausgegeben diesen Monat, hoppala, ja?
Na ja, okay, also wenn...
Ist auch nicht jedermanns Leid.
Es mag nicht für jedermann gut sein, wenn man so wie ich tendenziell dazu neigt... Also ich komme aus einer Situation, wo ich noch vor zwei Jahren oder drei Jahren in der Situation war, oh, Konto voll, toll, oh, Konto leer, doof, und den Zustand dazwischen nicht kannte und jetzt so langsam erst so den Überblick über meine Ausgabengewinne damit eigentlich auch ganz gut gefahren bin und jetzt so was habe, wo ich mal sehe, sozusagen wie viel geht denn eigentlich so für Miete und für dieses ganze Zeug drauf und wie viel... Also welches Geld geht in welchen Kategorien und ich dafür keine Arbeit leisten muss, weil ich das auf Dauer nicht tun würde und gerade bei Bargeld besteht bei mir wirklich nicht den Hauch einer Chance, dass ich da irgendwie einen Überblick bewahren könnte. Und darum ist das... also bin ich damit erstmal glücklich, wenn es diese Kategorisierung hinkriegt. Wenn sie das Interface noch besser machen, das muss besser werden.
Ich kippe jetzt gleich um, Vermütigkeit, aber ich glaube, wir haben noch ein Thema zu dem Thema.
Noch ein Thema zu dem Thema?
War da nicht was mit Einschlafen und Aufwachen?
Ah, Schlafen. Gute Überleitung. Ich hab den WakeMate. Das ist ein Sleep-Tracking-Device. Das benutze ich jetzt schon seit fast einem Jahr.
Das ist genau was?
Ja, es funktioniert erstaunlich gut.
Das weckt im Zimmer auf, wenn er einpennt.
Das ist so ein Armband, ein Stoff-Armband mit einem Bluetooth-Device drin. Machst du dir halt um, stellst den Wecker auf ein iPhone. Also die haben es für das iPhone. Ja.
Also so ein bisschen wie so ein Schweißband.
Das trifft es ganz gut. Du stellst es halt über das iPhone. Ich sage jetzt einfach mal nur iPhone. Es gibt es auch für andere Plattformen. Für das iPad? Bevor du es kaufst, musst du dich entscheiden, für welche Plattform du das Ding benutzen willst. Also, wenn du eins für iPhone und iPad kaufst, dann funktioniert das nicht auf dem BlackBerry. Und auch nicht für Android. Zumindest war das mit der ersten Version so. Ja, es hat Bluetooth drin. Du stellst halt deine Uhrzeit, wann du aufstehen möchtest und hast dann irgendwie so ein 30-Minuten-Window-Plus oder Minus und dann versucht er halt, die beste Uhrzeit rauszufinden, in der du gerade in so einer Schlafphase bist, also in so einer leichten Schlafphase und dich dort aufweckt, damit du am nächsten Morgen nicht total k.o.
bist. Auf Basis von was? Von deiner Bewegung?
Genau, auf Basis von deiner Bewegung.
Ach.
Das funktioniert echt gut. Die erste Version, die ich hatte, war irgendwie so buggy.
Kannst du immer ausschlafen?
Nee, ich kann nicht ausschlafen. Ich hab ja einen geregelten Tagesablauf.
Deswegen frag ich ja gerade, inwiefern hilft dir das dann noch, auch wenn es eh klar ist, wenn du aufwachen musst?
Du hast ja einen halben Stunde Rhythmus. Und du hast es ja manchmal, wenn du, wenn ein Wecker loitert, du aus einer Tiefschlaßphase rausgerissen wirst. Und da bist du total KO den ganzen Tag. Eigentlich allen Menschen. Und wenn er dich in so einer Phase erwischt, wo du relativ leichten Schlaf hast, dann bist du den ganzen Tag fit. Und dementsprechend versucht er dich in so einer Phase zu wecken. Und über den Schlafphasenrhythmus kommst du so alle, ich glaube 20, 30 Minuten in so einen Rhythmus rein. Also in so eine leichte Phase. Und dort kannst du halt gut geweckt werden. Und das versucht er halt über die Bewegungen festzustellen. Krass. Funktioniert.
Und wie weckt er dich dann?
In dem Fall von einem Wake-Mate leutet das iPhone. Das ja.
Also die abmacht sich dann so?
Genau, die macht sich bemerkbar.
Und dann kriegst du Ton. Aber es gibt jetzt kein Vibrationselement in diesem Teil? Nein, sondern es ist nur ein Beschleunigungs-Sensor und Bluetooth drin. Aber Bluetooth muss da sozusagen an sein und gepährt sein und so.
Der ist aber auch nicht die ganze Zeit in Verbindung.
Erst dann, wenn du sagst, wann er dich wecken soll.
Genau, in dieser Zeitphase, in dieser halben Stunde oder du kannst auch einstellen, dass es 20 Minuten, halbe Stunde oder was auch immer ist. In der aktiviert sich das Bluetooth dann wieder. Wie gesagt, die erste Version hat nicht so wahnsinnig geil funktioniert. Inzwischen wurde es mir von der Firma ausgetauscht, das Ding. Jetzt funktioniert es echt traumhaft. Ich muss aber dazu sagen, dass die Firma mit ihrem Support und ihrem Handling von den Usern echt beschissen ist. Also das als Vorwarnung, die sind echt nicht cool. Wenn ihr irgendeine Reklamation habt, dann auf jeden Fall mit Rückschein und sonst was schicken, weil ansonsten die verlangen, dass ihr Beweis, dass ihr das Gerät zurückgeschickt habt für einen Austausch. Das ist eine amerikanische Firma und die schicken dir das dann halt.
Also du hast das in den USA gekauft?
Es gibt keine International Backup. Man kann eine Sign-Up-List machen und wenn sie wieder Geräte für einen internationalen Vertrieb haben.
Ja, ich glaube ich war über ein Jahr auf der Warteliste. Ich hab das gleich am Anfang gekauft, als sie es angekündigt haben und ich hab echt ewig drauf gewartet.
Gab es nicht so eine App auch ohne dieses Wristband? Ja, aber das funktioniert nicht so wahnsinnig geil.
Also für mich hat es nicht funktioniert, weil meine Matratze ist so hart und deswegen bewegt sich das nicht so wahnsinnig geil. So, jetzt kommt aber, oder ist schon rausgekommen, das Jawbone Up, was noch ein bisschen mehr trackt und es hat Vibrationsalarm drin.
Das wollte ich eigentlich zum Weihnachten verschenken.
Also Firma heißt Jawbone und das Produkt heißt Up.
Also Jawbone kennt man vielleicht daher die Stellen so relativ hochwertige Bluetooth-Headsets und sowas.
Das funktioniert im Prinzip nach dem gleichen Prinzip. Hat auch eine iPhone-App. Und man kann aber, soll es den ganzen Tag tragen, ist es wasserdicht, also bis ein Meter. Und man soll es den ganzen Tag tragen, weil es auch mittrackt, wie viel man sich bewegt hat. Und man kann sich Reminders setzen lassen. Okay, du müsstest immer wieder aufstehen, um dich ein bisschen zu bewegen, zu strecken. Und man kann auch mit der iPhone-App mittracken, was man so gegessen hat. Ich weiß nicht, wofür das gut sein soll.
Was man gegessen hat?
Ja, mit Fotos machen. Du sollst Fotos machen. So wahrscheinlich, um zu sehen, dass man einfach zu viel gefuttert hat. Und um zu sehen, wie man sich danach fühlt. Und dass man danach vielleicht ein bisschen fertig ist.
Jetzt hat es einen, man soll sich bewegen?
Ja, du kannst dir Reminders einstellen, dass du dich mal wieder bewegen sollst.
Angeblich ist es ja gut für den Rücken, wenn man halt acht Stunden, man kann schon acht Stunden sitzen, man muss aber, angeblicher, ich glaube auch praktisch, dass man sich immer mal wieder bewegt. Und vor allem einfach nur auch seine Sitzposition ändern wäre schon super. Man muss ja teilweise nicht mehr aufstehen, aber die ganze Zeit in der gleichen Sitzposition ist halt scheiße. Und das wird das Ding halt sagen, wenn es merkt, du bewegst dich ja gar nicht, so, dann mal Arsch drehen.
Was ich ziemlich geil daran finde, ist die, da ist so eine, wie man es verbindet mit dem iPhone, und zwar über den Kopfhörerausgang. Man stopft das oben in den Kopfhörerausgang rein.
Das wäre der alte Audio-Serial-Hack.
Genau, und dann ist da wahrscheinlich irgendwie ein kleines Modem drinnen, und damit werden die Daten ausgetauscht.
Ach so, verstehe, da ist so ein Deckelchen dran, das heißt, du hast da kein Bluetooth-Kram, man muss Bluetooth nicht anhaben?
Nee, man muss nur USB dran haben zum Laden, weil hin und her muss das geladen werden.
Da, bei dem glaube ich nur alle 9 Tage, bei dem WakeMate alle 2 Tage. Also je nachdem, wie viel du schläfst, wenn du so 8 Stunden, 9 Stunden die Nacht schläfst, musst du es alle 2 Tage laden. Wenn du weniger schläfst, dann halt weniger. Was ich beim WakeMate total cool finde, was der wahrscheinlich auch, der Durborn auch hat, du kriegst einen Sleep-Score. Wie gut hast du die Nacht geschlafen?
Ja, das gibt es da oben. Da kann man sich zeigen lassen, wie man geschlafen hat.
Das ist echt lustig. Sleep Quality 91.
Und schon mal gemerkt, dass wenn du so richtig blau warst und richtig 10 Stunden gekomert hast, dass du sagst, voll super gepennt.
Und bist du dir sicher, dass das nicht nur Einbildungen ist? Nach dem Motto, da steht, du hast gut geschlafen und dann...
Das ist wirklich bei mir von mehreren Faktoren abhängig. Von wegen Lautstärke, Helligkeit, was ich den Abend vorher gemacht hab. Und du kannst halt so Texts vergeben und kannst es dann auf der Internetseite vergleichen nach den Texts, was sich da geändert hat. Also sehr lustiges Ding. Und beim WakeMate kann man es auf jeden Fall auch exportieren als CSV. Da müsste man jetzt mal gucken, was es für andere Apps gibt, die da irgendwelche lustigen Tracks draus machen könnten. Also auf jeden Fall mal anschauen. Ich find diesen ganzen Schlafkram super interessant.
Ja, das klingt cool.
Man kann auch gegen Freunde schlafen.
Wo kann man denn?
Es gibt auch so ein...
Challenges.
Ich glaub, das ist mehr für Joggen gehen und sowas gedacht, dass man so gegen Freunde antritt und dass das dann mit trackt.
Ach echt? Also wo es früher Voli-Vu-Couche-Amec-Mars hieß, das ist jetzt irgendwie...
Ja, exakt.
Möchtest du mit mir wett schlafen?
Genau.
Aber es sind ja Zeiten... Kaufen?
Wo?
Also Jobbauen? Nee, da musst du auf den roten Button dort oben klicken.
Ich glaub, die gibt's in Deutschland auch nicht, oder?
Doch, die gibt's schon.
Mittlerweile gibt's die schon?
Ja, werden Ende November...
Ist currently backordert.
Genau.
In drei bis vier Wochen.
Werden Ende November die schwarzen ausgeliefert in Deutschland, wenn du sie jetzt bestellst.
Die schwarzen?
Ende November?
Die schwarzen. Ich hab natürlich das Bright Silver bestellt und ich weiß noch nicht, wann meins dann kommt. Na, ich bin nicht so der Schwarz-Fan.
Ich wüsste hier... Oh, man kann im Augenblick keine andere Farbe als Schwarz auswählen? Ach man, nervt doch nicht!
Also es gibt doch eine deutsche Seite. Frag mich jetzt, äh warte auf der Seite...
Wie lange hast du dein Ding schon?
Das Wake-Mate-Teil, das hab ich, ich glaub seit Januar oder Februar. Also schon echt ein Stück.
Und benutzt es immer noch jeden Tag?
Jeden Tag. Ich hab's jetzt auch wieder dabei, das kommt immer ins Gepäck. Ich schleif das immer mit mir rum und da gibt's eigentlich keine Ausrede, warum ich das nachts nicht verwenden sollte.
Wenn du halt so dicke Arme hast, da steht wieder...
Und die kosten 100 Dollar, ja?
Das kostet 100 Dollar. Der Wakemade war glaube ich 60 Dollar.
Instocked Chips in 3-4 Weeks.
Der Jawbone Up hat allerdings horrende Versandkosten, irgendwie 15 oder 16 Euro.
Also noch ein halbes Jahr warten und dann kriegt man es im halben Preis bei Amazon oder so.
Na mir würde kaufen, hier legen wir einfach zusammen.
Na wenn es bis Weihnachten ankommt, dann ist das kein Problem.
Ich glaube Medium wird für euch nicht reichen. Medium habe ich bestellt.
Hier steht, dass es die beim Apple Retail Store gibt. Vielleicht gibt es die auch in unseren Apple Stores.
Die sind ausverkauft, zumindest in Amerika. Du bist jetzt gerade auf der amerikanischen Seite und auf den amerikanischen war es glaube ich innerhalb von 4 Stunden ausverkauft. Die haben sich mehr oder weniger drum gekloppt.
Wo ist denn die deutsche Seite dann bitte?
Da unten ist jemand ganz unter, da unten ist eine Flagge. Wobei die deutsche Seite sah für mich exakt genauso aus, wie die amerikanische.
Na, die ist ein bisschen anders. So, wenn du auf Shoppen gehst, sieht es anders aus.
Also ich bin jetzt hier auf der Shopping-Seite bei Jarbone und jetzt soll ich es in den Continue to Checkout, jetzt bin ich auf der amerikanischen.
Da steht es.
Auf der deutschen Seite. Das einzige, was auf Englisch ist, auf Deutsch ist es alle rechte Vorbehalte unten.
Gerät und ab zur Zeit nur in englischer Sprache verfügbar.
Ja, ich glaube, das wird jetzt kein Stern. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, warum das Armband in Englisch sein sollte, aber okay.
Englisch ist schwarz wahrscheinlich. Hier ist eine Anleitung, die Schnut eng um deine Handgelenk anlegen und dort markieren, wo die beiden Enden überkreuzen. Das hätte auch schief gehen können.
200 Euro für die Jawbone Jambox. Achso, und das ist, ich verstehe, weil die ja noch mehr Zeug machen.
Die stellen auch noch andere Geräte her.
Die sind echt bekannt für Bluetooth-Headsets.
Da sind sie echt schon nie auf dem Markt.
Ich warte erstmal ab.
Super Tipp, ich glaube, jetzt können wir es hier auch einpacken, wir sind schon lange noch auf Sendung, Freunde.
Was ich noch ganz kurz nachliefern will? Kleinigkeit, der Raspberry Pi, den wir schon letztens und vorletztens hatten, da ist jetzt seit vorgestern das finale Board-Layout fertig und das Ding soll so groß werden wie eine Visitenkarte. Das heißt, man hat später einen Linux-Computer auf dem Formfaktor von einer Visitenkarte. Das ist halt so ein totales Mini-Ding, aber ich meine, so ein kleines Linux auf einer Visitenkartengröße.
Aber du hast ja nur Ethernet und USB, ne? Nee, SATA wäre schon sehr geil, aber...
So ein kleines Netatalk drauf mit ein bisschen Storage, Backup.
Ich will mal... ja, dann bin ich auch noch was shameless pluggen. Hier ein Arbeitskollege von mir hat ja ein Network Attached Storage selber gebaut. Also selber ein Gehäuse entworfen, das selber fräsen lassen aus Edelstahl und so weiter. Evercube heißt die Seite, also evercube.be.
Die Domains gehen langsam aus.
Genau. Und er hat auch eine wunderschöne Seite gebaut. Er hat sich sozusagen hier so ein Kit, also du kannst sozusagen das Kit bei ihm bekommen. Und wenn du jetzt mal wartest, da kommen halt 5 2,5 Zoll Platten rein.
2,5 Zoll.
Das Ding ist halt auch echt kompakt sozusagen. Genau. Ist halt erstmal für Kleinen gebaut. Er überlegt noch, ob er mal eine größere Variante baut. Er wollte halt so eine richtig kleine oder möglichst kleine, total leise Box. Hat sich da halt echt irgendwie Gedanken gemacht und das gebaut und hat jetzt da wohl irgendwie auch schon die ersten Kids verkauft nach Übersee.
Was hat das für ein Interface?
Also eZata in dem Fall glaube ich vor allen Dingen. Und er hat halt da auch dieses, irgendein Mini-Board halt unten reingebaut. Ist halt auch ein Linux drauf, also du kannst dann auch nochmal irgendwie Scheiß drauflaufen lassen, theoretisch hin und jetzt. Das fand ich schon ganz cool. Ich weiß nicht, Netzwerk geht glaube ich auch, aber ich bin mir grad nicht sicher. Ja, aber könnt ihr euch ja mal anschauen. Ist auch, ich weiß nicht, ob er es mittlerweile schon hat. Ich glaube er hat schon die Google Sketch-Up, also er hat die CAD-Files und so da auch auf der Seite. Das ist halt ein Open-Source-Design. Da oben gibt es irgendwie auch dann in diesem ZIP sozusagen alles an Anleitungen und Files, was man braucht, um das komplett selber zu bauen. Also insofern ein ganz cooles Projekt. Also das Board, was er da benutzt hat und so, das ist jetzt alles nicht super high-performance, aber nichtsdestotrotz so für so einen kleinen, leisen Storage-Würfel, der irgendwo in der Ecke leise seine Daten frisst.
Ich find's nicht.
O2 hat uns wieder eins sehr geschubst.
Genau. Open Source-Hardware-Projekt.
429.
Für alle zusammen genau.
Mit Platten.
Von einem Tim.
Von einem Tim, genau. Tim Lawson-Ding.
Mit Platten?
Nee, ich glaube nicht.
Mit oder ohne Platten?
Mit oder ohne Platten.
Er kann aber auch weniger.
Okay, wir reißen das Thema jetzt nicht auf.
Das hatten wir auch schon.
Der Drobo haben wir auch schon.
Das ganze Nass-Thema ist ein einziger Fail. Du findest ihn gut?
Ich muss nach Hause.
Ich muss wiederkommen.
Ich finde es gut. Ich finde es gut. Bei deinen Seiten, die sehen ja immer ganz gut aus. Ich habe keine Seite mehr. Hier dein Bitcoin-Miner.
Ach so, das ist nicht mein Design.
Ja, kein Problem, ich habe noch eine Tüte Wattebausch. Damit können wir uns jetzt gleich ein bisschen beschmeißen.
Wie immer nach der Sendung.
Aber vorher entlassen wir noch die höhere Aussatzpflicht, uns sich das Drama auch noch zu geben. Und insofern, würde ich sagen, haben wir es gerissen. Winnie, vielen Dank für deine Teilnahme.
Gerne.
Auch wenn du Google-Pseudonyme angezeigt hast. Das ist ja schon ein kleiner Karma-Drop hier.
Ja, ich hätte wohl dich auch ganz doll gedischt.
Solltest du nicht in deinen Lebenslauf schreiben.
Wird man schon gleich mal gedisst, aber so ist das. Manche Leute sehen es anders. Ja, aber dafür hat sie uns hier auch die Wachmarte gebracht und hier Wake Maid. Ja, Wachmarte macht glücklichen Schlaf.
Mach mal ein Chat nach vorne. Hier gibt es gerade wieder so Danke und sowas. Weil der Chat macht nicht nur der.
Ha, siehst du mal, gucke mal hier. Der Chat umarmt dich, Winnie. Das ist alles gar nicht so schlimm.
Das sind übrigens gar nicht die ganzen Chat-Namen, die.
Wir schmeißen euch jetzt raus. Genau dafür, dass ihr Pseudonimie benutzt habt.
Tschüss! Ich geh!